I have to remind honorable members that
copies of the budget resolutions will be
available to them from the vote office
in members lobby at the end of the
Chancellor's statement and of course
online
it might also be helpful for some people
who are following our proceedings to
know that British sign language
interpretation of the statement which
will continue until the end of the
speech of the spokesman for the Scottish
national party is available to watch on
parliamentlive.tv advert uh live
subtitling will also be available for
the Chancellor's speech and the
remainder of today's debate I hardly
need remind honorable members but I will
do for good measure that they may not
make interventions during the chancellor
statement nor indeed during the replies
of the leader of the opposition
or even of the spokesman for the
Scottish national party
[Applause]
[Music]
Madam Deputy speaker in the face of
enormous challenges I report today on a
British economy which is proving the
doubters wrong
[Music]
in the Autumn we took difficult
decisions to deliver stability and sound
money
since mid-october 10-year guilt rates
have fallen debt servicing costs are
down mortgage rates are lower and
inflation has peaked the international
monetary fund
says our approach means the UK economy
is on the right track
but we remain Vigilant and will not
hesitate to take whatever steps are
necessary for economic stability
the office for Budget responsibility
forecasts that because of changing
International factors and the measures I
take
the UK will not now enter a technical
recession this year
[Applause]
they forecast we will meet the prime
minister's priorities to have inflation
reduce debt and get the economy growing
We are following the plan and the plan
is working
yeah
but that's not all we've done
in the face of a cost of living crisis
we have demonstrated our values by
protecting struggling families with a
two and a half thousand pound energy
price guarantee one-off support and the
upbrating of benefits with inflation
taken together these measures are worth
94 billion pounds over this year and
next one of the largest support packages
in Europe that average is madam Deputy
speaker over 3 300 pounds of cost of
living help for every household in the
country
today we deliver the next part of our
plan a budget for growth not just the
growth that comes when you emerge from a
downturn but long-term sustainable
Healthy Growth
pays for our NHS and schools finds jobs
for young people and provides a safety
net for older people all whilst making
our country one of the most prosperous
in the world
and that is why
is one of the prime minister's five
priorities for our country I deliver
that today by removing obstacles that
stop businesses investing
by tackling labor shortages that stop
them recruiting by breaking down
barriers that stop people working and by
harnessing British Ingenuity to make us
a science and technology superpower
I start with the forecasts produced by
Richard Hughes and his team at the
independent office for Budget
responsibility who I thank for their
diligent work
they have looked in detail at the prime
minister's economic priorities
the first of those is to halve inflation
inflation destroys the value of
hard-earned pay deters investment and
ferments Industrial strife this
government remains steadfast in its
support for the independent monetary
policy committee at the bank of England
as it takes action to return inflation
to the two percent Target
despite continuing Global instability
the obr report today that inflation in
the UK will fall from 10.7 percent in
the final quarter of last year to 2.9
percent by the end of 2023 that is more
than halving inflation hi
yes
High inflation is the high inflation
Madam Deputy speaker is the root cause
of the strikes we've seen in recent
months we will continue to work hard to
settle those disputes but only in a way
that does not fuel inflation
part of the fall in inflation predicted
by the obr happens because of additional
measures I take today
firstly I recognize that even though
wholesale Energy prices have been
falling there is still enormous pressure
on family finances some people remain in
real distress and we should always stand
ready to help when we can so after
listening to representations from Martin
Lewis and other experts I today confirm
that the energy price guarantee will
remain at two and a half thousand pounds
for the next three months
this means the two and a half thousand
pound cap for the typical household will
remain in place when Energy prices
remain high ahead of an expected fall in
prices from July this measure will save
the average family a further 160 pounds
on top of the energy support measures
already announced
the second measure concerns over 4
million households on prepayment meters
they're often the poorest households but
they currently pay more than comparable
customers on Direct debits off gem has
already agreed with suppliers a
temporary suspension to forced
installations of prepayment meters but
today I go further and confirm we will
bring their charges in line with
comparable direct debit charges
under a conservative government the
energy premium paid by our poorest
customers our poorest households is
coming to an end
[Music]
listens to representations from The
Honorable members for East Devon North
Cornwall comb Valley and Central Suffolk
and North Ipswich about the risk to
community facilities especially swimming
pools caused by high costs when times
are tough
such facilities matter even more
so today I am providing a
63. today I am providing a 63 million
pound fund what's up
we want to hear what the chancellor of
the exchequer is actually seeing enough
chance
today I am providing a 63 million pound
fund to keep our public Leisure centers
and pools afloat
I have also heard from my right
honorable friend the Charities Minister
and his secretary of state about the
brilliant work third sector
organizations are doing to help people
struggling in tough times they can often
Reach people in need that Central or
local government cannot so I will give
his Department 100 million pounds to
support thousands of local charities and
community community organizations do
their fantastic work
I also note the personal courage of one
of my predecessors my right honorable
friend from bromsgrove in talking about
the tragedy of suicide and the
importance of preventing it we already
invest a lot in this area but I will
assign an extra 10 million pounds over
the next two years nearly a million
pounds for every year that he's been in
Parliament to help the voluntary sector
play an even bigger role in stopping
families experiencing that intolerable
party
thank you
my penultimate cost of living measure
concerns one of our other most treasured
Community institutions the Great British
pub
in December I extended the alcohol Duty
freeze until the 1st of August after
which duties will go up in line with
inflation in the usual way but today I
will do something that was not possible
when we were in the EU and significantly
increased the generosity of draft relief
so that from the 1st of August the duty
on draft products in pubs will be up to
11 Pence lower than the duty in
supermarkets
it's a differential a conservative
government will maintain as part of a
new brexit pubs guarantee
Madam Deputy speaker
[Music]
Madam Deputy speaker British ale is warm
but the duty on a pint is frozen
and even better even better thanks to
the Windsor framework negotiated by my
right honorable friend the Prime
Minister that change will now apply to
every Pub in Northern Ireland
and finally Madam Deputy speaker I have
heard I've heard the representations
from The Honorable member for
Stoke-on-Trent North my right honorable
friend for Witham and my right humble
friend from South thanet and the Sun
newspaper about the impact on motorists
of the planned 11 Pence rise in fuel
Duty
I noticed the party opposite called for
a freeze on this Duty somehow they
forgot to tell the British people they
voted against every single Fury
because
because inflation remains High I have
decided now is not the right time to
operate fuel Duty with inflation or
increase the duty so here's what I'm
going to do for a further 12 months I'm
going to maintain the 5p cut and I'm
going to freeze fuel Duty 2 that saves
the average driver a hundred pounds next
year and around 200 pounds since the 5p
cut was introduced
[Applause]
Fiona pint all Frozen in today's budget
that doesn't just help families it helps
the economy too because their combined
impact reduces CPI inflation by nearly
three quarters of a percent this year
lowering inflation when it is
particularly High
I now turn to the prime minister's
second priority which is to reduce debt
here too our plan is on track underlying
debt is forecast to be 92.4 percent of
GDP next year then 97.3
94.6
94.8 percent before falling to 94.6 in
2728 we are meeting the debt priority
and with a buffer of six and a half
billion pounds it means we are meeting
our fiscal rule to have debt falling as
a percentage of GDP by the fifth year of
the forecast
as a proportion of GDP our debt remains
lower than the USA Canada France Italy
and Japan
and because of the decisions I take
today and the improved outlook for
public finances underlying debt in five
years time is now forecast to be nearly
three percentage points of GDP lower
than it was in the Autumn that means
more money for our public services and a
lower burden for future Generations
deeply held conservative values which we
put into practice today
at the Autumn statement I also announced
that public sector net borrowing must be
below three percent of GDP over the same
period the obr confirmed today that
we're meeting that rule with a buffer of
39.2 billion in fact our deficit Falls
in every single year of the forecast
with borrowing falling from 5.1 percent
of GDP and 2324 to 3.2 percent to 2.8
percent to 2.2 percent and 1.7 in 27 28.
even better in the final two years of
the forecast our current budget is in
Surplus meaning we only borrow for
investment and not for day-to-day
spending
day-to-day departmental spending will
grow at one percent a year on average in
real terms after 24 25 until the end of
the forecast period Capital plans are
maintained at the same level set at the
Autumn statement we will upgrade tobacco
Duty and we will freeze the gross gaming
due to yield bans we're also maintaining
the starting rate for savings and Isis
subscription limits and will bring
forward a range of measures to tackle
promoters of tax avoidance schemes
Madam Deputy speaker taken together
today's measures lead to a slightly
lower overall tax burden for the rest of
the parliament compared to the obr's
Autumn forecast other parties run out of
money but a conservative government is
reducing borrowing and improving our
public fund finances
[Applause]
by doing so by doing so we are on track
to have inflation get debt falling and
grow our economy which I turn to next
growth Madam Deputy speaker is the prime
minister's third priority and the focus
of today's budget
thirteen years ago we inherited an
economy that had crashed
but since
[Music]
they might want to listen to this they
might want to listen to this because
since 2010
we've grown more than major countries
like France Italy or Japan about the
same as Europe's largest economy Germany
we've halved unemployment we've cut
inequality we've reduced the number of
worthless households by one million
[Applause]
for the first time ever because of rises
in tax thresholds made by successive
conservative chancellors people in our
country can earn one thousand pounds a
month without paying a penny of tax or
National Insurance
the party opposite opposed those tax
reductions but they have helped lift two
million people out of absolute poverty
after housing costs including 400 000
pensioners and 500 000 children that
averages 80 pensioners and a hundred
children lifted out of poverty for every
single day we've been in office
and today today we Face the future with
extraordinary potential
the World Bank said that of all big
European countries we are the best place
to do business
Global Chief Executives say that apart
from America and China we are the best
country to invest in we became the
second country in the world to have a
stock of foreign direct investment worth
two trillion dollars and London has just
picked New York and 53 other Global
cities to be the best place in the world
for female entrepreneurs
declinists are wrong about our country
for another reason
which is our strength in new industries
that will shape this Century over the
last 13 years under conservative
leadership we have become the world's
third trillion dollar Tech economy after
the US and China we've built the largest
Life Sciences sector in Europe producing
a covered vaccine that saved 6 million
lives and a treatment that saved a
million more our film and TV industry
has become Europe's largest with our
creative Industries growing at twice the
rate of the economy our Advanced
manufacturing Industries produce around
half the world's large civil aircraft
wings and thanks to a clean energy
Miracle we have become a world leader in
offshore wind
other parties talk about a green energy
Revolution so I gently remind them that
nearly 90 percent of our solar power was
installed in the last 13 years showing
sun is shining
[Applause]
now
let's turn to what the obr say about our
growth prospects
in November they expected that the UK
economy would enter a session in 2022
and contract by 1.4 percent in 23. that
left many families feeling concerned
about the future but today the obr
forecast we will not enter a recession
at all this year with a contraction of
just 0.2 percent and after this year the
UK economy will grow in every single
year of the forecast period by 1.8
percent in 24 2.5 percent 2.1 percent
and 1.9 in 27. they also expect
the unemployment rate to rise by less
than one percentage point to 4.4 percent
with 170 000 fewer people out of work
compared to their Autumn forecast
Madam Deputy speaker that return to
growth has direct consequences for our
role on the global stage
I am proud that we are giving the brave
people of Ukraine more Military Support
than anyone else in Europe
on Monday we were we were able to go
even further with my right honorable
friend announcing a 5 billion package of
funding for the ministry of Defense an
additional 2 billion pounds next year
and 3 billion pounds the year after
today following representative
representations from our persuasive
defense secretary I confirm that we will
add a total of 11 billion pounds to our
defense budget over the next five years
and it will be nearly two and a quarter
percent of GDP by 2025.
we were the first European we were the
first large European country to commit
to two percent of GDP for defense and we
will now raise that to two and a half
percent as soon as fiscal and economic
circumstances allow
and following representations from the
equally persuasive Minister for Veterans
Affairs I am today also increasing
support for our brave ex-servicemen and
women
we will provide a package worth over 30
million pounds to increase the capacity
of the office for Veterans Affairs
support veterans with injuries returning
from their service and increase the
availability of Veteran housing
but to be Europe's biggest defender of
democracy we must build Europe's most
dynamic economy
that means tackling our long-standing
productivity issues including two in
particular which I addressed today lower
business investment and higher economic
inactivity than other countries
too often companies struggle to recruit
and even when they do output per
employee is lower
so today I set out the four pillars of
our industrial strategy to address these
issues
colleagues will know from my Bloomberg
speech they all conveniently start with
the letter e Enterprise employment
education and everywhere
I start Madam Deputy speaker with
everywhere
are measures
well they may not want to level up
growth across the United Kingdom
this government's this government was
elected on a mandate to level up
[Music]
four billion pounds in over 200 projects
across the country through the first two
rounds of the leveling up fund a third
round will follow
since we started focusing on leveling up
70 of the growth in salary jobs has come
from outside London and the southeast
and today we take further steps
Canary Wharf and the Liverpool docks
were two outstanding regeneration
projects that happened under a previous
conservative government
I pay tributes to Lord Hazeltine for
making them happen because they
transformed the lives of thousands of
people they showed what's possible when
entrepreneurs government and local
communities come together
so today I announced that we will
deliver 12 new investment zones 12
potential Canary wharfs in England in
England we've identified the following
areas
as having the potential to host one West
Midlands greater Manchester the
Northeast South Yorkshire West Yorkshire
East Midlands T side and once again
Liverpool
there will also be at least one in each
of Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland
to be to be chosen each area must
identify a location where they can offer
a bold and imaginative partnership
between local governments and the
University or research institutes in a
way that catalyzes new innovation
clusters if the application is
successful they'll have access to 80
million pounds of support for a range of
interventions including skills
infrastructure tax reliefs and business
rates retention
working together with our formidable
leveling up secretary I also want to
give some further support to leveling up
areas under the E of everywhere
first I will invest over 200 million
pounds in high quality local
regeneration projects across England
including the Regeneration of Tipton
town center and the Mazda new Mills
Redevelopment scheme I'm also announcing
I'm also announcing a further 161
million pounds for regeneration projects
in Merrell combined authorities and the
greater London Authority and I will make
over 400 million pounds available for
new leveling up Partnerships in areas
that include redcar and Cleveland
Blackburn Oldham Rochdale Mansfield
South tyneside and Basset law
yeah having listened to the case for
better local transport infrastructure
from many honorable members I can
announce a second round of the city
region sustainable transport settlements
allocating 8.8 billion pounds over the
next five-year funding period
and following a wet then cold winter I
have also received particularly strong
representations from my honorable
friends from North Devon Southwest Devon
and Newton Abbott as well as councilor
Peter Martin from my own constituency
about the curse of
[Applause]
review allocated 500 million pounds
every year to the potholes fund but
today I have decided to increase that
fund by a further 200 million pounds
next year
to help local communities tackle this
problem
Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland this
budget delivers not only a new invest
ment Zone but an additional 320 million
pounds for the Scottish government 180
million pounds for the Welsh government
and 130 million pounds for the Northern
Ireland executive as a result of
barnet's consequentials on top of which
on top of which in Scotland I can
announce up to 8.6 million pounds of
targeted funding for the Edinburgh
festivals as well as one and a half
million pounds funding to repair the
claddock bridge
I will provide 20 million pounds of
funding for the Welsh government to
restore the hollyhead Breakwater
and in Northern Ireland I'm allocating
up to 3 million pounds to extend the
tackling militarism program and up to 40
million pounds to extend further and
higher education participation
we need to unleash the Civic
entrepreneurship that's only possible
when elected local leaders are able to
fund and deliver solutions to their own
challenges that means giving them
responsibility for Local Economic growth
and the benefits from the upside when it
happens
so this government will consult on
transferring responsibilities for Local
Economic Development from local
Enterprise Partnerships to local
authorities from April 24. I will also
boost mayor's Financial autonomy by
agreeing multi-year single settlements
for the West Midlands and greater
combined Manchester Authority in the
next spending review something I intend
to roll out for all mayoral areas over
time I've also agreed a new long-term
commitment so that they can retain 100
of their business rates something I also
hope to expand to other areas investment
zones regeneration projects leveling up
Partnerships local transport
infrastructure and business rates
retention more control for local
communities over their economic Destiny
so we will level up wealth and
opportunity everywhere
today's priority
today's priority is the prime minister's
promise to grow the economy
we've talked about making that growth
happen everywhere so I now move on to my
second e-enterprise we need to be
we need to be well this has never been
something of interest to the labor party
for conservatives we won't rest until we
are Europe's most dynamic enterprise
economy
and under a conservative government
that is exactly what's been happening
since 2010 we have one million more
businesses in the UK a bigger increase
than Germany France or Italy but I want
another million and another million
after that so today I bring forward
Enterprise measures in these three areas
to lower business taxes reduce energy
costs and support our growth industries
so let's start with business taxation
conservatives know the importance of a
competitive tax regime we already have
lower levels of business taxation than
France Germany Italy or Japan
but I want us to have the most
pro-business pro-enterprise tax regime
anywhere
even after the corporation tax rise this
April we will have the lowest headline
rate in the G7 lower than any period
under the last Labor government
only 10 of companies will pay the full
25 rate but even at 19 our corporation
tax did not incentivize investment as
effectively as countries with higher
headline rates the result is less
capital investment and lower
productivity than countries like France
and Germany we've already taken measures
to address this for larger business
we've had the super deduction introduced
by my right honorable friend the Prime
Minister which ends this month for
smaller businesses we've increased the
annual investment allowance to one
million pounds meaning 99 of all
businesses can can deduct the full value
of all their investment from that Year's
taxable profits
if the super deduction was allowed to
end without a replacement we would have
fallen down the international league
tables on tax competitiveness and
damaged growth
as a conservative I could not allow that
to happen
so today I can announce we will
introduce a new policy of full capital
expensing for the next three years with
an intention to make it permanent as
soon as we can responsibly do so that
means that every single pound a company
invests in it equipment plant or
Machinery can be deducted in full and
immediately from taxable profits
it is a corporation tax cut worth an
average of nine billion pounds a year
for every year that it's in place and
its impact on the economy will be huge
the obr says it will increase in
business investment by three percent for
every year it's in place this decision
makes us the only major European country
with full expensing and gives us the
joint most generous Capital allowance
regime of any advanced economy
Madam Deputy speaker I understand the
party opposite is reviewing business
taxes let me save them the bother they
put them up we cut them
[Applause]
[Music]
to make our taxes I also want to make
our taxes more competitive in our life
science and creative industry sectors in
the Autumn I said I'd return with a more
robust r d tax credit scheme for smaller
research intensive companies
so today I'm introducing an enhanced
credit which means that if a qualifying
small or medium-sized business spends 40
or more of their total expenditure on R
D they'll be able to claim a credit
worth 27 pounds for every 100 pounds
they spend that means an eligible cancer
drug company spending two million pounds
on research and development will receive
over 500 000 pounds to help them develop
breakthrough treatments it's a 1.8
billion pound package of support helping
20 000 cutting-edge companies who day by
day are turning Britain into a science
superpower
yeah and this government's audio visual
tax reliefs have helped make our film
and TV industry the biggest in Europe
only last month Pinewood announced an
expansion which will bring another 8 000
jobs to the UK to give even more
momentum to this critical sector I'll
introduce an expenditure credit with a
rate of 34 for film high-end television
and video games and 39 for the animation
and children's TV sectors I'll maintain
the qualifying threshold of high-end
television at a million pounds and
because our theater's orchestras and
museums do such a brilliant job at
attracting tourists to London and the UK
I'll extend for another two years their
current 45 and 50 reliefs
Madame Deputy speaker an enterprise
economy needs low taxes but it also
needs cheap and reliable energy
we have already announced billions of
support to help businesses reduce their
energy bills through the energy bills
release scheme and the energy bills
discount scheme
we've appointed Dame Allison Rose chief
executive of NatWest to co-chair our
national Energy Efficiency task force
and help deliver our national ambition
to reduce energy use by 15 and to
support her efforts I'll extend the
climate change agreement scheme for two
years to allow eligible businesses 600
million pounds of tax relief on Energy
Efficiency measures
but the long-term solution is not
subsidy but security
that means investing in domestic sources
of energy that fall outside Putin or any
autocrats control
we are world leaders in renewable energy
so today I want to develop another plank
of our green economy carbon capture
usage and Storage
I'm allocating up to 20 billion pounds
of support
for the early development of ccus
starting with projects from our East
Coast to merseyside to North Wales
Paving the way for cc us everywhere
across the UK as we approach 2050. that
will support up to 50 000 jobs attract
private sector investment and help
capture 20 to 30 million tons of CO2 per
year by 2030.
we have increased the proportion of
electricity generated from Renewables
from under 10 when we came into office
to nearly 40 percent
but because the wind doesn't always blow
and the sun doesn't always shine even
under the conservatives speaker we will
need we will need another critical
source of cheap and reliable energy and
that is nuclear
[Applause]
now there have
they have more powerful advocates for
this than the honorable member for
innisman
Copeland Hartlepool and workington
they rightly say that increasing nuclear
capacity is vital to meet our Net Zero
obligations so to encourage private
sector investment into our nuclear
program I today confirm that subjects to
consultation nuclear power will be
classed as environmentally sustainable
[Applause]
that will give it access to the same
investment incentives as renewable
energy
and alongside that will come more public
investment
in the Autumn statement I announced the
first state finance investment in
nuclear for a generation a 700 million
pound investment in size well C today I
can announce two further commitments to
deliver our nuclear Ambitions firstly
following representations from our
energetic energy security secretary I am
announcing the launch of Great British
nuclear which will bring down costs and
provide opportunities across the nuclear
supply chain to help provide one quarter
of our electricity by 2050
and secondly
I am it's so good to hear labor in favor
of nuclear energy
[Applause]
just a shame they never did any
popular reactors
it will be completed by the end of this
year and if demonstrated as viable we
will co-fund this exciting new
technology
finally under the E of Enterprise Deputy
speaker I come to our Innovation economy
a central area of national competitive
Advantage for the United Kingdom
over the weekend I worked night and day
with the Prime Minister and the governor
of Bank of England to protect the
deposits of thousands of our most
cutting-edge companies we successfully
secured the sale of the UK arm of
Silicon Valley Bank to HSBC so the
future of those companies is now safe in
the hands of Europe's biggest and one of
its most credit worthy Banks
but those events show that we need to
build a larger more diverse financing
system where the benefits of investment
in high growth firms are available to
more investors so I will return in the
Autumn statement with a plan to deliver
that it will include measures to unlock
productive investment from defined
contribution Pension funds and other
sources make the London Stock Exchange a
more attractive place to list and
complete our response to the challenges
created by the U.S inflation reduction
Act
however when it comes to our Innovation
Industries there are two areas I want to
make progress on today
Nigel Lawson made the city of London one
of the world's top Financial Centers by
competitive deregulation
with our brexit autonomy we can do the
same for our high growth sectors so
today I want to reform the regulations
around medicines and medical
Technologies
we are lucky with the mhra to have one
of the most respected drugs Regulators
in in the world indeed the very first
anywhere to license a covid vaccine
from 2024 they will move to a different
model
which will allow rapid often near
automatic sign-off for medicines and
Technologies already approved by trusted
Regulators in other parts of the world
such as the United States Europe and
Japan
at the same time they will set up a
Swift new approval process for the most
cutting-edge medicines and devices to
ensure the UK becomes a global Center
for their development and with an extra
10 million pounds of funding over the
next two years they will put in place
the quickest simplest regulatory
approval in the world for companies
seeking rapid Market access we are proud
of the life science sector which receive
more inward investment than any in
Europe last year today's change will
make the UK an even more exciting place
to invest using our brexit freedoms and
speeding up access for NHS patients to
the very newest Strokes
today with our talented science
Innovation and Technology secretary I
also take measures to strengthen our
position in artificial intelligence
where the UK hosts one-third of All
European country companies
I'm accepting all nine of the digital
technology recommendations made by Sir
Patrick Valance in the review I asked
him to do in the Autumn statement
that means I can report to the house
that we will launch an AI sandbox to
trial new faster approaches to help
innovators get cutting-edge products to
Market we'll work at PACE with the
intellectual property office to provide
Clarity on IP rules so that generative
AI companies can access the material
they need
I will ask the Patrick's successor Dame
Angela McLean to report before the
summer on options around the growth Duty
for regulators
because AI needs Computing horsepower I
today commit around 900 million pounds
of funding to implement the
recommendations of the independent
future of compute review for an exascale
computer
the power needed by ai's complex
algorithms can also be provided by
Quantum computing so today we'll publish
a Quantum strategy which will set out
our vision to be a world-leading Quantum
enabled economy by 2033 with a research
and Innovation program totaling two and
a half billion pounds
I also want to encourage the best AI
research to happen in the UK so we'll
award a prize of one million pounds
every year for the next 10 years to the
person or team that does the most
groundbreaking British AI research the
world's first stored program computer
was built at the University of
Manchester in 1948 and was known as the
Manchester baby 75 years on the baby has
grown up so I will call this new
National AI award the Manchester prize
in its honor
Madam Deputy speaker
you want a UK to be
great for everybody we want the UK to be
the best place in Europe for companies
to locate invest and grow so today's
Enterprise measures strengthen our
technology and life science sectors
invest in energy security and for three
years but I hope permanently cut
corporation tax by nine billion pounds a
year to give us the best incentive
investment incentives of any advanced
economy
an enterprise economy
can only grow if it can hire the people
it needs which brings me to my third
pillar after everywhere and Enterprise
I said it was a growth budget Madame
Deputy speaker and we are talking about
the E of employment
I'm going to talk about a difficult
topic for the party opposite now because
brexit was a decision by the British
people to change our economic model
in that in that historic vote our
country decided to move from a model
based on unlimited low-skill migration
to one based on high wages and high
skills
today we show how we will deliver that
with a major set of reforms the obr say
it is the biggest positive supply side
intervention they have ever recognized
in their forecast
we have around 1 million vacancies in
the economy but excluding students there
are over seven million adults of working
age who are not in work that's a
potential pool of seven people for every
vacancy
conservatives believe work is a virtue
we agree with the road haulage King
Eddie Stobart who said the only place
success comes before work is the
dictionary
so so today I bring forward reforms to
remove the barriers that stop people who
want to from working
and I start with over 2 million people
who are inactive due to a disability or
long-term sickness
thanks to the reforms courageously
introduced by the right honorable member
for chingford and Woodford green the
number of disabled people in work has
risen by 2 million since 2013.
but even after that we could fill half
the vacancies in the economy with people
who say they would like to work despite
being inactive due to sickness or
disability with zoom teams and new
working models that make it easier to
work from home this is possible now more
than ever
so for that reason the ever diligent
work and pension secretary today takes
the next step in his groundbreaking work
on tackling economic active inactivity
I thank him for that and today we
publish a white paper on disability
benefits reform it is the biggest change
to our welfare system in a decade his
plans will abolish the work capability
assessment in Great Britain and separate
benefit entitlement from an individual's
ability to work
as a result disabled benefit claimants
will always be able to seek work without
fear of losing financial support
today I'm going further by announcing
that in England and Wales after
listening to representations for this
from the center for social justice and
others we will fund a new program called
Universal support
this is a new voluntary employment
scheme for disabled people where the
government will spend up to four
thousand pounds a person to help them
find appropriate jobs and put in place
the support they need it will fund 50
000 places every single year
we also want to help those who are
forced to leave work because of a health
condition such as a back pain or a
mental health issue
we should give them support before they
end up leaving their job
so working with our health secretary I'm
announcing a 400 million pound plan to
increase the availability of mental
health and musculoskeletal resources and
expand the individual placement and
support scheme and because Occupational
Health provided by employers has a key
role to play I'll also bring forward two
new consultations on how to improve its
availability and double the funding for
the small company subsidy pilot
there's another group that deserves
particular attention which is children
in care
they too should be given all possible
help to make a normal working life
possible when they reach adulthood
often they depend on Foster families who
do a brilliant job so today I'm merely
doubling the qualifying care relief
threshold to 18 140 pounds which will
give a tax cut to a qualifying carer
worth an average of 450 pounds a year
I'll also increase the funding we
provide to the staying close program by
50 percent to help more care leavers
into employment and I'll support young
people with special educational needs
and disabilities with a 3 million pilot
expansion of the department for
Education supported internship program
to help those people transition from
education into the workplace
Madame Deputy speaker no civilized
society can ignore the contribution that
can be made by those with challenging
family circumstances a long-term illness
or a disability so today we remove the
barriers we can with reforms that
strengthen our society as well as
strengthening our economy
the next set of employment reforms
affects those on universal credit
without a health condition who are
looking for work or on low earnings
there are more than two million job
seekers in this group more than enough
to fill every vacancy in the economy
Independence is always better than
dependents which is why a conservative
government believes
which is why
with some exceptions Madam Deputy
speaker
Independence is always better than
dependence which is why a conservative
government believes those who can work
should
so sanctions will be applied more
rigorously to those who fail to meet
strict work search requirements or
choose not to take out a reasonable job
offer and for those working low hours we
will increase the administrative
earnings threshold from the equivalent
of 15 hours to 18 hours at National
living wage for an individual claimant
meaning that anyone working below this
level will receive more work coach
support alongside a more intensive
conditionality regime
the next group of workers I want to
support are those aged over 50
my younger officials have termed these
people older workers although as a 56
year old myself I prefer the term
experienced
fully three and a half million people of
pre-retirement age over 50 are not part
of the labor force an increase of 320
000 pounds since 320 000 since before
the pandemic we now have the 23rd
highest inactivity rate for over 55s in
the oecd if we match the rate of Sweden
we would add more than a million people
to our National Labor Force Madam Deputy
speaker I say this not to flatter you
but older people are the most skilled
and experienced people we have
[Applause]
no no
country can Thrive no country can Thrive
if it turns its back on such a wealth of
talent and ability but for too many
turning 50 is a moment of anxiety about
the cliff edge of retirement rather than
a moment of anticipation about another
two decades of fulfillment
I know this Madam Deputy speaker myself
after I turned 50 I was relegated to the
back benches and planned for a quiet
life but instead I decided to set an
example by embarking on a new career in
finance
so today I take three steps to make it
easier for those who wish to
[Applause]
it's going well thank you and today I
take three steps to make it easier for
those who wish to to work longer first
we will increase the number of people
who get the best possible Financial
Health and career guidance ahead of
retirement by enhancing the dwp's
excellent mid-life mot strategy they
will also increase by fivefold the
number of 50 plus Universal credits who
receive midlife mots from 8 000 to 40
000 a year
second with my right honorable friends
the education secretary who has a deep
personal commitment to this area will
introduce a new kind of apprenticeship
targeted at the over 50s who want to
return to work they will be called
returnerships
and operate alongside skills boot camps
and sector-based work academies they'll
bring together our existing skills
programs to make them more appealing for
older workers focusing on flexibility
and previous experience to reduce
training length
finally I have listened to the concerns
of many senior NHS clinicians who say
unpredictable pension tax charges are
making them leave the NHS just when they
are needed the most
the NHS is our biggest employer and we
will shortly publish a long-term
Workforce plan that I promised in the
Autumn statement
I don't want any doctor to retire early
because of the way pension taxes work
it's an issue I've discussed not just
with the current health secretary but a
former Health secretary who kindly took
a break from what's Happening his
colleagues to consider it
I've realized the issue goes wider than
doctors no one should be pushed out of
the workforce for tax reasons so today I
will increase the pensions annual
tax-free allowance from by 50 percent
from forty thousand to sixty thousand
some have also asked me to increase the
lifetime allowance from its one million
pound limit
but I've decided not to do that instead
I will go further and abolish the
lifetime allowance
[Music]
reform
that will stop over 80 percent of NHS
doctors from receiving a tax charge
incentivize our most experienced and
productive workers to stay in work for
longer and simplify our tax system
taking thousands of people out of the
complexity ah a lot of audiences because
the touch of the executive is either
unpopular or popular we still have to
keep the noise down because we still
have to hear what he has to say he has
more to say
thank you madam Deputy speaker this is a
comprehensive plan to remove the
barriers to work facing those on
benefits those with health conditions
and older workers that is the E of the
employment pillar of today's growth
budget which brings me to the final
pillar of our growth plan after
employment Enterprise and everywhere I
turn to the E of Education
over more than a decade
this conservative government has driven
improvement in our education system
we've risen by nearly 10 places in the
international league tables for English
and maths since 2015 alone
in the Autumn statement I built on this
program with an extra 2.3 billion pounds
annual investment to our schools
we're reviewing our approach to skills
with Sir Michael Barber we set out our
plans to transform lifelong learning
with a new lifelong loan entitlement and
my right honorable friend the Prime
Minister announced plans to make maths
compulsory till 18. but today I want to
address an issue in our education system
that is bad for children and damaging
for the economy it's an issue that
starts even before a child enters the
gates of a school today I want to reform
our child care system
we have one of the most expensive
systems in the world almost half
of non-working mothers say they would
prefer to work if they could arrange
suitable child care for many women a
career break becomes a career end
our female participation participation
rate is higher than average for oecd
economies but we Trail top performers
like Denmark and the Netherlands if we
match Dutch levels of participation
there will be more than one million
additional women working
and we can do that
so today I announce a series of reforms
that start that Journey
I begin with the supply of child care
we've seen a significant decline in
child minders over recent years down
nine percent in England in just one year
but child minders are a vital way to
deliver affordable and flexible care and
we need more of them
so I've listened to representations from
my honorable friend from Stroud
and decided to address this by piloting
incentive payments of 600 pounds for
child minders who sign up to the
profession rising to 1200 pounds for
those who join through an agency
I've also heard many concerns about cost
pressures facing the sector
we know this is making it hard to hire
staff and raising prices for parents
with around two-thirds of child care
providers increasing fees last year
alone
so we'll increase the funding paid to
nurseries providing free child care
under the hours offer by 204 million
pounds from this September rising to 288
million pounds next year that's an
average of a 30 percent increase in the
two-year-old rate this year just as the
sector has requested I will also offer
providers more flexibility in how they
operate in line with other parts of the
UK so alongside that additional funding
we will change minimum staff to child
ratios from one to four to one to five
for two-year-olds in in England as
happens in Scotland although the new
ratios will remain optional with no
obligation on either child minders or
parents to adopt them
I want to help the 700 000 parents on
universal credits who until the reforms
I announced today have limited
requirements to look for work many
remain out of work because they cannot
afford The Upfront payment necessary to
access subsidized child care
so for any parents who are moving into
work or want to increase their hours we
will pay the child care costs up front
and we will increase the maximum they
can claim to 951 pounds for one child
and 1 630 pounds for two children an
increase of almost 50 percent
I turn now to parents of school-aged
children who often face barriers to
working because of the limited
availability of wraparound care
one-third of primary schools do not
offer Child Care at both ends of the
school day even though for many people a
job requires it to be available before
and after school
to address this we'll fund schools and
local authorities to increase the supply
of wrap-around care so all school age
parents can drop their children off
between 8 AM and 6 p.m and our ambition
is that all schools will start to offer
a full wraparound offer either on their
own or in partnership with other schools
by September 2026
[Music]
madam
decrease the availability of child care
reduce costs and increase the number of
parents able to use it taken together
with earlier conservative reforms they
amount to the most significant
improvements to child care provision in
a decade but if we really want to remove
the barriers to work we need to go
further for parents who have a child
under three
for them Child Care remains just too
expensive
in 2010 there was barely any free child
care for under fives
a conservative-led government changed
that with free child care for three and
four-year-olds in England it was a
landmark reform
but not a complete one I don't want any
parent with a child under five to be
prevented from working if they want to
because it's damaging to our economy and
unfair mainly to women
so today I announce that ineligible
households where all adults are working
at least 16 hours we will introduce 30
hours of free child care not just for
three and four-year-olds but for every
single child over the age of nine months
the 30-hour offer will now start from
the moment maternity or paternity leave
ends it's a package worth on average six
and a half thousand pounds every year
for a family with a two-year-old child
using 35 hours of child care every week
and reduces their child care costs by
nearly 60 percent
yeah
because it is such a large reform we
will introduce it in stages to ensure
there is enough Supply in the market
working parents of two-year-olds will be
able to access 15 hours of free care
from April 2024 helping around half a
million parents
from September 24 that 15 hours will be
extended to all children from nine
months up meaning a total of nearly 1
million parents will be eligible
and from September 25 every single
working parent of under fives will have
access to 30 hours free child care per
week
Mr Perkins stop it
[Applause]
Madame Deputy speaker today we complete
a landmark conservative reform we help
the economy transform the lives of
thousands of women and build a child
care system comparable to the best a
major early years reform for our
education system the E of Education
alongside the three other pillars of our
growth plan Enterprise employment and
everywhere
so Madam Deputy speaker in November we
delivered stability today it's growth we
tackle the two biggest barriers that
stop businesses growing investment
incentives and labor Supply the best
investment incentives in Europe the
biggest ever employment package for
disabled people more help for older
people barriers removed for families
feeling the pinch fuel Duty Frozen beer
Duty cut energy bills capped and for
parents 30 hours of free child care for
all under fives today we build for the
future with inflation down debt falling
and growth up the declinists are wrong
and the optimists are right
we
we stick to the plan because the plan is
working and I commend this statement to
the house
I thank the chancellor of the exchequer
for his budget statement and I hope the
house will
settle down please
understanding order number 51 the first
motion entitled absolutely the bad
behaviors are on this side of the house
I think a little bit of decorum please
while we go through the necessary parts
of the procedure understanding order
number 51 the first motion entitled
provisional collection of taxes must be
decided without debate well the
chancellor of the exchequer please move
formally
um
thank you Chancellor I'm just putting
your emotions the question is that
pursuant to section 5 of the provisional
collection of taxes act 1968 provisional
statutory effect shall be given to the
following motions a stamp Duty land tax
transaction funded with the assistance
of a subsidy motion number 39 the fuel
duties accepted machines motion number
44 C rates of tobacco products Duty
motion number 46 D late payment interest
value added tax portion number 57 e
Charities value added tax
Etc motion number 65 as many as are of
that opinion say I
of the contrary no I think they always
have it the eyes have it let us now
consider the motion entitled income tax
charge for it's on this motion that the
debate will take place today and on the
succeeding days the questions on this
motion
and on the remaining motions will be put
at the end of the budget debate on
Tuesday the 21st of March so I call the
chancellor the exchequer to move the
motion formally
move forward
and the question is that income tax is
charged for the tax year
2023-24 and it is declared that it's
expedient in the public interest that
this resolution should have statutory
effect under the provisions of the
provisional collection of taxes Act
1968.
I'm not I call the leader of the
opposition
thank you madam Deputy speaker can I say
it's good to see you back in the chair
so for all the hype a budget for growth
to downgrade the growth forecast
his opening boast was that things aren't
quite as bad now as they were in October
last year after the Kamikaze budget and
the more that he pretends everything is
fine the more he shows just how out of
touch they are
after 13 years of his government our
economy needed major surgery but like
Millions across our country this budget
leaves us stuck in the waiting room with
only a sticking plaster to hand a
country set on a path of managed decline
falling behind our competitors the sick
man of Europe once again
this was a day for ambition for bringing
us together with purpose and intent for
unlocking the pride that is in every
Community matching their belief in the
possibilities of the future but Madam
Deputy speaker after today we know the
Tory cupboard is as bare as the salad
Isle in our supermarket
[Applause]
the lettuces may be out but the turnips
are in
I hopelessly divided party caught
between a rock of Decline and a hard
place of their own economic recklessness
dressing up stagnation of stability as
their expiry date looms ever closer
and the figures published today spell it
out a year of stagnation growth
non-existent according to the IMF the
worst performing country in the G7 this
year a prediction today confirmed by the
OVR and growth downgraded in years to
come this is a failure you can measure
not just in the figures but in the empty
pockets of working people right across
the country
13 years without wage growth 13 years no
better off 13 years stuck in a doom Loop
of lower growth higher taxes and broken
public proper services
Deputy Madam speaker our opr makes clear
today things don't look any better in
the long run a broken labor market
holding back our prospects seven million
on the NHS waiting lists ill health and
disability on the rise and the
consequences as we've just heard defer
to the Future the classic short-term
sticking plaster cycle decisions
cynically duck today paying for working
people tomorrow
yeah it doesn't have to be like this
Britain has enormous potential on
science innovation technology we should
be leading not lagging we need an
industrial strategy that removes
barriers to investment
of the announcements today are nowhere
near the mark the lowest investment in
the G7 that's their record
all our competitors know this they're
gearing up for An Almighty race for the
opportunities of tomorrow and we've got
to be on the start line not back in the
changing room tying our laces
now he mentioned the war in Ukraine
and of course on this side of the house
we stand with Ukraine and we stand with
the government's response to Putin's
brutality we'll look carefully at the
details of the military spending
announced and we will support them
but what we cannot accept is the use of
the war as a blanket excuse for failure
but other countries wages in this
country are lower now in real terms than
they were 13 years ago
the average French family is a 10th
richer the average German family a fifth
richer countries which face the same
pandemic countries which face the same
War
and the war didn't ban onshore wind the
war didn't scrap our home insulation
scream team the war didn't run down our
gas storage facilities they did
decisions which hurt working people
battling the cost of living crisis right
now
it's been the same story for the whole
13 years always the sticking plaster
never The Cure and today's budget does
nothing to change that
again we see a failure to grip the
long-term challenges
while the leader of the opposition is
delivering yes
shouldn't be listening no we will now
listen to the leader of the opposition
so
today's budget changes nothing again we
see a failure to grip the long-term
challenges no determination to create
growth which unlocks the potential of
the many working people being made to
pay for Tory choices and Tory mistakes
Madam Deputy speaker these are the
organizing principles of conservative
economics judge them by their choices
the running down of our Public Services
paid for by working people the disaster
of the Tory mortgage premium paid for by
working people
opportunities to still miss for a proper
windfall tax paid for by working people
that's what makes the Chancellor's boast
about lower inflation so ridiculous the
idea that it's a tax cut British people
can see through that they see their tax
burden at its highest level for 70 years
and they know it's not the government
that's lowering inflation it's working
people earning less enjoying less it's
their sacrifice that is helping to bring
inflation down and they deserve better
than another Cheap Trick from the
government of gimmicks making them pay
whilst trying to claim the credit
even with the price guarantee the
average Energy bill has doubled in 18
months
because of their recklessness the
average mortgage payment is up 2 000
pounds a year a massive hit to living
standards however they cook the books
and yet still no real ambition on
Industrial strategy no real ambition on
the clean energy that will give us
cheaper bills no real ambition on house
building the same old Tory choices
sticking plaster politics no growth for
the many working people paid
and let's turn to his policies on the
cost of living Madam Deputy speaker I
say his policies because there's a
history to this a pattern over the
course of the whole cost of living
crisis time and again it's labor who
bring the government not just to its
senses but to our position
who first pushed for the energy price
guarantee labor who first called for a
proper windfall tax labor who first
stood by people on prepayment meters
labor and who first said we should
freeze the price guarantee this April
labor and and we can go on because it's
also labor the first committee
come
policy that in January he dismissed as
part of a dossier that he published so
for one poor soul in their research team
at least this really is a back to work
budget
and
[Applause]
for the chancellor as he promotes this
policy in coming days
use your own car
and For Heaven's Sake make sure you know
how to use a debit card
and I look forward to the Prime Minister
promoting the swimming pools policy
unlike the car he won't have to borrow
one of those
but Madam Deputy speaker the cost of
living crisis is not over and once again
they've left money on the table when it
comes to oil and gas companies money
that could have been better spent on
working people
politics is about whose side you're on
there are loopholes that urgently need
closing even the former CEO of shell
admitted that they should be paying more
of the long-term plan just isn't there
the same old Tory choices the same three
principles sticking class to politics no
growth for the many working people pay
and you see those principles at play in
our broken labor market
much of what the chancellor said today
focused on that as well it might
the figures announced in this budget
show how damaging the current situation
is to growth a long-term drag on our
ability to create more wealth our
inactivity levels are particularly
shocking up half a million since the
pandemic the worst jobs recovery since
the G7 people unable to work because of
ill health more than ever before
now we will look at what the chancellors
announced today because on these benches
we've long called for reform of the work
capability assessment for a welfare
system that supports people with
disabilities and long-term health
conditions to thrive at work the
Universal Credit system must help people
into employment and child care is a huge
barrier to that we've made the case for
reform
but on child care of course more money
on the system is obviously a good thing
[Applause]
they obviously didn't listen to when he
said he's actually going to do it
Taurus
up and down the country no it's no use
having more free hours if you can't
access them and it pushes the costs for
parents outside the offer that's what
we've seen before
and on pensions he made a big spending
commitment which will benefit those with
the broadest shoulders
where many people are struggling to save
into their pension we needed a fix for
doctors but the announcement today is a
huge giveaway to some of the very
wealthiest
the only permanent tax cut in the budget
is for the richest one percent how can
that possibly be a priority for this
government
the truth is our labor market is the
cast iron example of an economy with
weak foundations our crisis in
participation simply hasn't happened
elsewhere not to this extent it's a
feature of Tory Britain and Global
excuses won't wash we need a wider
reform agenda
instead of making working people pay we
need to make work pay move on from
growth that's based on insecure low-paid
jobs to growth which comes from good
work from strong employment rights that
can deliver higher productivity growth
from the many for the many that makes
people better off in all parts of our
country
I welcome his announcement on Devolution
deals the principle that we should push
power out of Westminster is fully
supported on this side of the house in
fact we want him to go further
communities Beyond Birmingham Manchester
Manchester deserve the right powers and
the same powers to drive growth as well
[Music]
former Health secretary absolutely
a signed copy of this book he knows that
growth needs and NHS fit for the future
and no country can be fit for work when
there are seven million people on
Hospital waiting
so I was waiting for him to match
Labor's ambition yeah absolutely waiting
for him to match our plan to train more
doctors and nurses to tackle the
capacity crisis a policy he publicly
praised just 15 days before he became
Chancellor and yet it never came a
madame Deputy speaker if there was ever
a symbol of the poverty of ambition that
is it
because the reality is the country
getting sicker is a country getting
poorer and a country getting poorer is a
country getting sicker health and wealth
must go together Britain can't afford to
be the sick man of Europe Britain can't
afford the Tories
[Applause]
there is another way on these benches we
understand institutions must be
respected constraints accepted the
fiscal rules should be fat sound and
followed rigorously that every pound is
precious and must not be wasted
look they want to shout about their
record let them shout wages lower taxes
higher borrowing higher debt higher
their chaos has a cost
certainty is vital for the growth we
need essential for businesses and
investors in our country as we've
spelled out compared with a blanket cut
to corporation tax investment allowances
are the right approach but the question
many businesses will ask today is how
long before the wind blows again and we
all go through this again
and that's what they don't understand
about business investment they're
endless fighting on tax is bad for
growth in and of itself
Madam Deputy has been real stability
means that taxes don't go up and down
like yo-yos
guaranteed tax credit regime doesn't get
overhauled twice in six months
order okay that's enough I now can't
hear the right honorable gentleman at
all exactly and it's nothing to do with
being old not quiet
armor
thank you let me give an example of that
instability it's a bit of a fraught
subject at the moment but when he was
culture secretary the chancellor
apparently took some lessons on the
rules of football
so let me provide a refresher the amount
of times his government has broken their
fiscal rules 11. that's one football
team the amount of times they've changed
corporation tax policy 22 that's two
teams you've got a game
but if he wants the post-max analysis
he'll have to consult the experts back
on his screens and ours this weekend I
know the whole house will want to
applaud that
but Madam Deputy speaker a budget is not
just about the choices made but the
choice is ignored
Britain needs more than certainty for
growth that's the least we should expect
we need change stability and success
anyone listening to this and worried
about NHS waiting list any about crime
it's about crime going unpunished you
know what they don't want to hear they
don't want to hear about the waiting
list
they don't want to hear about the crime
going unpunished house building rates
falling don't want to hear about that
either I suppose do you yeah
they will have heard very little that
makes them feel hopeful about our future
they could have used sensible taxation
policies or non-doms or oil and gas
companies have made the money work for
working people tackle the vested
interests that gum up our planning
system and show real ambition or the
investment we need to turn us into a
green growth superpower
and that was the test today can we move
beyond the usual sticking plaster
Solutions set a new direction for growth
that serves the interests of working
people
but I'm afraid the verdict on this
budget is clear they won't offer change
because they can't
so I
are going backwards the sick man of
Europe once again
that's the Britain they've created and
they should look it in the eye
because today's figures on growth put
their failures up in lights
after 13 years of tourists sticking
plaster politics 13 years of no growth
for the many 13 years of being asked to
pay
working people are entitled to ask am I
any better off than I was before and
after 13 years with no excuses left
nobody left to blame no ambitional
answers the resounding answer is no and
they know it
[Applause]
[Music]
now we'll just have things like just
settle down a bit now please and the
people are leaving let's do so quickly
and quietly
because out of consideration for
everyone else who is still taking part
in the debates
before I come to come on and get a move
on
right
before I come to the chairman of the
treasury select committee Harriet
Baldwin
[Applause]
thank you very much Madam Deputy speaker
and wonderful to have you back in
after that torrent of socialist
declinism from the opposition
[Applause]
I want to start by saying how lucky we
are to have a lucky Chancellor
[Applause]
been lucky this winter because
the weather has been a lot warmer than
when he stood here in November and as a
result
price of energy has come down but he has
also made some of his own luck Madame
Deputy speaker because thanks to the
steps that he took the financial markets
have stabilized and he has had to pay
less in interest than he was expecting
to about 4 billion pounds
it is actually quite hard to believe
that this is the first actual official
budget that we've had in this chamber
since October 2021
are a lot of things have changed since
the last time we had a budget
our world leading NHS vaccination
railout rollout has ended the severe
contagion of the pandemic but Putin's
evil and illegal invasion of Ukraine has
sparked the worst inflation for 40 years
the challenges those events have placed
on the public finances have been
extraordinary and the spending can't all
be borrowed and passed on to the next
generation and that's why I welcome the
news today from the chancellor that he's
forecasting three percent lower debt in
years to come yeah our committee the
treasury committee welcomes the fact
that the budget is accompanied by
forecast from the office for Budget
responsibility we think that it's
important that that stands alongside a
budget it's a key part of the
independent framework for chancellors
and we will be taking evidence from them
next week on the underlying assumptions
behind their forecasts
because what has changed most
perniciously since the last budget in
October 2021 is inflation
it was only just beginning to rear its
ugly head in October 2021
and as a member of the treasury
committee throughout this entire period
I've been like Cassandra in highlighting
some of the inflationary risks that
we've faced
far from being transitory as the
Independent Bank of England hoped
inflation has become quite deeply
embedded in the UK economy in wage
inflation and in expectations and that's
why I welcome the news today that the
office for Budget responsibility is
expecting that by the end of this year
inflation will be back down to 2.9
percent again because inflation is the
worst tax that we have on our economy it
is a tax paid particularly by the very
poorest who spend the highest proportion
of their incomes on food and energy and
so the chancellor must not hear the
siren voices
urging him to increase or to abandon the
inflation Target that he gives to the
Independent Bank of England the top
priority for our economy this year must
be to at least half inflation
it's to be welcomed that in his budget
today the chancellor has tried to focus
on measures that help to achieve that
inflation Target
the extension of the fuel Duty freeze
and the cap on household energy costs
will all help to keep inflation lower by
almost one percent uh but lower than it
would have been
and these may not feel like giveaways
but they do cost money against the
do-nothing counterfactual option so it's
good to see that they're being
implemented because of better public
finances and that these tax cuts can be
seen as consistent with the government's
second priority of reducing debt
in our recent treasury committee report
we called on the chancellor to think
again about the fiction that lies behind
fuel Duty forecasts
every year they get embedded in the
fiscal Outlook and every year
chancellors realize that it's not an
ideal time to raise fuel Duty I welcome
the fact that the fuel Duty cut has been
extended for another year and that once
again the fiction has not been followed
through into reality but I do think we
need to think long and hard about why
attacks that is inflationary that harms
growth and is heading the way of the
dodo as we all move to electric cars is
still in the forecast numbers
the third Economic Policy of growing the
economy in a non-inflationary way will
involve all of us working more
productively and the stride review named
after my illustrious predecessor has
rightly focused on this key question and
I think there were many measures that we
can all see will be very helpful that
were announced in today's uh budget
because with over 1 million job
vacancies in our economy we are still as
a country working fewer hours than we
were before the pandemic and unlocking
that human and economic potential is key
to strong productive non-inflationary
growth so the steps that have been
announced today on child care and on
pensions will help to ease the labor
shortages that are pushing up wage
demands and they will help counter those
inflationary pressures and so the
treasury committee looks forward to
exploring all of these issues in detail
with both our expert Witnesses I'm with
the chancellor in himself in our next
evidence sessions because the details
really matter
the treasury committee has highlighted
the new benefit Cliff edges that my
right honorable friend introduced last
November when he announced that next
winter only low paid households will
receive the 900 pounds help with their
cost of living
we are script to be spread into six
installments to reduce the risk of Cliff
edges and we're sorry to hear that a
somewhat clunky computer system means
that there will be three installments
instead because we worry that if you
lose your job one day just after the
qualifying date you will miss out on a
lot of help
and there are still Cliff edges take
rates and disincentives to work the law
in our benefits and tax system whether
it's around free School meals help with
the child care limits child benefit
tapers tax free child care Cliff edges
the withdrawal of a tax re-allowance and
the very welcome measures today
announced on all those fronts and with
the pension cap abolition will all be
studied in detail by the committee we're
planning to work closely with our
colleagues on the work and pensions
committee to find recommendations to
smooth some of these Cliff edges and
distortions and the chancellor can see
how these work as disincentives to
adding more hours and every hour of work
should pay
I think that they've made huge progress
towards that today I think at any stage
in life and at any age you should be
rewarded more the more you work speak
speaking briefly as a constituency MP
Madame Deputy speaker I just want to
welcome the help for swimming pools for
our pubs for leveling up with more than
theaters and for our child care
providers and our nurseries I think
there's a lot of very good news for them
today
the Chancellor's had some luck since
November Madam Deputy speaker he shared
that luck with UK households today he
has a clear intention to bring down
inflation to grow the economy and to
reduce debt May good luck continue to
follow him and may the extra billions of
pounds of expense that he's scoring for
the defense budget yeah help our
Ukrainian friends have good luck and to
beat back the Russian invader
UK
[Applause]
spokesman for the Scottish national
party Stuart Hosey
thank you very much Madam Deputy speaker
I thought the chair of the select
committee was about to launch a ship
without preparation at the end if I may
make a couple of small observations
before I start the chancellor mentioned
uh Nigel Lawson and his deregulation
budgets in the past and he spoke about
the resolution of
um Silicon Valley Bank I hope this
government learned the right lessons
from those episodes and indeed from the
2008-9 crash do not weaken regulation do
not weaken tier one Capital do not
return the banking system into risk can
I also say I was intrigued by many of
the things he said about reducing
economic inactivity I'm sure some of the
measures May well work I think to add
more and brutal sanctions to Universal
Credit Clements was probably rather
unconscionable given everything else
which is going on he did seem to give
the impression of broad sublet Uplands
and there were lots of cheating and
waving of order papers at the end
what the chancellor actually described
though it was a UK economy which has
gone from the most robust in the UA G7
to one of the weakest a UK economy where
brexit slammed the break on UK
investment a UK whose performance
deteriorated after the brexit referendum
both an absolute and relative terms
a country which unilaterally imposed
trade barriers with its nearest
Neighbors
and a country the only one in the G7
where the economy has not returned to
its pre-pandemic level now one could
make a case to say that was not all the
fault of the government but many of the
difficulties were and many were caused
by the disastrous fiscal loosening by
his predecessor and the right honorable
member for spellthorne and we can see
the problem the economy faces through
the prism of debt interest he's right in
terms of what he said compared to last
November four months ago but year on
year on year the debt interest payments
of 30 40 50 60 billion pounds higher
than they were a year ago and for
ordinary people working people and the
ubr confirmed in November real household
disposable income remains below the
2019-20 level and will do for the next
four or five years and I'm seeing
nothing in the red book and the obr
forecast in the last few millets that
would change my mind about that
assessment in November so I think we had
every right today to expect this budget
would begin to address more of the
long-term issues the economy faces and
action to tackle some of the cost
burdens on ordinary people and these
long-term issues were addressed by both
the CBI and the TUC in their submissions
to this Budget on growth the CBI said
the UK economy faces continues to face
Global and domestic headwinds with the
prospect of several more years of low
growth the TUC said the government is
arguing once more that the state of the
public finances is a reason to restrict
economic growth flying in the face of
evidence to the country on productivity
the CBI noted Britain has experienced 15
years of low growth and flatlining
productivity the TUC call to get
productivity Rising by rebooting the
skill system on exports and trade both
said broadly the same things the CBI
saying the government should work with
businesses across the UK's Nations and
regions to kick-start an exporting boom
on the supply of labor
the CBI said acute labor and skills
shortages are an albatross hampering UK
growth and the TU said TUC said there's
a recruitment and retention crisis in
public services
and on green energy on the green economy
the CBI said going green is essential
both for our International
competitiveness and our energy
resilience and the TUC demanded that the
government Institute the green jobs task
force with a long-term remix and
Regulatory capacity to plan to
decarbonize the economy
come to many of these things and there
will be some measures in the budget
there always are to be welcomed the
changes he announced on prepayment
meters it will help more support for
local charities it will help the
replacement for the corporation tax
super deduction absolutely essential
that could not be allowed to Simply fall
off the table
the problem is that when one even has a
cursory glance at the red book and the
obr forecast there's little to indicate
they've really understood or are taken
seriously tackling the issues raised on
growth
the obr forecast makes clear the impact
of government investment it's negative
in 2025 26 and 27 a drag on growth for
most of the forecast period on
productivity even on the government's
favorite productivity per hour metric it
does not reach 1.5 in any year in the
forecast period below the two percent
historic rate and the much wanted
20 billion pounds of r d spend by 24.25
announced three or four times before
today not mentioned today but I'm
assuming it's still on the table as is
the million pounds a year permanent
annual investment allowance I welcome
those things the problem is with
inflation the way we've had it and
inflation forecast those figures that
allowance will not buy the million
pounds a year or the 20 billion of r d
spend that it was originally anticipated
to do on exports trade and the balance
of payments the current account balance
remains negative for the entire forecast
periods and being outside the EU single
Market remains a drag on the ability of
funds to trade easily with our nearest
Neighbors
on the supply of labor and the
chancellor to be fair did speak a lot
about this employment employment is
forecast to rise but that will barely
get the labor and skills shortages
throughout the economy my view and my
party's view is only reversing brexit
and ensuring free movement of people
will do that but even within the
framework which we have it's instructive
isn't it there was 16 plus unemployment
rate at 3.1 percent uh unemployment rate
of 3.1 percent an employment rate of 76
and a half percent and an economic
inactivity rate down to 21 as Scotland
has the best employment best
unemployment and blessed economic
inactivity rate of any of the nations of
the UK it demonstrates rather clearly
that the competent and compassionate SNP
government can deliver unemployment
where the UK government is failing yeah
and on and ongoing green again the
chancellor made great matter of this
there were some interesting thing said
the billion pounds a year investment or
so in carbon capture and Storage
to be welcomed but we will look very
carefully to see where it is spent there
was no mention for example of the acorn
project in peterhead a project of course
that had a billion pounds of funding
pooled almost a decade ago but he did
mention small modular reactors a nuclear
power which of course is at the heart of
the government's energy policy I think
it's useful given this is now back on
the agenda that we look at the economics
of this
the primary o and on SMR before I moved
on remember this is paid theme stuff
there's not a single small modular
reaction reactive design which has even
been licensed for use for the primary
mechanism to drive investment in nuclear
is either the regulated asset based
model or a guaranteed price for
electricity with a strike price it
almost double that of a real renewable
energy linked to CPI for 35 years that a
loan guarantees to transfer project risk
risk including that of course overruns
to the government and then the taxpayer
there's a waste disposal service for
spent Fuel and Fuel and other waste and
the price of those contracts is set
according to the government's
methodology but if the price go above a
cap they too will be passed to the
government and the taxpayer and then of
course there's a commitment by
government to manage decommissioning
cost overruns even though it is
impossible to know what they'll be
because they do not become come apparent
until the decommissioning takes place
massive costs to the consumer and a near
unlimited contingent risk placed on the
taxpayer but here's the Rob when they
call it green or renewable allowing one
or two generations to buy expensive
overpriced nuclear energy nuclear
electricity and then forcing the next 50
generations to decommission store and
guard toxic nuclear waste is not green
now you will recall I'm sure Madam
Deputy speaker
that the government introduced their new
fiscal Charter last year net debt to
fall as a share of GDP in the fifth year
of a rolling program in public sector
net borrowing not to exceed three
percent of GDP in the same year now when
the obr reported in the Autumn those
targets were due to be met in 27 28.
0.3 0.6 9.5 billion and 18.6 billion if
my memory sells now they're forecast
today still to be met interesting though
the net debt measure is now showing a
margin of only 0.2 percent
what this does tell us though because
the debt figure is different is that
there's probably a little more Headroom
than anticipated only four months ago
so the expectation should have been
that the treasury did more to tackle
domestic and business energy costs
particularly for smes that they continue
to act as squeeze inflation down where
it had the power to do so and that it
ensures things within its control public
sector pay the minimum wage the state
pension Social Security Rises as they
did in November do not leave people any
worse off
because if they do not do that into the
future then energy of placites inflation
weak pay Rises will continue to erode
people's standard of living and we
certainly know from the November obr
forecast inflation was set to Peak at a
40-year high and the wages and living
standards were still set to be squeezed
by around seven percent wiping out all
of the growth from the past eight years
what do we know today that we didn't
know then telecoms prices due to rise BT
are putting their costs up 15 at the end
of this month grocery prices continue to
rise if you can get fresh produce at all
grocery inflation Rose in February to a
record high of 17.1 percent that will
add the best part of a thousand pounds
to the average family shopping basket
throughout a year and we know that
families are really beginning to feel
the pain of increased mortgage costs
so it's obvious the government today had
three urgent tasks all of which ought to
have been designed to deal with things
which matter to the public firstly to
continue to support businesses
struggling with high energy costs not
simply to freeze the cap although it is
not a cap at all but to reduce it to
recognize this cap as an average and pay
attention to the fact that a UK average
Energy bill of two and a half thousand
pounds in Scotland will mean three or
three and a half thousand pounds they
should have supported the reduction to
two thousand and maintained the 400
pounds Energy bill support scheme
secondly the government ought to have
continued to Bear Down on inflation and
forcing down Energy prices would have
helped with that as it did last year
three and a half percent last year was
the impact another two percent of the
current rates uh this year and they
could have gone further by mandating The
Regulators to stop the blatant price
gouging of profit dealing by energy and
telecoms and thirdly as I've said they
needed to ensure today or even signal
their attention when it comes to the
things under their control the next
round of public sector pay benefits
minimum wage pension settlements that
nobody falls behind and they could have
gone further to introduce real fairness
and raise more cash to really support
the economy and really boost trade
ending non-dom status not mentioned
today taxing share BuyBacks not
mentioned today not doing but scrapping
costly costly vanity nuclear power
projects and investing in real green
Renewables
and fundamentally modern Deputy speaker
rejoining the EU single Market to give
our exporters on our economy a fighting
chance to recover
before I I call the next honorable
member it will be obvious that a great
many people wish to speak this afternoon
I would prefer not to have to put a time
limit on and we managed without a time
limit if everybody sticks to around
seven minutes you can say a lot in seven
minutes
um but if we can't manage to uh have a
self-imposed
rule then we will put on a time limit
pretty Patel thank you madam Deputy
speaker my open my remark for having
Deputy speaker by welcoming you back to
the chair
ones please hear you as well as see you
today in robust form
um now Madame Deputy speaker as a former
treasury Minister I understand the
challenges that my right-home friend the
chancellor and his treasury colleagues
and all the officials
um have been confronted with and faced
with and the lobbying the Relentless
lobbying from the back benches as well
and that they have facing putting this
important budget together and I do
actually want to pay tribute to them all
and to my Martin friendly Chancellor in
particular that work and the work that
takes place in balancing the different
and contrasting interests and
representations received is difficult
and it is challenging and of course no
budget will please everyone there's no
doubt about that and there are always
more demands for more resources more
Simplicity and I could read off a list
but I'm not just going to do that right
now but importantly the key test for any
budget are whether it ensures that
there's a robust framework place in
place for sound money and of course that
that is exactly what this part in this
part in government stands for we do
believe in sound money we do believe in
balancing the food and we believe in
growing our economy and giving the
people the freedom to succeed through
many of the measures my right and friend
of chancellor has spoken about today and
of course that includes whether it
maintains a strong fiscal position and
stability and whether it delivers fiscal
and supply-side reforms to enable of
course the private sector to grow and
flourish and of course my friend
chancellor has also mentioned a former
Chancellor today of course Lord Lawson
who did exactly that and those pillars
are absolutely fundamental to the health
and well-being and the Integrity of any
sound policy whether it's fiscal or
monetary behind growing the economy
which then leads to supporting new jobs
creating wealth in our country to
sustain public services and I think on
that point I think we should all just
dwell upon you know that comment in
relation to what the party's opposite
are advocating which which would lead to
Greater instability and I'm afraid more
debt without getting too party political
at this early stage of my remarks and I
do believe that this budget has combined
many of those elements bear in mind we
still face the challenges of the
pandemic Global inflationary pressures
which have disrupted with our economy
and sometimes I do feel that in this
house in particular perhaps party's
opposite fail to realize the extent of
that just disruption and the
displacement that that has led to in
terms of the fiscal position of our
government and that is very significant
and what I do I have to say I like to
see and I have seen today is that the
government is not fearful when it comes
to pursuing an ambitious pro-growth
agenda that does seek to reduce tax
burden I'm going to come on to that
shortly but this budget also makes
progress towards a good direction and
there are a few areas that I will come
on to when it comes to economic growth
this being a budget for growth and that
is also about about investment in people
our economy and the long-term future of
our country first of all Madam Deputy
speaker I would like to ask the
chancellor and he's heard me on this and
I'm very grateful I'm personally
grateful to him on this
um to continue to keep the wider
approach to corporation tax under review
I've absolutely heard what the
chancellor has said today in terms of
the tax incentives that are going to be
put in place at 9 billion pounds which I
understand will be tapered depending on
businesses and their level of
Investments and I think there is an
important message here that we all know
it's a message that maybe we do not have
not spoken about enough many businesses
not all businesses because it depends on
their sizes have been sitting on vast
levels of investment that they've not
had the confidence to actually release
for investment purposes I have no doubt
that today's measures will absolutely
lead to that but as an Essex MP where we
represent you know the bulk of small and
medium-sized businesses they are the
ones that we have to think of and we
must be putting out the hand of support
to them in particular our country thanks
to previous policies under conservative
government has led to the flowering of
many many thousands millions of smes I
come from that background myself there
are so many others that do we need them
to be the lifeblood to our economy and
also to grow jobs and employment in this
country but of course you know tax
nonprofits of businesses you know the
increasing corporation tax the changes
that have been brought in you know will
seem attractive but obviously the devil
will be in the detail and of course we
must continue to work through that and
there is nothing that we want to do in
terms of frustrating business investment
we believe in growth and that is
absolutely why and I was delighted to
hear the chancellor go back to 2010
actually to remind this house and the
country of what we face back of the
struggles the difficulties but that
became the start to the cuts
incorporation tax to help businesses
grow and of course that is effectively
the overall direction of travel that was
supported on this side which the other
side obviously had quite a different
Legacy I do believe that there is more
that we can do in unleashing a wave of
pro-growth business reforms and
transform our economy even more
particularly post-brexit Britain
post-brexit is about yes International
Partnerships bilateral agreements but
also shown that we are the place to come
and invest leveraging our markets our
Capital markets in particular
demonstrating that we have the financial
capabilities to continue to grow but
also get that investment back into our
country and I do believe just on the
issue of Corporation tags when it comes
to the wider prospectus of the minimum
rates of corporation tax which my right
on for the chance has heard me out on
many times and other college days we
know that the introduction of the
minimum effective tax rate will be
delayed in Washington and other
countries and I would just ask him again
to think carefully about the timing of
this why now let us absolutely focus on
the budgetary measures he's announced
today and ensure that that does
everything possible to unleash the
business potential and the economic
growth that we desperately want to see
and rightly want to see so I will
continue to work with him on that issue
but I do just want to of course mention
everything that has been announced today
when it comes to Enterprise zones
unlocking potentials of our countries
different regions in our economy
particularly again through leveling up
but also when it comes to the tax
deductions will be absolutely vital and
I absolutely believe that that will help
in terms of future capital investment
and further supply side reforms that
help to basically build our
infrastructure invest in people see jobs
being dispersed around the country and
when we've never seen before you know
well certainly not you know in my life
time in this Parliament but actually
generationally as well is absolutely
crucial it really is and so I'm
delighted with the work and the
announcements today when it comes to
pensions lifetime tax allowances child
care in particular and I say this is
actually I was the treasury Minister
that worked back in the day to bring in
tax-free child care and again I think
this is important that we focus on in
particular those low-income households
those that struggle actually to get
their foot on the ladder when it comes
to child care but also even getting
sustainable employment and having been
the Full Employment Minister and I did
work obviously with the right honorable
gentlemen my I write humble friend for
chingford and Woodford green at the time
DWP we saw so many challenges with the
introduction of Universal Credit we
wanted to make reforms through work
capability assessments these are going
to be vital labor market reforms that
will help to get more people back into
work and I absolutely endorse the
chances work on that and colleagues
across the government as well
he will not be surprised I do want to
welcome his announcement today on
freezing fuel Duty and keeping the
reduction that was brought in last year
and of course my art of a friend will
understand the difficulties and actually
the pressures household budgets he has
spoken about that very strongly today
being on the side of hard press motor is
hard-pressed taxpayers we have to stand
up for them and times have been tough on
that we know of course about the
implications around oh well the forecast
actually in November's obr report alone
did bring concerns to families and the
Headroom that has now transpired is
welcome and this is an important welcome
and a great buffer I think for motorists
but actually for the country and keeping
field Duty down of course is going to
help the government meet its ambitious
Targets in terms of producing inflation
everybody wants to see inflation come
down for the right reasons that is again
how we grow the economy and this will
save the hard-pressed families hundreds
of pounds a year but in including
businesses and again when we look at
Logistics firms I represent Witham we
are full of logistic firms we have ports
surrounding us now we're very proud of
our pause we're proud of the work that
they do they will absolutely be benefit
um benefit from benefit from this and we
have a proud record in supporting the
nation's motorists for 13 years it's a
record we should always remind everyone
across the country and supporting of
course those
um hard pressed motorists as well that
of course compares to what we've seen in
previous governments I do think though
families and businesses in London and
Essex and the surrounding areas will
look at what we've done on food Duty
against what the mayor of London is
proposing on you there's
um and I think that is absolutely
somewhere else that is a charge that
will hit low-income families and of
course while conservatives are
constantly tackling those issues around
high taxes this is absolutely absolutely
the right challenge we should be pushing
out as well Madam Deputy speaker I would
just like to make a few other
observations what is on infrastructure
and to comment on the needs of
infrastructure and of course that is
down to the supply side it reforms in
particular Essex is a county of
entrepreneurs and of course our road
network is absolutely vital my right
humble friend has heard me speak about
va120 the a12 all those fantastic roads
that I'm afraid are gridlocked we need
the wider investment because that's the
only way we keep our haulage haulages
moving our motor is traveling but in
particular making sure that our
transport is fit for the future and that
does come from treasury Investments as
well I'm going to conclude my remarks
might have Deputy speaker in the
interest of time but I do commend my
writing friend Chancellor for the way in
which he has approached this project he
said to me last year we will have a
budget for growth he is true to his word
there'll be areas where I would like to
follow up with him and ministers but I
do want to thank him for the one which
he's engaged very constructively listen
to commuters listen to motorists listen
to the voice of Ethics as well but
others around the country yeah
thank you madam Deputy speaker man
Deputy speaker you think from the noises
on the other side of the house that this
was a Triumph but let's not forget who
is responsible for this state of the
economy that we have today wages aren't
low in real terms now than they were in
2010 and we are growing slower than most
members of the G7 and obviously kovid
the war in Ukraine have knocked the
economy but it was this government
that allowed a fraud and error under
covid schemes to hit the billions of
pounds much of which as the Public
Accounts committee is repeatedly
highlighted will never be recovered
billions that could have been invested
in public services and in many of the
measures that the chancellor announced
today and it was this conservative
government a conservative prime minister
and Chancellor that crashed the economy
last Autumn and have left Havoc for many
people's lives were a reminder every
time someone goes grocery shopping every
time the mortgage Bill and statement
arise and every time a rent statement
arrives people are reminded that it is
the conservative government that has
crashed this country and it is labor
that will deliver a better solution well
I do welcome a couple of points I should
say in generosity to the chancellor the
support for leisure centers and swimming
pools much needed and the prepayment
meter changes are long overdue so that
is good to see and scrapping local local
leps and giving local authorities the
opportunity to lead in their area is
also long overdue and again Public
Accounts committee has repeatedly
highlighted concerns about how leps
spent money locally with no
accountability I'm all for involving
businesses and others in an area in
decisions for the future but for those
to be led without accountability was
unforgivable so it's great to see that
change finally coming through after much
pressure and it is necessary to see an
increase in money for defense partly
because of the challenges that have been
thrown up by the war in the Ukraine in
Ukraine but it is absolutely vital that
that money must come with real rigor on
spending and project management at every
step of the way repeatedly the Public
Accounts committee highlights the
defense equipment plan and the
efficiencies that never materialize and
the overruns on cost and a mere rounding
error in some of these large defense
projects would build a new school or
maybe one of those wanted 14 new
hospitals that we have yet to see I
represent many great pubs in Hackney
South and shoreditch so it's great to
see an 11 reduction in pints but if you
add take that into account with business
rates going through the roof energy
bills your top people tied pubs tied
very often to energy bills that were
that are very high and ramped up from in
some cases more than 200 percent and in
one case I had a 700 uh rise one of my
pubs had in seven percent 100 rise in
their energy bills add to that rent
increases and other bills going up if if
11p a pint is not going to make the
difference when some of my pubs have
told me that they would need to charge
15 pounds a pint or even 18 pounds a
pint uh in just to break even a Madam
Deputy speaker even in shoreditch that
would be an extraordinarily and
unachievable amount for people to spend
so I can see where the plants are coming
from trying to get people the footfall
into pubs I applaud the idea but he
needs to get into the real world and
maybe come and meet some of the
publicans and Hackney South and
shoreditch I'll buy him a Pikeman and
Deputy speaker if he looks looks them in
the eye and tells them that this is a
success
the child care changes or something I've
been campaigning on for a long time and
a welcoming principle but and it's
heartening to see I'd say the chance of
taking a leaf out of Hackney Labor's
Playbook
um where Hackney Council led a
successful program to give grants to
child minders to encourage them to take
up the work actually grants so that
those places could be provided for
working parents but quality is as vital
as cost for parents and I speak as a
working mother here of three having had
a baby while in the house knowing that
all those fantastic child carers were
only were good and it was the quality of
that child care that made me able to
come and do my job they are they are
often not recognized enough so it's good
that we're talking about it today but
the chancellor is borrowing from the
right honorable member of Norfolk the
former prime minister's Playbook she was
the minister who proposed that she would
this pile them high and teach them cheap
approach to child care and I worry about
the change in ratios heartens at its
only voluntary but these voluntary
changes creep in and the money proposed
will take a long time to deliver the
people and the places and the certainty
for child care businesses and
individuals to invest and if we if we
don't get that right and those ratios
those payments are not uprated we will
see that ratio increase creep in as a
norm and that will be a deterrent I
think for many working parents I said I
speak very much to myself I would not
have been able to come to work and do
the job I do if I hadn't been confident
in the quality as well as the cost of
child care and of course I'm a
privileged Member of Parliament who
could afford a quality child care and we
need to make sure that's available to
everybody but this budget does nothing
to solve the fundamental problem in my
constituency which is the housing
situation we have eight and a half
thousand people on the wait list for
Council housing and that's not just
though there are many more who want it
but they're the ones who qualify under
the rules which are now quite stringent
on average it's a nine year wait for a
three-bedroom property a three-year wait
for a one-bedroom property but these are
no national uh weights I every week I
visit people on their doorstep go into
their homes and see the overcrowding and
on Monday at my surgery someone came to
see me he's living in a in the private
sector renting a one-bedroom flat he his
two children and his wife live there he
works he works hard he wants to save up
to buy his own home but he can't do that
while he's renting privately he can't
get a council property because he can't
qualify for that even with that level of
overcrowding and that's not the worst
overcrowding I've seen I see four the
week before I was visiting a woman and
she has four daughters uh in a
two-bedroom flat and a small tiny
kitchen one living space and the tiniest
bathroom you see cubicles in this place
Amanda Deputy speaker would be bigger
than their entire bathroom so this is a
real challenge for people without a fun
fundamentally without a secure roof over
your head you cannot operate and right
this doesn't even go into the issues for
Generation renting the private rented
sector but let's be clear it is this
government there's an absolutely ripped
up the opportunity for people to have a
safe and stable home this is the
government that has or the party that
has lived off the back of right to buy
giving people a roof over their head
which we're not going to go into right
to buy but they have nothing to offer
generation rent people desperate for
Council housing who can't afford to rent
privately and they've done nothing on
that and I'm very concerned I just want
to touch on pensions the problems of
Lifetime allowance was first flagged by
the Public Accounts Committee in 2012.
we're here in 2023 and it's been
reversed but I think Madame Deputy
speaker no chance there should ever be
allowed near pensions this has they make
an announcement in their budget about a
pension there's no analysis or impact
over the decades that you need to
consider those decisions in and no
revisiting or operating for many years
and it was um it was out of kilter with
other pension changes which causes
ongoing problems and there's nothing
with this lifetime allowance has been
abolished that helps the richest one
percent but nothing for the poorer
workers who are in Auto enrollment which
is a good first step but nowhere near
enough to stop the ticking time bomb
that will be poorer Panthers and future
that will cost the exchequer in terms of
benefits in years to come and it will do
nothing I don't I think to reverse the
Exodus of people leaving it might stop
some people and their tracks and make
them think but many will have already
made their pension plans and many people
have now factored in the idea of a lower
pension and local work for doctors or a
second new job for those who are not
doctors and decided that's an option and
that is now built into the way of
thinking after over a decade of that
approach because of the lifetime
allowance which was never uprated but
look in Hackney Madam Deputy speaker
nearly one in two children live in
poverty and of those 61 are in working
households there are small measures in
the budget here that might help them a
little but it's not enough to tackle the
real issue of the Working Poor in my
constituency and there's really no hope
on housing as I've said for Generation
rent and families who need that without
that housing base there is nothing that
they can do to improve their lord they
can work as hard as they want but
they'll never be able to pay the rent
and we this is thin pickings Madam
Deputy speaker for people who face
systemic lifestyle challenges every day
and I don't think the chancellor has
delivered for them
name Andrea Lancer
thank you madam Deputy speaker well I
take a different view to The Honorable
lady for whom I have greatness yeah yeah
but I I actually personally feel that
this is an excellent budget and I'd like
to um set out some reasons why but also
some questions for the chancellor and
for his team so to start with cost of
living that is obviously the single
biggest issue for all of our
constituents and has been for some time
I think that the fuel Duty freeze is an
excellent and absolutely essential
decision but again like my honorable
friend the treasury select committee
chair I do wonder why we continue to
have that automatic fuel Duty rise which
was introduced by the last Labor
government and which is always costed in
to every obr forecast and gives people
concern I think it needs to be something
that is perhaps scrapped altogether
secondly with energy bills fantastic to
be giving people that extra bit of
support until the spring when it gets
warm of people are not using fuel so
much and it is widely anticipated that
bills will come down anyway but again I
would like to see the chancellor giving
thought to encouraging energy suppliers
to offer fixed rates term fixed rates
like you have with a mortgage so that
you can have a fixed rate for your
energy bills for the next one or two
years
I'm very happy to I'm grateful to her
for giving way but I do just want to
come back to this fuel Duty issue
because I know that she has been
concerned about climate change at least
in the past and the cuts in fuel due to
indeed that the freezes in in the field
Duty has meant that emissions have gone
up five percent at the same time the
treasury is lost out on billions of
funding so she really wants to help long
hard-pressed drivers and others then why
won't you look at something like a a
wealth tax for example a wealth tax on
the one percent richest people could
raise up to 70 billion pounds she could
then help those drivers but she could
also be helping public transport the pay
sector people who are out on the strike
right now they're out on the streets
they want us to have more funding why
isn't she doing that
yeah well
um where I agree with the honorable lady
is that decarbonization is vital but
where we park companies I think people
have to live in the meantime and I think
some of the ideas that she puts forward
are utterly unworkable and unpractical
so coming on to child care costs
fantastic news something that I think is
going to be transformational for so many
families and I know there are lots of
honorable colleagues across the house
who've been campaigning for that for a
long time I would however like to ask
the treasury team to consider going
further and that is to looking at an
attendance allowance for grandparents
who are looking after their
grandchildren it's something that so
many families would like to take
advantage of and too many grandparents
simply can't afford it because it means
they have to give up their income and in
fact it'll cost them money to do it I
also think we need to look further at
child mind of Regulation and
particularly one of the regulations is
having to have fire doors across your
house at huge expense to a child minder
who's wanting to start up of course it's
a huge obstacle for people wanting to
offer that flexible choice for families
so secondly I'd like to
address the issue of quality of life and
I think this budget goes a long way to
helping people with quality of life in
particular helping people with
disabilities and long-term illnesses
into work I have constituents come to my
surgeries who are desperate and who feel
that they're just on the scrappy because
nobody will give them a job it is so
difficult so I really do applaud that I
also think helping people with upfront
child care costs when they're on
Universal Credit I had a Ukrainian
family staying with me with an
eight-year-old and a two-year-old
daughter and it was a huge issue helping
my guest to apply for Universal Credit
and then for the child care element
inevitably I could lend her the money
for child care costs but for somebody
who can't get that this is absolutely
essential to help them and then the
third element is help for the over 50s I
absolutely applaud the government for
encouraging people providing support for
getting people back into the workplace
but I would again like to highlight the
fact that very often it's women over 50
who find they're applying for job after
job and getting nowhere quite often
because they've been out of the
workplace for quite some time
in terms of pension cap and the annual
allowance that's fantastic news and that
is is actually something where I do
agree with the honorable lady the member
for Hackney is that this should have
been done a long time ago there is no
question it has encouraged people to
think well there's no point carrying on
working because I can't improve my um
quality of life in retirement and
although these some sounds a lot they
don't actually deliver a decent pension
for people so I think this is essential
and you know sad to say for many
colleagues in this house but it might
even keep me working Madame Deputy
speaker
oh that's right cheers
thank you
um but again
um it is it is very important that we
continue to look at the um at the issues
for those who already fixed their
maximum
um pension cap back over recent years
because some people fixed it at one
point 2 million or 1.4 million what are
we going to do about them I think that
will be an issue for some people be a
draft Duty that's fantastic that's
really going to help us a great quality
of life moves but in my constituency of
South northamptonshire with 92 villages
we really need buses so that we can get
to those pubs and there wasn't anything
for buses so that's another pitch the
pothole news fantastic but let's see
some innovative ways of fixing them too
often potholes get fixed and a couple of
weeks later there's a pothole again
where it was so we need to think about
that and also clearing litter from roads
you know some of these quality of life
issues that have just badgered us in our
constituencies for so long we could do a
lot more about
so quality of life great more to do the
third area I wanted to cover is business
and I think the tax incentive to invest
in new plant and machinery would be a
massive boost for business the
chancellor is absolutely right in his
focus on GDP per capita by improving
investment and reducing the lower
quality jobs we've got to move to more
automation more use of Technology better
quality higher paid jobs that is
absolutely right to be doing that and
secondly the chancer is absolutely right
to be focused on R D and science the
chancellor gave very impressive
statistics regarding our performance in
the UK in a globally competitive
environment and certainly our progress
is very strong as a former base
secretary myself I met amazing
businesses in space technology and in
cutting-edge life science and also in
nuclear visiting the brilliant Fusion
project in Cullen and working with the
Rolls-Royce LED Consortium in small
module reactors I absolutely applaud the
Chancellor's commitment to nuclear as
well as to carbon capture usage and
storage the big challenge of our age is
keeping the lights on keeping the cost
of bills down and decarbonizing you
can't do any one of those on their own
you've got to keep that energy trilemma
in balance it is the critical challenge
of our age I do think that there is much
more the government could and should be
doing to build more electricity
infrastructure to promote more
Renewables with much better local
payback and also to make homes and
businesses far more energy efficient I
think too little work has gone into that
and I would commend to my honorable
friend on the front bench the 1922
backbench committee report on the future
for energy and that is a committee that
I chair it has a wealth of practical
actions in fact I think 29 of them and I
do urge the chancellor in the whole
fresh routine to take a close look
finally
I want to cover the issue of Finance
like many I was heartily relieved by the
obr's revised forecasts today but I do
Wonder does the chancellor worry about
the impact of forecasting on business
and consumer confidence I personally do
worry that some of the incredibly
negative forecasting that we've seen
recently can become a self-fulfilling
prophecy seeing the astonishment on some
of the faces opposite at the great
achievements of the UK since 2010 from
halving unemployment to reducing poverty
to the huge growth in female
entrepreneurship and the success in
leveling up right across the UK there is
so much to be proud of but also as many
of my constituents ask me what more can
we do to get the positive messages
across and the same is true of brexit
from new trade deals to freedom on taxes
on subsidies to improved Financial
regulation and our influence in the
world how can the chancellor make sure
we're getting the positive messages
about brexit across to our to our
constituents finally a plea from an
ex-city Minister and someone who was on
the treasury Committee in 2010 when the
last Labor government wrecked our
economy there have been many good
reforms made to strengthen the banking
sector and I do urge the chancellor to
keep ring fencing in place thank you
um I do want to emphasize it's not fair
on others if we don't stick to the
guidance given by the chairman of ways
and means which was seven minutes that
may well have to go down but I do urge
colleagues to be mindful of that advice
Sir George Howard thank you yeah Madam
Deputy speaker and it was a pleasant uh
it was a pleasure to see the uh
honorable that the chairman chair of
ways and means in the chair
um who's still here
um
Madame Deputy speaker as with most
budgets the next few days will show the
extent to which the Chancellor's
rhetoric and the measures he's announced
stand up this scrutiny
but the early indications are that
as my right honorable friendly leader of
the opposition pointed out in his
response it doesn't undo the damage of
the last 13 years
and nor does it resolve the doubts about
the Strategic economic direction of the
future
two problems have already been
highlighted
the officer's office of budget
responsibility are forecasting a fall in
real incomes of 5.7 over the next two
years
and that means the cost of living crisis
that many of our constituents are facing
in very real terms will continue
uh the second is the adjusted for
inflation
real wages have fallen recently by about
3.2 percent
now the chancellor has in the budget
signaled measures to boost productivity
and of course in principle that is
important it's important particularly to
our need for greater economic growth
which is also referred to
The Honorable lady for horn castle of
now who I'm pleased to see is in her
place
um is aware that along with the right up
the honorable member for old
triggerman's sale and others from
various parties across all of the house
I have a tabled earlier sorry last year
a 10-minute rule bill which was aimed at
reforming employee
ownership schemes
um
the and so I welcome the reference in
the red book
to the uh research that the department
has commissioned into these schemes how
they're doing and how they can be
improved
and I've welcomed the engagement we've
had with the uh honorable lady which is
much appreciated
well I I want to use this opportunity
um
to Madam Deputy speaker to give notice
that the honorable gentleman for Ultra
Goodman's sale
um subject to the provisions of the
finance bill hoped a table an amendment
which would create a new employee share
ownership scheme for the benefits of low
paid workers
this proposal would
in addition to helping those vulnerable
to still acute cost of living problems
that I've already referred to
to achieve greater Financial stability
it would also boost productivity in
those companies that take such a scheme
of board
I believe moreover that Madam Deputy
speaker that The Honorable lady for
horncastle and love is favorable you
disposed to such a scheme whether or not
she accepts our Amendment will remain to
be seen at least in principle
and I would be grateful if she could
give some indication of her willingness
to continue to work with the honorable
gentleman for old Sugarman sale and
others from all corners of the house to
bring about the sort of changes that we
hope to achieve in employees share
ownership
Sir John Redford I've declared my
business interests in the register
I strongly welcome all the measures in
the budget to try and help more people
into work the government is absolutely
right that we want to move away from the
model of always inviting in many
hundreds of thousands of people from
abroad to take low-paid jobs here we
need to work away at having more
worthwhile and better paid jobs here
with the right supporting investment and
training and I look forward to seeing
the benefits in my working and
constituency of more and cheaper child
care of a decent standard of better help
for the disabled of improvements in the
tax and benefit system so that it is
even more worthwhile to go into work and
any supporting training packages or
confidence building activities that may
be needed so that those people can get
into jobs it is very welcome and it will
make an important contribution not just
to our economy and its prospects but
also to our wider Society where I would
like to take issue with with the chance
from the government is over they're
correctly specified need to boost
investment and to get a lot more company
activity in growing what we do here in
Britain I welcome the AIM and I of
course appreciate that 100 first year
allowance will be helpful but we need to
remember that it's a replacement for an
even more generous allowance and it's
coming in at the same time that they are
proposing a 31 increase in the rate of
business taxation on profits now on a
couple of occasions in the past I did
lead industrial International companies
and as I have no more interest in those
areas I can draw some conclusions from
my experiences and when we were making
those decisions about where you put the
new product or the new investment where
you expanded the workforce where you
might need a new Factory of course the
headline rate of Taxation in any country
concern that might be on your long list
was a relevant consideration it's also
true that when you've got down to a
short list and countries with high rates
didn't tend to get onto the shortlist
unless you're already there you then did
detailed analyzes of the project and any
first year allowance or initial
allowance would make a positive
difference but if over a 20 25 year life
of a factory or project that you're
looking at you're going to be paying 31
more profits tax on it it's clearly not
going to look nearly as good as it does
this year in the United Kingdom with one
of the the lower tax rates in the world
the government needs to understand that
exactly the time where it's putting the
rate up our competitors are going the
other way particularly the United States
of America where although the government
says their headline rate is slightly
higher than our ours the details of the
inflation reduction act make it very
clear that there will be all sorts of
tax breaks incentives and subsidies for
a wide range of Industries including
some of the industries the government
wishes to Target here like digital and
green and that would be a very important
counter magnet to the Investments that
we could otherwise get like ask an
English-speaking country with common law
principles and so forth they have many
advantages and we need to have a better
offer to counter them even closer to
home and proof that lower corporation
tax rates work for the businesses and
for the society that uses them is of
course the Republic of Ireland and the
Republic of Ireland has the lowest tax
rate of the Main advanced countries
competing for investment a relatively
small country it has achieved Giant
Steps with attracting large amounts of
investment much of which would otherwise
I think have come to the United Kingdom
by having that much much better rate of
corporation tax and so the the proof
that lower rates produce more revenue
and help more growth is in the way in
which Irish GDP per head is so much
higher than United Kingdoms and the way
in which business tax per head raised is
so much higher I think it's four times
higher in the Republic of Ireland than
it is here at home in the United Kingdom
so I would ask the government to look
again
uh the final point that I can fit in is
that I do think the government needs to
look at this on a sector-by-sector basis
as well the energy sector is capital
intensive it's one of the areas where
you could get a lot of big investment
quite quickly with a lot of very
well-paid jobs improve your National
energy security cut the import Bill and
gain an awful lot of future tax revenue
because we do tax energy so much higher
than other things but because now we
have this incredibly complicated system
with price controls on domestic energy
with windfall taxes with carbon taxes
and then with subsidies to the industry
itself as we realize the the
difficulties that the high tax rates are
causing we are causing complication but
more importantly we're putting off many
big potential investors who would
otherwise get out more oil and gas from
our own reserves and would produce more
deliverable Renewable Power and and help
expand the grid which will need to
happen if you're going to carry on with
those developments if you take heavy
Industries Ceramics and steel and so
forth big energy users I think we have
the highest carbon taxes of any of the
major countries we have some of the
highest energy prices on top of the very
high carbon taxes and so it means we are
not competitive in things like steel and
Ceramics government then has to provide
taxpayers money giving back some of the
tax revenues in the form of subsidies
but it's often too little too late and
then we end up losing capacity so I
would say to the government stop this
subsidy win for tax High tax model it is
not working for the businesses it is not
working for our country it is not
raising additional revenues to spend on
other things conscious of colleagues
wish to get in all my other analysis and
comments we put on my website in the
usual way
Deputy speaker and I'll go straight to
the right honorable gentleman's website
as soon as it's up there this despite
all the growth and back to work billing
from tourist central office this was a
budget that was treading water and going
nowhere fast there was nothing effective
on falling real wages which are now in a
not equal since the Napoleonic War in
fact the obr says that wages are
expected to fall by 5.7
over the next two years the largest
Falls since records began after 13
wasted Tory years we have a productivity
problem so entrenched that the UK is now
the only G7 economy which has not yet
returned to its pre-covered pandemic
levels of output and the bank of England
does not expect this Milestone to be
reached until 2026 at the earliest and
before party opposite stop blaming
Global factors for This Global factors
then to explain our alarming relative
decline they don't explain why under
this government the UK is stuck in the
economic slow lane all economies have
had to deal with the impact of the
coveted endemic and the war in Ukraine
but only the UK has managed to go from
being one of the most robust economies
in the G7 to one of the weakest the
decade of austerity that followed the
banking crisis left us unprepared for
future challenges and brexit has had a
further dismal effect on our economic
prospects both were deliberatory choices
I'm happy because
um I I do however think it is important
to recognize companies like Ireland for
example have now the highest rates of
debt and all of the EU the United
Kingdom doesn't have that
um does the member not recognize that
the issues that have been raised today
with regards to fuel will help vast
rural constituencies like mine and get
mobility of people who are poor
um addressed in a way which hasn't been
the case here before I'm coming to
I'm coming to some in in individual
issues later but obviously the fuel
issue is very important to those in uh
constituencies like The Honorable
gentleman's the self-harm of
unilaterally deciding to impose trade
barriers on our closest trading
Partnerships was unique to the UK this
generated huge regulatory uncertainty
for business and hindered the
recruitment of workers and was done in
measurable and senseless damage to our
economic prospects the obr forecast said
that brexit would cost up to four
percent of GDP twice the losses
inflicted by the covid-19 pandemic and
it has and in fact today's obr document
shows that trade is down on alarming 15
that is the record that this Chancellor
and the Tory party opposite must take
responsibility for after 13 years in
office the tours have given us five
Prime Ministers three in the last six
months seven chancellors four of them in
just three months the catastrophe of
last sept December's mini budget and the
Meltdown in the bond markets that it
caused unremarked upon I think by the
party opposite in today's proceedings
they shredded the UK's reputation abroad
and they were the opposite of fiscally
responsible Little Wonder then that
during this incoherent chaos they've
delivered us the worst of all possible
Worlds the highest tax burden for 70
years up again as a percentage of GDP in
the obr documents today to 37.7
alongside a crumbling infrastructure an
overstretched public services and don't
forget that this chancellor has penciled
in 55 billion more austerity Cuts in
public expenditure to begin conveniently
after the next general election and
today he announced the mere one percent
increase in departmental spending in the
future which is ongoing and damaging
austerity we see our NHS teaching on the
brink with 7.2 million people on waiting
lists and record job vacancy vacancies
our transport system isn't fit for
purpose and the privatized water
industry pollutes our waterways with
sewage while shareholders and Executives
pocket massive profits and put consumer
prices up and we see a brutal cost of
living crisis juxtaposed with soaring
levels of private wealth for the few and
the pension tax cut for the top one
percent that will make that worse Madam
Deputy speaker the last proper budget
was delivered in this house in October
2021 not by the Chancellor's predecessor
or even its predecessor's predecessor
but by the current prime minister who
was the Chancellor's predecessors
predecessors predecessor this farcical
string of irresponsible Tory
administrations has delivered only
uncertainty turmoil and Chaos what they
have not delivered Madam Deputy speaker
is the business certainty or political
stability upon which economic Prosperity
can and must be built and we have all
paid the price there is only one answer
to dysfunction and incompetence on this
scale and that is a wholesale change of
the entire management and I don't mean
the pretend change that this Chancellor
and the unelected Prime Minister
represent all of them are culpable for
The Bleak economic performance those who
cause the problems are incapable of
fixing them the bank of England forecast
that growth will be virtually
non-existent this year and anemic next
year the obr reveals that the economy
will shrink by 0.2 percent this year and
it's downgraded the UK's long-term
forecast in all years afterwards she
didn't discern that from what the
chancellor had to stay in his budget
today this contrast with 2.7 annual
average growth rates achieved between
1998 and 2007 by the last Labor
government if that had been replicated
since 2010 GDP would now be 800 billion
pounds higher had that happened we would
have been able to collect 300 billion in
tax revenues to prepare our economy
properly to face the future in this
budget there's little sign of the
strategic planning needed to improve
productivity performance and therefore
growth perhaps not surprising from a
government which for 13 Wasted Years has
completely failed to develop an
industrial strategy worth the name as it
doesn't really believe that governments
have any legitimate role in guiding
markets we are in the middle of a brutal
cost of living crisis with sharp Falls
in-household living standards for which
the government policies are not
adequately compensating despite the
chances welcome extension of the current
energy cap until summer even with
extended public support Energy prices
are due to be 20 percent higher than
last year soaring inflation set the
poorest hardest because the energy and
food cost makeup a larger share of the
the income of the poorest mortgage costs
are also Rising with interest rates
costing those who have to refix their
mortgages up to 10 percent more many are
paying the many budget premium for the
costs of Tory chaos last year rents are
rising steeply while real wages are
falling for all and those in the public
sector they are falling for the 12th
successive year the today's budget had
nothing to say about that Madam Deputy
speaker real wages are below where there
were 18 years ago and this decline is
forecast to continue for at least this
year and next the chance this decision
to instigate a stealth tax by freezing
income tax thresholds will reduce
take-home pay substantially and make the
cost of living crisis worse for many
already teetering on the brink the obr
shows that these stealth factors will
raise 29.3 billion because of fiscal
drag equivalent to our four Pence
increase in the basic rate of tax
dragging nearly 6 million people into
higher tax Band rates over the next four
years and you didn't hear Madame Deputy
speaker the chancellor referred to that
in his budget either
thank you madam Deputy speaker and the
chancellor always has more people asking
for things than he can possibly Grant
um but what I know is that everyone on
this side and all of the things that we
ask for are designed to help back
British businesses and go for growth so
that we can create more jobs and boost
people's wages and the reason we do that
is because all of us know that actually
it's not just about those policies not
just about particular taxes or
particular lines of expenditure but it's
about people and their families out
there and this budget does make positive
steps to support families and make sure
that we're supporting the future of our
country helping with child care
providing the footings for a great
education and also helping people get a
GP appointment and clearing the NHS
backlog and on that last point which I'd
like to turn to First
the abolition of doctors taxes in this
budget shows that tax tax reform doesn't
necessarily mean putting money in
people's pockets good though that is it
can be a simpler tax system that creates
positive outcomes for our country and
backs our Public Services by abolishing
the lifetime allowance by increasing the
annual allowance by increasing the money
purchase annual allowance we are helping
people provide for their own Futures and
supporting our NHS
but I would of course
um ask uh my honorable friend on the
front bench and uh the chancellor to
bear in mind that there is always more
to do and there are still tax traps
there for some of our doctors for
example 62 and a half percent tax trap
between 100 and 125 000 pounds which
affects some of our most qualified
Medics who want to retain in our NHS to
help provide the care we need of course
it goes down to 45 Pence after 125 000
pounds which shows that it is a trap and
I hope that the government will look at
that in the weeks months and years ahead
there is also a 71 tax trap for families
between fifty thousand and sixty
thousand pounds which affects some of
our younger doctors and we should be
finding ways to deal with that but I do
welcome the Chancellor's commitment to
helping families with the cost of child
care specifically it is a great start of
a ten finding ways to keep the cost of
child okay down for parents is important
but we mustn't lose sight of keeping the
cost of child care down for the taxpayer
too and it is extraordinary to see some
people uh opposite and elsewhere attack
the alignment of the system in England
with now the system in Scotland
increasing from one to four to one to
five but what is missing is choice
now for 25 years the consensus has been
that everyone should go to work and the
state will provide ever more free child
care except that it isn't free taxes are
at a 70-year high and I would contend
that choice is missing from the equation
instead of a one-size-fits-all system
from Whitehall families should be able
to decide what works for them instead of
government dictating how many hours of
free child care and who from in the
years ahead what about moving to a
system of tax reliefs so that parents
can pay for the child care they want
from who they want
or indeed even a radical thought one
parent could choose to stay at home
allowing the other to work extra hours
if that's what they want to do and so I
would urge the treasury and my honorable
friends to consider
reigniting the review into family
taxation things may have changed since
2019 but I recall that single people in
2019 without a family paid eight percent
lower tax than the oecd average but
single earners who in a capital have two
children pay 26 percent more there is an
injustice in this that I hope the
government will address uh in the not
too distant future by commissioning a
family tax review and that tax review
should should actually reflect the fact
that familial support not only for child
care but also for elderly relatives
provide something like one trillion
pounds of unpaid care in this country
which people could decide to pass to the
state I do not believe that's desirable
and I believe that the state should in
turn provide the environment that allows
people to take responsibility for
themselves
on wrap around Child Care
um I believe this is an excellent step
to help working parents and not have to
worry about what happens after school
time but I would urge the government to
make sure that we are giving that money
direct to schools and to academies to do
what is right providing a co-curricular
offer that is suitable for that
particular community and the children
that they know best rather than any
government department or indeed any
local Authority
and if I can turn then to business
because we can't pay for any of this
without strong British businesses I do
welcome the full expensing of the uh
business investment this is a good step
to ensure that businesses can take
decisions today but as my right
honorable friend the member for working
mentioned a moment ago we should still
still seek to revisit corporation tax in
the months and years ahead because any
increase in corporation tax will make us
less competitive reduce investment in
the long run stifle job creation all of
which are required for growth and we've
seen that with with AstraZeneca decide
to move a what would have been a 300
million pound investment in the
northwest of England to Ireland which
not only means a lack of business taxes
being paid in this country but also the
personal taxes that would have been paid
by the hard-working people who had
worked at that plant and you don't have
to believe me a Madam Deputy speaker
even the ifs says that this won't raise
the expected Revenue the increase in
corporation tax won't raise the expected
Revenue
um that uh that is currently suggested
by some and Europe economics has said it
will muffle our growth potential 30
billion pounds less over 10 years
one final idea Madam Deputy speaker I'd
urge um the chancellor and my my humble
friend to look at the vat threshold for
small businesses into the future today
it is at 85 000 pounds it's been like
that since 2017. it's planned to remain
like that until at least 2026. the
fiscal drag means that 60
000 extra businesses are being dragged
into this threshold and it holds their
growth and pushes them into the gray
Market
a 250 a thousand pound profit is the
threshold in the new planned corporation
tax and perhaps it's a round figure to
look at a 250 000 pound turnover
threshold for that registration in the
future by not increasing corporation tax
or reversing it in the future by raising
that registration threshold by reversing
ir35 which other members May mention but
I shot Madam Deputy speaker we will be
delivering a 67 billion pound Boost
after 10 years on top of other growth in
the British economy investment would be
up jobs will be created and it will pay
for itself
Sarah Olney thank you very much Madam
Deputy speaker families were looking at
this budget for support but instead of
throwing them a Lifeline the chancellor
has thrown them under the bus mortgage
bills are up the cost of the weekly shop
is up Energy prices are up all because
of conservative chaos yet this
government has offered no immediate help
with the cost of living they are so out
of touch they might as well be on a
different planet the chancellor could
have done so much more if only he cared
enough he had enough money in the
treasury to cut people's energy bills by
500 pounds and take them down to last
April's levels yet he simply chose not
to and whilst he may claim he is
extending support that's simply not true
people will pay more for their energy
this year than they did last year not
less even though gas prices are falling
in three months time there'll be no
extra help in place whatsoever the 400
pound payment also gone fuel poverty
will get worse not better and the
government will now cut energy support
for businesses by 85 percent those shops
and restaurants that won't be forced to
clothes will have little Choice than to
raise their prices the price of food
clothes the pint in the local pub will
all go up and all because this
government is cutting support to
businesses
Madam Deputy speaker we heard the
chancellor say that this government will
grow the economy by getting people back
to work and what's his plan tinkering
around the edges of a system broken by
his very own government changing pension
rules that won't benefit the majority of
people piecemeal changes to a child care
system that needs wholesale reform and
forcing people with ill health to work
by threatening to take away their
benefits are we really meant to believe
that that's the recipe for economic
growth under this government's watch
more than 7 million people are waiting
for treatment on the NHS and thousands
can't get discharged from hospital when
they're ready because there's no one
there to look after them so I've got
some news for the chancellor people
aren't off work because they're on the
golf course they're off work because
they're stuck on a hospital waiting list
you can't fix the economy if you don't
fix the workforce and you can't fix the
workforce if you don't fix the NHS and
social care giving care workers a pay
Boost of two pound an hour would be a
good way to start and finally fixing our
crumbling hospitals that are crying out
for some proper investment the
governments in he doesn't get that
liberal Democrats have been championing
their need for properly funded genuinely
free child care for years but unless the
government funds free hours at the
actual cost of providing them it will
make the problem even worse a lack of
providers and eye-watering fees for
full-time Child Care Madam Deputy
speaker it takes some real nerve from
the chancellor to say he wants to get
more people into work when he's the one
who throws the personal allowance and
unfair stealth tax penalizing people for
every extra pound they earn
don't take it from me that this
government has no idea how to grow our
economy just look at the figures under
this conservative government the UK is
the only major economy that's still
smaller than before the pandemic the IMF
expects Britain to see the lowest growth
of any other G7 country and whilst
thankfully it looks like a recession
could be avoided this government seems
content with growth moving at a snail's
pace if the bank of England is right the
government's Economic Policy could keep
long-term growth stock at one percent
and what does the obr make of the
announcements we've just heard by 2028
they will add no more than 0.2 percent
to our GDP
what a waste that would be of all the
talent and ambition I see across every
part of the UK but there's no greater
indictment of this government's Economic
Policy than their track record on living
standards the obr today warning of the
largest two-year fall in living
standards in almost 70 years according
to the resolution Foundation the typical
household income saw a hit of 700 pounds
this year and it's about to fall by
another 1100 pounds over the next year
and what's more over half of that 650
pounds is due to conservative tax Rises
that's an eye-watering 1800 pounds over
two years taken away by conservative
chaos and tax Rises no you've spoken
Madam Deputy speaker this government is
letting people down all across the UK in
very tough times the British people have
shown remarkable decency and strength
but they are finding it harder and
harder to make ends meet nearly 3
million people are expected to fall into
poverty over the next two years and in
four years time over a third of children
could be growing up in poverty they the
highest point this Century that's the
true cost of the cost of living crisis
under the conservatives and that's why
liberal Democrats are calling for more
help with energy bills more help with
mortgages and investment in our Public
Services many of these people will
either be carers or be receiving care
from a loved one so the one thing the
government could do to help right now is
finally raise the carers allowance that
would go a huge way towards helping some
of the most vulnerable among us all it
takes is a government that really cares
rather than a government that makes
people pay for its own mistakes thank
you
Kevin Foster thank you uh Madam Deputy
speaker I think it's certainly
interesting follow what we've just heard
and just reflect on where we'd be with
our energy Supply if we'd had new
nuclear reactors coming online last year
where did so because that was a claim
from the then Deputy Prime Minister
about 10 years ago that it wasn't worth
doing them and also where motorists and
warehousehold bills would be if we'd
listen to the resolution at a liberal
Democrat conference for reintroducing
indexation of fuel Duty so I know find
some of the comments we've just heard
rather interesting but the budget we've
heard today comes at a challenging time
globally and and within the rest of
Europe and it's therefore welcoming much
of the package that's been announced
today and the Chancellor's rightly
focused on the fact that cutting
inflation is one of the best tax cuts he
could deliver particularly helping to
ease the pressure on family budgets and
there is a lot to like in this regard
and first starting with the energy price
guarantee extension and until July we
are now starting to see prices coming
down on the wholesale markets around
energy that's encouraging and it's
certainly encouraging to see the
additional three months of support that
will now be provided and I particularly
welcome to change around prepayment
meters because it always struck me as
well in some ways rather odd that those
are already struggling to pay their
bills who are then put onto a prepayment
meter because of the danger of
non-payment then actually have to pay
the highest rates of the lot and the era
when someone had to go round and collect
money out of a meter are long gone you
know the systems that manage this are
now more digital and automatic and
therefore there's really no reason to
have this differential and this premium
charge to some of the poorest in both
tool Bay and across the country and
therefore it's very welcome to hit the
move today to abolish that
the certainly the fuel Duty freeze for
the 12th year and keeping the 5p
reduction will be welcome not just by
those motorists who have to fill up a
tank but of course we have to remember
that this is one of the things that
affects the cost of virtually everything
in the shop because of the fact that
things have to be delivered and using
and for the vast majority of products
that will be via Road Transport so it is
very welcome to see that being done and
certainly you know I do very much
welcome the extension of free child care
to one and two-year-olds you know it
really will get more into work and also
welcome the fact the chance of recognize
is not just about increasing the hours
that parents out but also making sure
there's appropriate funding package for
providers you know this is not something
that can be done easily and I welcome
the fact that he clearly listened to the
representations made by the sector now
coming on to what a lot of people call
the doctor's tax you know the changes to
the pension allowances and the abolition
of the lifetime allowance it is
absolutely clear that there are doctors
and skilled professionals who would be
working in our NHS today but for the
fact that they'd hit the lifetime
allowances and then were penalized in a
tax sense for carrying on working it is
extremely welcome to see that change
being made obviously the annual
allowance prevents this to be in a way
of large-scale tax avoidance but it
means that those who are one who are
wanted to carry on working are not being
penalized for it and it is extremely
welcome to see now there are areas I'd
of course like to have seen the chance
to go slightly further on I think
virtually all of us would say there are
things we may want to look at you know
note for example the 12 investment Zone
it is disappointing that there isn't one
in the southwest region but I would also
like to see this perhaps build on the
particularly arguments around planning
reform in areas where local authorities
are signed up to doing so in our town
centers through the Advent of online
shopping probably need to have the type
of regeneration and all alteration to
their purpose and structure that we saw
when the introduction of the motor car
of 50 or 60 years ago is the main method
of people traveling into them you know
the idea that we can go on as we are is
different and it's actually for me it
made eminent sense to allow some
flexibilities in places like talking
paint and town centers where the local
Authority had supported that move and
again perhaps that may be something
we'll see more development on in the
future and similarly like like the model
member for woke him isn't in his place
at the moment I am skeptical about just
how much raising the corporation tax
rate will deliver will actually produce
in terms of actual income into the
government but I do know some of the
changes that have been made today which
will be interesting to see and the
impact they have around investment
now in terms of the last eight years
we've seen a welcome change from the
time when Torbay rarely featured unless
of government funding announcement so
we've seen the town deal we've seen the
future High streets fund we've seen the
new stations fund and of course the
building of writer future project for
tour Bay Hospital which could be the
largest single investment in tour-based
Health Services since the creation of
the NHS back in 1948 and you know we
could cover at length the lack of
delivery of some of these funded schemes
by the lib Dem independent Coalition at
Torbay Council but I hope today's news
is the start of getting on with a job of
delivering in our Bay particularly the
news around one of these being one of
the leveling up partnership areas that's
in the main budget documents you know
I've seen how some of that working
together in government focusing
particularly in areas like Blackpool can
start driving projects forward and I
really hope that that is something that
we can look forward to in our Bay and I
also welcome the fact that there'll be a
third round of the leveling up funds
it's ourselves vital at this time tool
Bay has a strong bid which can get the
funding needed to level up our community
being a Madam Deputy speaker I accept a
budget is a difficult job that as will
always be more demands than there are
resources to meet them there's aspects
that of course are welcome more
generally such as increased defense
spending particularly given the defense
interests within South Devon and across
the Southwest more generally but overall
this is a good package this is a package
that will deliver for people and it's a
package that I genuinely believe shows
the chancellor has taken on a difficult
job and is doing it well and so whilst
I'll continue to speak up on some of the
areas that I believe we could do a
little bit more and I hope we could go
further on particularly in relation tool
Bay overall this is a package that I
think will be broad broadly welcomed and
of what we've seen so far in this debate
is there's no serious alternative being
presented from the benches opposite
speaker the first test for this budget
was whether people are going to be
better off or worse off as a result of
it
the chancellor has failed in his first
test because the OVR
forecast an analysis delivers a damning
verdict in the executive summary it
talks of how real household income is
due to Fall by 5.7 in the next two years
the largest two-year fall since records
began in 1956-57 with living standards
lower than pre-pandemic levels even up
to 2027-28
there was no mention of support for
mortgage prisoners in this and the
chancellor Mr chance to end non-dom tax
status which could have helped fund an
expansion of the workforce in the NHS
his pledge his pledge for potholes
Madame Deputy speaker
all very well except that the issue is
that the highways maintenance budget
that he cut that was cut in 2021 by 400
million would have been enough to fill 8
million potholes
and there's good progress on Child Care
on prepayment meters on supporting over
50s back to work but all of that has
been playing catch up with where labor
has been
now my starting point is optimism and
ambition for what Britain can become and
how we can rebuild our economy and
restore our reputation for trust around
the world after the devastating damage
particularly done by the mini budget
last September
but this needs a serious plan for
stability and growth that commands
confidence and makes Britain the best
place to invest and to start or grow a
business
we know that government working in
partnership with industry is what will
help British businesses to be thriving
growing and investing if we are to ever
achieve any of our goals whether that's
making all parts of the country better
off or getting on track for Net Zero the
investment that businesses undertake to
develop products and services increase
productivity create jobs that investment
is the most crucial ingredient
but the challenge we have here in the UK
is that business investment has been
lagging for years caused by 13 years of
Tory failure this was a problem before
the pandemic before the war in Ukraine
and it's making it much harder for us to
recover from those shocks today a
consequence of the low growth low
productivity and high-tech economy that
this government has created and the
continual chopping and changing of
government policies and priorities have
made our economy less stable and
contributed to Falling living standards
falling business confidence and falling
consumer confidence
context let me speak to the budget Madam
speaker that's in front of us today and
what a missed opportunity we needed to
see a strong serious industrial policy
framework for the long term that
businesses can trust and that can bring
Clarity consistency stability and
certainty even more so in the uncertain
world that we face but today's budget
did not even come close which is not
surprising as the government has spent
the last few years watering down its
industrial strategy and hoping nobody
will notice well the only ear here e
here today Madam Deputy speaker was
everything but a serious plan
and what a contrast with Labor's clear
strategic missions and priorities for
the British economy and our goal of
securing the highest sustained growth in
the G7
now what we have seen today is little
more than tinkering around the edges
more sticking plaster politics and more
attempts at short-term fixes with a
handout for the richest one percent
slipped in
this budget Falls Way short of The Wider
plan for green growth that our
businesses and communities have also
been calling for the chancellor
announced a 20 billion pound investment
over two decades to capture to create
carbon capture Technologies but as ever
this is yet another poor invitation of
Labor policy
but there wasn't and there wasn't nearly
enough last September over 200 leading
businesses and financial institutions
wrote to the uh to the Prime Minister
then saying they were committed to
protecting and restoring nature and
delivering a net zero economy in support
of the youth case targets with delivery
mechanisms strengthened across the whole
of government
the steps announced today
are yet again a poor imitation of where
labor has been and it has taken the ssmt
to also say there is little that enables
the UK to compete with the massive
packages of support to power a green
transition that are available elsewhere
now small businesses should also be part
of this transition to a green economy
roundtables I'm doing small businesses
across the country have shown how much
they need to be Central to our plans for
growth but all we seem to think is the
government is a record is a is a record
of failure and a lack of ambition and
the FSB said today
that the distinct lack of new support uh
in uh and in in core areas proves that
small business and small firms are
overlooked and undervalued the latest
ons data available on business deaths
shows that business deaths have
outweighed business bursts for seven
consecutive quarters running and even
schemes set up like by the government to
help small businesses grow are falling
short the government's help to grow
digital was billed as the government's
Flagship small business productivity
policy but a year after it running the
government pulled the pla the plug in
February because of low take-up and when
I recently asked the minister what
programs were available to smes looking
to transition to Net Zero he cited the
boiler upgrade program
but the scheme's own impact assessment
says that the impact of this scheme for
small businesses is negligible the
latest data released from the scheme
shows that 0.4 percent of all
installations in the scheme have been
for evidence has been have been for smes
so the evidence is clear the government
is simply not serious about helping smes
transition to Net Zero or supporting
them at all so in conclusion Madame
Deputy speaker if the government was
serious about supporting small
businesses as well they would back
Labor's plan to help Britain become a
clean energy superpower by 2030 and
provide 0.7 billion to help in help to
Green grants for smes the lack of
long-term shift in the government in the
chancellor State and today has left us
with the usual sticking plaster politics
this is a natural end result of what
happens when you spend 13 years
hollowing out public services and not
investing in workers and businesses and
having a tired government that's run out
of ideas yeah yeah bias Elwood thank you
Madam Deputy speaker so much to digest
from this red book in such a short space
of time let me Begin by welcoming the
budget statement today that not just
reflects a return to economic disability
but also a viable plan to energize UK
growth it has been a busy year since the
last spring event the Russian invasion
uh continues of foot in Ukraine causing
geopolitical and economic ramifications
impacting on energy and fuel prices
there's the aftermath of course of covid
which cost the government intervention
four Bill 400 billion pounds from the
treasury's coffers and let's also put
our hand up that the political turmoil
uh moving through three prime ministers
uh was a testing for the markets and was
not our finest Hour certainly stagnation
summarizes 2022 slow economic growth
inhibiting Economic Development or
expansion and inflation with Rising
prices but Falling GDP
so it's good to see a return to fiscal
responsibility as ethics are made to
bring inflation under control and
restore confidence with the markets and
secure new reliable sources of energy
Imports and become more energy
self-sufficient including MPS to say
investment in modular nuclear reactors
now is the chancellor stated the
forecast looks more optimistic as our
economy begins to strengthen growth is
forecast to return the government's key
objectives of halving inflation or
growing the economy and reducing debt
are all on track
but significant challenges remain as
we've heard today many are still
impacted by the cost of living crisis
there's still not enough investment in
business to make our economy grow faster
and our labor market needs invigorating
to entice many of the economically
inactive back in to work so the actions
announced today address these very
issues and would be a welcome in
Bournemouth East and indeed across the
country extending the energy price
guarantee for example to help keep fuel
bills low and freezing fuel Duty
extending child care to include one and
two-year-olds and additional funding to
support nurses so more parents can
return to work after building a family
and of course increasing the annual
pension allowance to sixty thousand
pounds which I hope will encourage
doctors in Bournemouth and indeed across
the country from delaying their thought
of retiring
what I did not see in the red book and I
looked at the front page now were any
plans to reduce vat for the hospitality
industry from 20 to 10 now tourism
destinations were affected such as born
with because of the pandemic grateful of
course for that government intervention
then but as Hospitality recovers today
it's hit by The Perfect Storm of
inflation driving up wages higher fuel
prices and of course increased utility
costs there is a petition in the UK
government Parliament website there's
now reached over 11 000 signatures and I
hope the treasury will do the maths when
lower vat and allow Hospitality
operations to survive and indeed Build
and Grow thus increasing productivity
and that will help Advance our GDP
please Chancellor I invite you to do the
maths but let me finally turn to defense
because even today
the the chancellor connected the state
of our economy with events in Eastern
Europe now with around half of our GDP
subject to International headwinds our
connectivity our access to International
markets our ability to Source Global
goods and services are all impacting on
our economy and this has been powerfully
illustrated by the conflict in Ukraine
had that Invasion not taken place UK GDP
would be at four percent today not at 10
percent imagine what would happen if the
threat picture were deteriorate
yet that is exactly what the government
predicts will happen as written in the
new integrated review and I quote
there is a growing prospect that the
International Security environment will
further deteriorate in the coming years
with State threats increasing and
diversifying in Europe and Beyond the
risk of escalation is greater than any
time in decades now if ever there was a
call to move away from peacetime defense
spend that was it
now I crunched the numbers already Madam
Deputy speaker in the red book simply
put away from the Ukraine support of
ammunition replenishment for the next
two years There is five billion pounds
allocated of which three billion goes to
the new nuclear Enterprise leaving just
one billion pounds a year to improve our
conventional forces that will not allow
our hollowed-out army to be regenerated
it will not allow all those swathing
cuts we saw in the last review to be
reversed such as tank numbers troop
numbers armored Fighting Vehicle numbers
even typhoon numbers Hercules aircraft
numbers as well
we should recognize and I say this loud
and care about him Deputy speaker we're
sliding towards a new Cold War as Russia
and China further align themselves to
challenge and exploit the Frailty of our
Global Order and AS Global Security
further deteriorates a failure to invest
in upgrading our peacetime defense
posture now will not only harm our
economy as our markets are slowly closed
off it diminishes our voice on the
international stage this is not the time
to Blink but we should have must have
the political courage backed by our hard
power that is what's earned us a
permanent seat on the U.N security
Council and I urge the treasury to
reconsider their investment in our UK
defense posture Madam Deputy speaker to
conclude
after the Windsor framework the Paris
Summit the orcas deal
today what we saw by the chancellor is
another example of statecraft returning
to number 10. domestically this budget
will help tackle the cost of living
crisis it will strengthen our economy
and it will boost growth I commend the
government for its actions here today
but with storm clouds gathering I hope
the government understands I'll keep
pushing for an increased defense budget
thank you madam Deputy speaker Britain
could be so much better we have
world-class universities we have some of
the best firms in the world we have an
amazing Tech and Life Sciences sector
great startups smes a fantastic banking
sector and people who are desperate to
rebuild our economy after the Damage
Done to our country by this government
the chancellor could have could have
come up with a budget that is fixing
that's about fixing the future that is
about investment that is about growth
what we have is him trying to fix the
Damage Done by his party in government
what we saw last year was that was the
Specter of the IMF pointing out that the
UK has the weakest growth compared to
our competitors
UK growth is flatlining the economy will
shrink by 0.2 this year
the obr forecast that the next two years
will see the biggest fall in household
incomes with real incomes foot to Fall
by 5.67 in the next two years the
largest since records began in the 1950s
Madam Deputy speaker we also saw the
Specter of people's mortgages going up
and the average mortgage because of the
Liz truss premium will be sorry because
of the former prime minister and the
former chancellors
uh uh Chancellor of crashing the economy
will go up by an average of 2 000 pounds
a month the previous prime minister
crashed the economy in her 49 days in
office costing the country over a
billion pounds for every day she was in
office making it the most expensive work
experience placement in history Madame
Deputy speaker
this Chancellor delivered his Autumn
statement and promised a shallow
downturn what he did was serve up 55
billion pounds of spending cuts and tax
Rises to patch up the conservative chaos
caused by multiple prime ministers and
about four chancellors but Madam speaker
I've lost count
what he should have done today was begun
with an apology to the British people
because because apology is what's needed
for the fact that what they've seen and
what they've experienced is economic
misery and hardship on in the hands of
the former prime minister and the former
Chancellor Madam Deputy speaker what we
need is rapid investment a genuine plan
for growth we've seen in the U.S
President Biden introducing the
inflation reduction act where it's 370
billion dollars will be invested in
business will be focused on green uh
green uh Greening the economy we need to
make sure that our economy is fit for
the future that there is a genuine plan
for growth we haven't seen that what we
are seeing is investment down what we
are seeing is investment blows business
investment in the G7 for this country
mortgages going up what we've seen is
Wages at the lowest in real terms uh for
uh over the last 13 years the tax burden
among the highest since records began
since since the second world war and the
chancellor has done nothing to improve
the plight of the British people what
we've seen here is him trying to pretend
that the mess that's been made is not
the mess made by his party in government
labor will deliver a green growth
supporting 400 000 jobs in Green
businesses we will retain workers with
the skills in the green economy in every
corner of the UK there will be genuine
leveling up we will rebuild our business
rebuild business with a national
Investment Bank that supports the drive
for a Net Zero economy
and I could say much more but I'm
limited in time we have a plan for
growth we have a plan for a high-skilled
high-wage economy the conservatives had
13 years in government what we've seen
is 13 years of austerity the destruction
of vital public services and the
destruction of our economy and added to
that what we saw is the the previous
prime minister but one negotiate a deal
that has led to our economic uh
reduction in our GDP because of the poor
deal that was negotiated uh a brexit
deal that was negotiated that is costing
a hundred billion pounds in Lost output
and 40 billion Less in Revenue to the
treasury every year Madam Deputy speaker
the the last prime minister has cost 55
billion pounds when she tanked the
economy with her then Chancellor Britain
could do much better but we won't get
much better we won't get better until
until we have a change in government
it's time for a labor government yeah
speaker can I congratulate the uh the
treasury team for what I thought was a
very imaginative budget particularly
getting people back into work the
pension changes to get some key
employees back to their employment
particularly in the NHS I had concerns
about the corporation tax rise but
they've been broadly tempered by the
full expensing but I I will make
reference to my members of interest I'm
a chartered accountant Charter Tax
Advisor so this this may come over as a
little dull but it may be instructive to
the treasury bench I want to take a very
quick Gallop through corporation tax and
dividend tax law over the last 50 years
uh dividends were imputed with uh
Advanced corporation tax the system that
was introduced in 1973. it was a
withholding tax at source so that the
recipients of those dividends if they
were basic rate taxpayers were deemed to
have the tax paid at source of course
because of that attacks that have
already been deducted both Charities but
most notably Pension funds could reclaim
that tax that have been deducted now
strangely one of the first acts of the
1997 incoming labor government was to
scrap that advanced corporation tax
regime and for Pension funds this was a
wholesale uh well it was a catastrophe
for Pension funds where else were at one
time the world leading well-funded
they're now in the state that they are
today with the estimates of damage to
Pension funds at now 250 billion pounds
and the virtual extinction of the
defined benefit scheme
so act was scrapped and that started a
very long period of tax free dividends
up to the basic rate ban for four basic
rate taxpayers and that was on a a very
simplistic basis that because Dividends
are not a deduction against uh taxable
profits they were sort of internally
imputed to have had that rate of
corporation tax attached to them and so
in the hands of the basic rate taxpayer
they were free we had a short period of
this very strange 10 band but all
toddled along quite nicely up until 2016
uh the 10 tax credit was abolished and
replaced with a tax-free dividend
allowance of 5 000 pounds and I feel the
treasurer's assessment of the time were
that owner managed businesses
particularly were using dividends rather
too extensively and there was an
avoidance of uh both ER and ee National
Insurance well let's so be it but even
at that level it didn't last for very
long I think it was deemed even at the
5000 level to have been a little over
exploited so that dividend allowance was
reduced to 2 000 pounds from April 18.
and then with dividends above that rate
then taxed at seven and a half percent
and in this past year we've raised that
to 8.75 again I would say so be it but
we have introduced a double taxation of
company profits both in company profits
then in the hands of the recipient
but what concerns me more than anything
and the reason for my speech this
afternoon is the proposal that was
raised at the second Autumn statement
last year confirmed today obviously not
overturned was for the dividend tax-free
amount to be reduced to a thousand
pounds to 23.24 and to reduce still
further to just 500 pounds in 24 25.
now my plea is for reconsideration of
this I'll give you an example
a retired taxpayer blissfully had been
pay all of their working lives receipt
of a state pension perhaps an
occupational pension as well and the
coding is working perfectly adequately
they've been in a share-safe scheme it
was the right thing to do they're
encouraged to do it all they're working
uh lives and there are now million
people in the country in a share saved
scheme and they've been blissfully
outside of doing a tax return the system
has worked easily for them now the
likelihood of ever receiving two
thousand pounds of dividends was pretty
low possibly the prospect of even a
thousand pounds of dividends is fairly
low but I'm afraid the likelihood of
getting 500 pounds plus of dividends
through a share save scheme in 24 25 is
likely to be very high
do we realistically want to catch people
with fines through the door when they
didn't realize what has happened and
what has changed and do we really want
to drag hundreds of thousands
potentially of taxpayers retired who'd
never had to worry about a tax return
into the tax return system
I just believe that 500 pound threshold
is unduly parsimonious shall we say now
let's contrast that with what we have in
other aspects of the tax system where we
do allow a small amount of income to be
earned tax-free there are two that I
know of that's the property allowance
where you can have a thousand pound of
rent perhaps by renting out your a bit
of car parking space to a Commuter or
you've got a holding property that you
might rent out for a week or two and of
course the trading allowance where you
can earn a thousand pounds and that
effectively falls out of tax as well so
we're allowing 2 000 pounds of tax-free
income even available to the 60 tax
buyer so we're allowing potentially 1200
pounds of tax not to be paid because it
makes it administratively easy not worth
the hassle and the very small tax loss
is worthwhile
so my my plea to the front bench it may
be too late to stop the thousand pound
uh threshold from coming into play for
23-24 but it's certainly not too late to
give some consideration to the 500 pound
threshold as I say we've allowed 2 000
of other earnings for other things to
fall out of tax I think the 500 pound
limit is far too low will drag uh in
innocent taxpayers into the tax system
who perhaps have never been in the tax
system before so that is my
recommendation to the treasury bench and
my contribution this afternoon thank you
Sammy Wilson
speaker first of all there's much to be
welcomed in this budget but I think that
as we have found time and time again
sometimes when you look at the rosary
listen to the rosary rhetoric from the
dispatch box and then delve into the
detail
the gloss comes off some of the picture
which has been painted
and if we look at the Deeds some of the
detail of this budget
on one hand the government has said and
quite rightly and I welcome many of the
measures which have indicated we want to
give people an incentive to get back
into work
And yet when we look at what is
happening with personal income tax
we find it over the next two years
personal income tax to take is going to
go up by
um nearly uh 20 percent
now
that is because many people are being
dragged into
the tax regime as a result the result of
alliances not being changed and as a
result of people then going into higher
tax brackets hardly an incentive
for people to work
we're told that the government wants to
help businesses invest
so nine billion pounds is going to be
given in tax alliances for investment
what would we look at the the obr
forecast at the same time the increase
in corporation tax is going to take off
twice as much
as the in the alliance which is allowed
for given for uh to attract investment
government wants to help small
businesses and we had a nice months for
various members high-speed schemes yet
when we look at the figure for business
rates over the next two years 25
increase
and the take from business rates
and overall
during the next two years we're going to
say tax receipts
across the economy going up by 10
percent at a time and it's not due to
economic growth
at a time when we're actually finding
that there's going to be negative growth
in one of those years and one point I
think it's two or one twenty eight
percent in the second year
so the real tax burden
on high schools and on businesses and on
the economy
is increasing
the government says and the the minister
made much of the the chance we made much
of the fact that he wanted to help firms
with and help with energy costs
yet we find that since the emissions
trading scheme
which is really directed towards putting
costs on high energy users
is going up from one billion to 6
billion and we already know the result
of that many of those businesses energy
intensive Industries are simply going
overseas
so when we look at the
the rhetoric and then look at the detail
we find that rather than being a budget
for growth
because you can't tax your way to growth
this is a budget which is going to
impaired growth and yet we know that if
we're going to finance Public Services
if we're going to get our debt down if
we're going to be able to finance our
debt
then we have to grow the economy
if we're going to make people better off
they've got to I'm so uh modern Debbie
speaker the first point I want to make
is that let's look at the detail
before we give a blanket welcome to this
budget I happen belonged a party which
believes at low taxation is the best way
of uh growing an economy it's the best
it's right to allow people and
businesses to spend their money as they
see fit make the wise decisions which
they believe will suit them rather than
the step doing it where that can be
avoided of course we've got to spend
money on on uh essential services and I
support the increase for example at this
time of turbulence
um in in the geopolitics and uh in
Ukraine and in other parts of the world
I support the increase in defense
spending I think it's right that a
concrete
is prepared to defend itself and has got
the ability to do so
I wanted to address just a few of the
the specific measures in the the budget
that as a supporter of the fair fuel
group
um I welcome the fact that the
chancellor has
taken the wise decision to freeze fuel
Duty again it's a way of reducing
inflation
it also is a way of helping small
businesses and for consumers who are
finding the cost of living increase is
hurting their pockets and of course
um from the point of view of places like
Northern Iron which are heavily
dependent yeah upon getting their
supplies in by Laurie Etc it helps to
um reduce costs there
I I share the the views of the member
for Northeast Hampshire on the child
care
um proposals
because whilst the proposals will help
and I have no doubt it'll be welcomed by
many of the providers of child care and
many of the users of child care
nevertheless and I know this from
experience in Northern Ireland there are
many places where it is not possible
to Bayern Child Care from
um bodies have been set up in many cases
the alliance doesn't cover the cost so
the the individual fines themselves
still out of pocket and there's not the
flexibility when the government finances
it because you're relying on there being
a network in the local area
yes
for forgiving way uh just on the on the
child care the child care is welcome for
England absolutely but would he agree
with me that a more sensible approach
that would have helped families right
across the United Kingdom for ages older
than 35 because Checker doesn't stop at
ages three to five a tax-free Alliance
increase would have been much better
well a tax Reliance of course would have
avoided not to remember the point the
member for Northeast Hampshire was
making it gives much work flexibility in
the in the um the whole system and
therefore I think it would be a better
way of dealing with the uh with the
issue I'm not going to give way again
because I'm nearly seven minutes and I
just want to finish up with one last
point there are many other measures in
this such as the tax-free
um zones for industry and the the
changes in the miracle uh licensing for
medic medicines cetera
I'd like to know whether the chancellor
has looked
at whether those can apply to Northern
Ireland given that even after the
Windsor framework we are still subject
to EU law in Northern Ireland we're
still still subject to EU state aid laws
in Northern Ireland and my fear is that
when we actually try to apply them we
will find that the EU will once again be
able to interfere in the Affairs of the
United Kingdom by stopping those kinds
of proposals
um benefiting Northern Ireland as a as a
whole there are many other points that I
wanted to make Madame Dairy speaker but
there are many other people want to get
in can I make one last point and that is
that vat for hospitality and reductions
for vat and Hospitality as the same with
corporation tax
are very important in Northern because
of course we have got a land boundary
with another country where corporation
tax rates are lower vat rates are lower
and therefore without changes in those
two things we are placed at a
competitive disadvantage
Mary Robinson but I'm Deputy speaker and
I welcome today's budget and this
government's continued support for the
areas that need it most
um and I was listening intently to the
remarks of them at the right honorable
member for East London but I would say I
do believe that this is a budget for
growth for the UK for the country and
it's a budget for growth further north
it sets out in my view the commitment to
ensuring opportunity and investment and
improving collectivity and I welcome it
and I'm seeing this in action already in
Cheadle with the 8.626 million pounds
for the new Cheadle rail station and the
commitment to Greener jobs which I'm
also already seeing and the the building
progressing for a new 4.4 million pound
Cheadle Eco business park so I know that
the government is giving local areas and
regions the tools and infrastructure
they need to prosper and I'm proud that
Chile is already home to a number of
national International firms on the um
the AAA on the beach to tales and down
to name but a few and the creation of
the 12 new investment zones one of which
will be hosted in Greater Manchester a
will attract more businesses and jobs to
our region and to Cheadle
and in addition I really welcome the new
innovation cluster in Greater Manchester
which will accelerate research and
development and reinforce our place as a
center of innovation and we'll see the
benefits of this spread out into Cheadle
in jobs and investment and also
reinforcing the Cheadle the Cheshire
life science Corridor right on cheadle's
Border meanwhile can I also welcome the
announcements around Child Care joining
many others supporting parents and
families is vital to ensuring that our
communities prosper by providing more
child care support for those on
Universal Credit and extending the 30
hours free child care provision to one
and two-year-olds more parents will have
the flexibility to take up employment
and pursue their careers I hear the
Chancellor's intention to revise the
staff to child ratios to mirror those in
Scotland but could I also suggest that
funding is also found to ensure that
safety is never compromised and Nursery
staff can feel confident that when work
when they are working with new these new
ratios that they are have got the skills
that they need to do so
I believe that helping people getting
into well-paid skills Employments is the
best way to combat Regional inequalities
and is key to leveling up so measures to
not only create jobs but make it easier
for people to take the month is hugely
important further to these job creating
job supporting moves I welcome the
announcement of investment in carbon
capture usage and storage on Far Coast
to the Northwest and the Northeast not
only does this signal our commitment to
Net Zero but also lays the foundation
for high quality long-term jobs and
investment in the north and in order for
these jobs to get the maximum boost to
the northern economy the skills and
training also needs to be based locally
in the north and running side by side
these new opportunities
and I welcome the initiatives to improve
training and skills and bring back bring
people back into the workforce we know
that for investment across the north to
boost growth and fulfill its potential
it's vital that our infrastructure
matches these new opportunities and so
when I urge government to fully deliver
and fast-track Northern Powerhouse rail
join up these Northern towns and cities
and unite and Link the investment
opportunities
turning to local transport announcements
and the announcement of integrated
ticketing systems is great news for
people in Chile but I would also call on
the mayor of Greater Manchester to hear
my constituents who are calling for an
extension of Metrolink so that we can
fully benefit from his newly devolved
powers
it's clear that greater Manchester will
play a key part in the government's
leveling up agenda with a rollout of
more powers to the devolved area
the Trailblazer deals due to be signed
off with greater Manchester and
Birmingham show the confidence of the
government in local decision making
however greater powers and devolved
Authority must be accompanied by
improved scrutiny and accountability the
suite of departmental powers which will
be held by the greater Manchester mayor
will be extensive
covering and already including Health
and Social care transport functions and
skills to name but a few and I see these
are to be expanded with the deepened
evolution to include as you said a
simplified and integrated ticketing
system in local Transport Systems
Devolution of the majority of 19 plus
adult skills funding to Mayors a
long-term commitment to local
authorities retaining 100 of their
business rates and for the first time
outside London local leaders will now be
able to set the Strategic Direction Over
the affordable housing program in their
areas
foreign
if the mayor of Greater Manchester is to
set up a White Hall on Oxford Street
then the scrutiny of these Powers must
be at least as robust as the scrutiny
which gets given to ministers in this
place
Trailblazer Powers need Trailblazer
scrutiny Trailblazer accountability and
Trailblazer governance Madam Deputy
speaker
I welcome this budget for growth under
the measures to invest in and innovate
in the North this budget will grow the
UK economy and I will continue to make
the case that only by continuing to
level up the North and close the
regional productivity cap will our
country truly reach its full potential
yeah
Dave Margaret Hodge thank you very much
Madam Deputy speaker and it's a pleasure
to follow the right honorable member for
Cheadle I have to say I do disagree with
her I don't think that the budget of
2023 will go down in history at the
moment when the UK government finally
got to grips with 13 years of pitiful
growth rates I don't think the budget
will go down as the year when the
government honestly confronted the DAR
state of our Public Services much valued
by my constituents much neglected by
this government
and I don't think this will be the
moment when the government admitted that
child poverty has reached the highest
levels for a generation and that they
have taken and that they have recognized
that we need urgent action to tackle the
inequality that brings for me Madam
Deputy speaker the budget is a
tragically missed opportunity I'm afraid
it's a failure of political leadership
and a woeful lack of responsible
stewardship over the nation's finances
and taxpayers money indeed during the
budget we heard that and during the cost
of living crisis we heard that the
people who are probably going to benefit
most from proposals in the budget are
those who will benefit from the Life
Lifting of the lifetime alerts and I
wonder if ministers at the end will tell
us who is it who's going to benefit from
that it's not just going to be the
doctors it's going to be the bankers
it's going to be the military it's going
to be the Millionaires and is it really
right to prioritize them as we are in
the middle of the cost of living a
crisis
uh my constituents my constituents are
desperate to feel real hope for their
future
for their future and for the Future
Families but what are the realities
facing the families embarking and
important public sector pays been cut by
4.3 since the financial crash police
officers are now taking home 13 Less in
real terms and they weren't 2009 and in
the obr we see that they say that living
standards are expected to go down by six
percent not just this year but also next
year there are eight hundred thousand I
will people
and I refer to it as a squeeze middle
class uh does the honorability agree of
it then fairness of the refusal the
uplifting child benefit cap over the
last 10 years especially with the
increases price increase for last year
greatly impacts on Working Families
those people in the middle classes lose
the elderly right normally is referring
to
yeah I I think I heard what the
honorable member said and I think he's
talking about this squeeze medal uh who
I agree with not benefit from from the
budget either
um there are 800 000 fewer owner
occupiers today than there were in 2010
while the number of rough sleeve sleep
sleepers has grown by staggering 169 and
we didn't hear Health even mentioned in
the budget speech today with Hospital
waiting lists growing access to GPS
almost impossible and we're now facing
the most appalling record of having the
highest waiting times in a e for nearly
20 years all of this and the tax burden
is at its highest since World War II
um this can't offer hope I say to the to
ministers opposite to the people of
barking and I one cannot offer Hope by
proclaiming a slogan and I fear that
much of the budget is full of slogan
let's take child care of course
everybody can agree that we must support
women back to the workplace but ensuring
that our children get high quality
Education and Care in their early years
is just as important because that's how
you give our children the very best
chance in life and that's how you tackle
inequality at its roots I'm always
reluctant to heart back to the past but
there are lessons to be learned from the
labor what the labor government achieved
on this and I was privileged to play a
key role in delivering our earlier
Services children were at the heart of
our concerns and we knew that if we gave
them the best start in life parents
would feel confident that the little
ones were in good earns and it would
help to develop the Next Generation
creation of educated skilled and
productive workers ask the deputy ask
the Labor's Deputy leader her life was
transformed by her experience of a short
start Children's Center
but Madam Deputy speaker good quality
child care costs money and it's a
scandal that we're still paying child
care workers the minimum wage whilst
those who are teaching universities for
example are probably in the top 10
business and the government is talking
about isn't as agreed today to change
the ratio of adults to children to cut
costs if if the early years matter the
most then the state should invest
properly to make sure we get
well-trained skilled people working the
little ones and ensure that each child
has the level of attention they need to
develop properly I wonder how many times
either the prime minister or the
chancellor has looked after five
toddlers and beavers babies under two
for 12 hours seven days a week so let's
look at the funding generously I assume
4 billion would all go to one and two
year olds that would allow 2 670 pounds
to be spent on each child labor with our
choice our children child came to early
years of investment spent at today's
prices Madame Deputy speaker four
thousand one hundred pounds on each
child every child one-third more
1230 pounds more on each little one
cheap underfunded Child Care delivered
by low paid undertrained workers will
fail the next generation of children and
it won't help mothers feel confident
about going back to work it's a
political and electoral call not a
serious policy to support children and
Tackle inequality and it will be largely
ineffective in encouraging women back to
work I know very quickly want to focus
on three other areas of received
scientific attention in the statement
getting the revenue in it's a scandal Mr
Speaker that the gap between Madam
Deputy speaker that the gap between what
we collect and what we should collect is
still 32 billion pounds getting on for
half of the total amount we spend on
defense it's a scandal that hmrc only
prosecuted eight cases where there is
evidence of enabling tax evasion by a
string of professionals such as
accountants lawyers and bankers at the
same time
hmlc pursued almost 400 000 people
earning less than 13 000 each for not
filling in a tax return on time remember
the personal allowance is almost thirty
thousand pounds it's a scandal that hmrc
investigated 30 to let fewer compliance
cases last year and that prosecutions
fell from 700 to a mere 163. that
failure cost us an estimated 9 billion
pounds the equivalent of of the total
budget for the foreign office we know
that every pound spent on compliance
activity yields 18 pounds in additional
Revenue it's also a scandal that we
spent hundreds of billions of pounds on
a vast array of tax reliefs because they
are not that are not viewed in the
Public Accounts as expenditure so we've
no idea how much they cost whether they
fulfill the purpose for which they were
intended and whether they provide value
for net money I've seen estimates that
suggests that the total cost of his
non-structural reliefs it can come to
eight percent the chances only response
to this particular Scandal is to abolish
the office for tax simplification which
examine tax producers r d tax relief is
one agricultural property relief
business property reliefs uh you all
used to avoid inheritance inheritance
tax finally
that let me talk about government waste
can I do one minute I was I wanted to
mentioned on government waste uh 15
billion lost to fraud and error in Kobe
schemes eight sites for nuclear power
station approved in 2010 not one build
and the cost for Hinckley Point
increased so far from 18 billion to
nearly 30 billion not to mention the
white elephant that is HS hs2 Madame
Decker speaker why can't the Government
Act to make our tax system fairer why
can't they adopt the principle
established in the 1980s by Nigel Lawson
that income secured from wealth should
be taxed of the same rate rate as income
secured from work taxing capital gains
at the same rate would raise 16 billion
ensuring landlords paid national
insurance would gain another 8 billion
incensing the pensioners like me who are
still in full-time employment pay the
full National Insurance on wages another
3.6 billion abolishing the out-of-dates
50 000 upper earnings limit for 99
another 24 1 billion Madam speaker I've
spoken for too long but this is an
opportunity in this it's an ill thought
out it's ill thought out through gimmick
on child care it's more for the better
off in their pensions and nothing for
ordinary families struggling to make
ends meets that's how history will judge
this budget
I'm Deputy speaker it's a privilege to
follow the right honorable lady for uh
for barking but I was disappointed with
much of what she said and particularly
the tone that she took because my
constituents face much of the challenges
that are faced here uh in England and
across the rest of the UK but the on
right honorable lady talks about the
labor Solutions which are very different
to my constituent and she talked about
health care she talked about child care
those are devolved functions and the
performances and the opportunities in
Wales are much less in spite of the
labor party running it so I would I
would suggest that the right honorable
lady spend a little bit of time and
looking at the experiences my
constituents face before she then starts
casting aspersions and doubts on the
policies and strategy that that have
been outlined a little bit earlier today
I do want to pay tribute to Madam Deputy
speaker to the chancellor and to the
treasury team for the stability and the
confidence that they have brought to the
economy
uh I think the Fallout from the covid uh
uh uh pandemic and the consequences of
Putin's uh uh aggression in Ukraine have
had a major impact on all economies uh
around the world but uh there's no doubt
that the stability and the supply slide
changes and the inflationary uh the
deflationary policies that have been
pursued have had a a major positive
impact and builds on the uh the speech
the uh Bloomberg speech to the
chancellor outlined uh some uh weeks ago
and today's budgets now start to start
to put some flesh on those bones but I
think the big news from the budget
without question comes from the obr
forecasts and that in spite of the uh
the do mongrels opposite and in spite of
the critics and uh uh uh of the
government from all sides uh over the
challenges in in recent months uh the UK
will avoid a technical recession and I
think we need to recognize the Merit of
that and the influence that has come
from the treasury team in playing a big
part in securing that then the second
headline for me is the prediction that
inflation by the end of the year will
fall to 2.9 that is quite remarkable and
again shows that the restraints in spite
of calls from Members also on all sides
including myself for more spending in my
constituency that in spite of uh uh uh
uh those calls they have resisted and
that is uh reducing the impact of what
is the worst form of Taxation which is
inflation which is eroding the uh the
standard of living the uh uh wages that
people earn and the capital that they uh
that they have amassed
so I think by listening to members
opposite similarly they fail to
recognize that since 2010 the UK economy
has grown faster than France Italy and
Japan and at the same Pace as Germany
and they will persist Madame Deputy
speaking and continue to talk down the
economy but they do have real impact in
the way in which they talk down the
economy because it does put doubt in
their mind uh doubting investors Minds
when they see the opposition uh clearly
uh uh undermining the confidence that
the front bench have placed uh have have
established I want to highlight very
quickly that the help with energy costs
is very welcome the fuel Duty freeze uh
will be of huge relief to my
constituents those in rural areas as
well as those small business white van
man and woman who have to go out and
about and win those contracts day in day
out they will be relieved and pleased
with uh that with the fuel Duty freeze
prepayment meter changes are very
welcome and I would say a long overdue I
think that that should have been acted
on uh by a number of chancellors and
energy ministers over over decades gone
by and I think that this is uh very
welcome but I'm pleased that this front
bench has has has grasped the nettle and
insisted on such uh changes they will
make a real difference to the cost of
living for some of the most hard-pressed
families and really show that this
government is on the heart on the side
of of hard-working people and
hard-working families and ultimately the
the child care changes and I look to the
two uh Welsh labor members on the front
bench opposite and really hope that they
will encourage their colleagues in
Cardiff Bay to follow suit because the
we need to remember that 25 that 50 of
the Welsh population lives within 25
miles of the border with England and
Wales and on that basis unless the Welsh
government follow the conservative
government's lead then consider my
constituents and their conceptions will
start feeling the pain of far greater
incentives that are seen uh in England
on a broader basis uh Madam Deputy
speaker I wonder what welcome the annual
investment allowance and the captain
incentives that uh that have been uh
laid out today the incentives for energy
security small motor reactors uh nuclear
investment carbon capture and storage
but would also suggest
um a simpler taxation system will mean
that we don't need so many incentives
and so many reliefs in so many areas now
I recognize it's not easy to do that at
a time of economic challenge but that's
clearly where we want to end
but the main points I want to make
within the very limited time I have
Madame Deputy speaker is the warm
welcome from the uh beer and Pub
industry for the draft duty extension
from the five percent uh relief to 9.2
relief as has been quoted by many
members that will effectively in real
terms mean that the price of a pint will
be 11 Pence Less in a pub and than it
will be elsewhere as a result of uh the
changes that have been announced today
they've been welcomed widely by the
industry and I should declare my
interest Madam Deputy speaker as the
chairman of the old party uh
parliamentary group on pubs so this this
the the the pub companies but of course
the we need to recognize that this duty
is paid for by the Brewers and this is a
call that we need to make that the
Brewers need to pass this benefit on to
the pubs because it's the pubs within
our community are the ones that act as
the fabric of society that employ offer
flexible employment opportunities that
have that great capacity of bringing
people back into employment that often
would uh would be left out of the uh out
of the workforce they are the pubs and
Hospitality the sector of the economy
that goes first that feels the impact of
a recession or any downturn first but
also gains the benefit benefits at the
end of that recession when people are
feeling far better now there's no doubt
Madame Deputy speaker that this budget
will have made a Major Impact to
hard-working families getting people
back into work encouraging investment
but it's also a a budget that will
support people in terms of the cost of
living and I'm absolutely delighted that
the chancellor has listened to the draft
uh to the calls from the industry on the
draft Duty relief now there are further
calls that the industry has got and I'm
encouraged that the exchecker second G
has already contacted my office seeking
a call early next week in order to
discuss the impact of changes and how we
can further maximize the benefits of
them and with that Madam Deputy speaker
I'll draw to a close thank you
at Stephen McKay yeah yeah thank you uh
Madam Deputy speaker I thought that was
a rather smug performance from the
chancellor who seems to have forgotten
that he only inherited his job because
of the economic chaos caused by The
Reckless stupidity of his predecessor
and the women who appointed him he asked
to be congratulated for his magnificent
achievement of avoiding our recession
well after 13 years of the Tories
destroying people's living standards
that's some achievement
on investment he promises us yet another
competition more of the begging bull
culture which West Midlands story mayor
Andy Street once abolished the people of
the West Midlands say don't make us beg
Don't Force any more of your rigged
competitions owners just give us a
rightful entitlement and let us go on
with the job
and the problem with the super deduction
scheme is that it rewards businesses
including those who avoid paying taxes
in this country like Amazon for
Investments they were going to make
anyway
whole safeguards will there be to ensure
that his Capital expenses scheme doesn't
repeat the same error with the taxpayer
again fitting the bill
there seems to be very little modern day
TV speaker to support small High Street
businesses cafes restaurants
hairdressers people who don't matter to
this side of those apparently
and of course there's no action on
business rates
I think he could have added a
because most of the worthwhile
announcements could and should have been
introduced a long time ago they've been
told about them from this side of the
house often enough
Universal support is a good idea
although it's not quite what the right
honorable gentleman for chingford and
Woodford had in mind when he introduced
Universal Credit and I want to know how
will the chancellor pay for Universal
support I hope it won't mean siphoning
money from the existing access to work
budget
I'm not seeing staff child ratios for
child care will increase capacity but
not necessarily reduce costs
I'll be sure to consult with providers
and parents in my cellular constituency
and how easy it will be to deliver on
today's promises I suspect there will be
quite a gap between the promises and
availability on the ground
and the freeze on fuel Duty and energy
costs are welcome in fact they are the
least he can do
genuine measures to encourage people
back to work can support those over 50
to remain in work are also welcome but
brutal and arbitrarily imposed sanctions
won't work that's just the same old
tories
and his pension plans although they will
help with Doctor retention will in
reality benefit those with existing
large pension ports will do nothing for
those and smaller incomes
his budget ignores the crippling worth
of living standards resulting from years
of totally wage restraint even The
Institute of physical studies cast doubt
on this government's arguments about
public sector pay there was more scope
in this budget to promote growth and
offer a fair settlement on public pay
and if unlike his predecessor he worries
about how to pay the bills he could
always look again at fairer taxation tax
and ordinary families is rising
relentlessly in this country but the UK
is still below the oecd average for tax
reason so I'm with my right honorable
friend from barking on this he could
raise around 15.6 billion through
equalizing capital gains and income tax
3.6 billion through abortion non-dome
status and about 9.6 billion by
extending National Insurance to
investment income why is it that
aren't worries is
that have to pay and not the other
people
this was a rather smug and self-con
gradual E3 budget he ignores the
problems created by 13 years of touring
missile homelessness crime out of
control fuel buildings crumbling record
NHS waiting list and a public that no
longer believes a word they say it was
the budget of a tire Chancellor an
entire government who run out of ideas
The credibility is shredded and this was
just far too little to we
[Music]
set out three big economic priorities
Target inflation grow the economy and
reduce debt the chancellor in this
budget has set the seam for how we sort
of make these priorities succeed
I believe this budget has shown vision
and pragmatism which will help people
and businesses in the two cities
Madam Deputy speaker households as
always are at the Forefront of the
government's priorities so I'm delighted
to hear the energy price guarantee is to
be extended to keep the average cost of
energy bills at two and a half thousand
pounds for a further three months
maintaining the support will save
households hundreds of pounds over the
coming months preventing millions of
families from falling into fuel poverty
in the two cities we have many residents
being supplied energy by communal heat
networks and I recognize that the energy
bill is progressing and this will go
some way to supporting those who rely on
communal eating networks however I do
hope that financial support can be
extended to these households as they are
all too often overlooked through no
fault of their own
and I would also I would also suggest
that the hospitality sector I know
welcome to brexit HUB guarantee but they
do still remain concerned about their
energy costs for their businesses like
restaurants and pubs which are such a
huge huge sector for the West End and
across my constituency
this budget does so much and goes a long
way to boost employment
be booting the benefit system to support
people back into work is something I
particularly welcome
this budget includes the biggest reform
to the welfare system in a decade which
will now mean that disabled and
long-term sick people can work without
the worry of losing out
this is important for several reasons
but principally among them is that in
the real world people's ability to work
isn't as binary as the current system
implies
I've seen this firsthand in the fair
shot Cafe in covert Garden run by Bianca
Tavella
who's supporting young people with
learning difficulty
difficulties get disabilities getting
back into the workplace and it makes a
huge difference to the individual and
their families
I also welcome the measures to support
for children in care and as they enter
working age as well as helping job
Seekers into decent jobs with decent
wages
here I believe the chancellor is right
that we are removing barriers we can't
the barriers that we can with reform
which strengthens our society as well as
strengthens our economy
and building on this point changes to
child care is something which will have
a real impact on people's lives in the
two cities and I'd like to take this
opportunity to to congratulate my uncle
friend the member for Stroud and also my
honorable member my honorable friend the
member for East Surrey who have really
driven this through and got it over the
line
and particularly I welcome this uh major
changes to child care because it will
give working women
real opportunity to choose what is best
for them and their family whether they
stay at home with their children or if
they want to continue with their careers
and not least because now parents will
be afforded 30 hours of free childcare
from as early as nine months until their
child's fourth birthday and also the
help for wrap around Child Care through
schools is most welcome
for me this is so important because this
means that parents can have the
flexibility to decide what's best for
them and their children
speaker I also believe that the
chancellor has also produced a sensible
and pragmatic approach to business
taxation the two cities this is
incredibly important
and as a conservative I recognize the
value of competitive tax regimes and I
understand the value of pro-business
pro-enterprise governments so
announcements on simplifying the tax
system for small and medium-sized
businesses are something I'm glad to
hear
however I I must take this opportunity
to once again make a plea for the return
of vat free shopping for overseas
visitors yeah uh returning this will be
a massive boost not just to London and
particularly to my constituency but it
will have a massive knock-on effect for
jobs and businesses across the United
Kingdom and I know I've spoken to the
chancellor about this specifically and I
know that he is looking at it but I
really do hope that we will have an
announcement sooner rather than later
because the benefit it has for the whole
country is so important
um
having said that I do look forward to
the review of taxes paid by smaller
businesses and the consultation to
expand the cash basis as well as
measures to simplify Customs Imports and
Export processes for small businesses
and while I welcome all of this I would
also urge the government to keep tax
simplification as an ongoing priority
for the government
but in conclusion Madam Deputy speaker
despite enormous Global challenges the
UK economy is proving the doubt is wrong
far from entering a technical recession
this year this government is stimulating
growth supporting hard-working families
and looking forward with a powerful
vision for this country
oh uh Dawn Butler thank you madam Deputy
speaker and it's a pleasure to follow
the honorable member from cities of
London and Westminster and I actually
agree with something that she said in
regards to vat and whilst I'm on a
positive uh mood my little speaker I'd
like to thank the chancellor for his
announcement on prepayment meters
because it's a campaign that I've been
championing for the last uh seven years
um but uh but Madam Deputy speaker I
feel like there's a lot missed in this
budget like at the moment we are facing
a profit crisis where the people are
struggling and the office of budget
responsibility has stated that real
household income dues due to Fall by 5.7
in the next two years which is the
largest two-year fall since records
began so it will be lower than
pre-pandemic levels so I think the
chancellor has missed a huge uh trick
here and the pension announcements and I
know the devil will be in the detail
tell but the pension announcements as
far as I can make out is for the wealthy
for those that can afford to put away
sixty thousand pounds a year
um and and also it seems like the only
permanent tax cut in the budget is for
those who were very very wealthy
um and the chancellor could have stopped
all the strikes if he had only made an
announcement on public sector workers
pay today but he chose not to do that
and there was nothing as we've heard
from other members on this side of the
house on capital gains tax or income uh
tax and that's very strange about the
deputy speaker and the thing is this
improving the UK economy cannot happen
without London's contribution and
London's councils have uh some key five
priorities and if I can just list them
they are housing and homelessness Health
and Care supporting businesses helping
London deliver Net Zero and greater
Devolution to to local government
London businesses are struggling in the
face of increasing labor and energy
costs and sustained High inflation and I
just wonder if the chancellor will
commit to keep the energy bill relief
scheme under review and materially
improve the discount for businesses and
also reform the apprenticeship Levy to
make it easier and cheaper for employee
employers to recruit and retain Talent
at the moment there's a lot of we've
heard about
employers buying equipment rather than
investing in people and as the uh and
remember from cities of London had said
reintroduced the vat retail export
scheme to make London and other UK
destinations more competitive to
overseas Shoppers it will actually add a
net gain to the public purse
um
there has been in local authorities
especially mine in Brent during the
pandemic and the current cost of living
crisis there's it means that local
authorities will have to make Savings of
at least a hundred million pounds next
year to balance budgets that is just not
sustainable for local authorities such
as mine in Brent and we have a problem
with homelessness shelter recently
reported that one in 58 londoners are
homeless so will the chancellor increase
the local housing allowance rates which
have been frozen since 2020 to help
homelessness
um and also in increased discretionary
housing payments
I mean all of these things the things
that the chancellor could have done if
who's really interested in investing in
growth in our countries because local
authorities can only do so much
um and I wonder if there is money to
provide additional investment for the
refurbishment of existing housing stock
to treat damp mold and address Fire and
Building Safety we know that when labor
came in last time they had to put a lot
of money into making social housing
right and and some of the very important
especially as I say in in London is to
remove all restrictions on how councils
can use right to buy receipts to sustain
affordable housing delivery without
placing additional demands on the public
person these are all things that can be
done if we had a bit of imagination from
the government and let me not forget
that London's Devolution settlement is
over 20 years old can the government's
commitment to deepen Devolution should
apply equally to London to enable London
boroughs and the mayor of London to
tackle 21st century problems facing the
capital today and I just wonder as I
conclude Madam Deputy speaker
if the chancellor will work closely with
London councils myself as chair of the
London PLP and to ensure that the burden
that we broaden the balance of Revenue
raising Powers available to councils in
the longer term to improve Financial
resilience and reduce Reliance on any
single funding stream we've heard today
that members opposite have said Madam
Deputy speaker that they're sometimes
confused what what we stand for on this
side of the house and and I just want to
uh I just want to reassure and reaffirm
that London stands and labor party
stands for a moral Crusade for making
our country better and I do hope the
government will take some of these
points on board
uh Jacob Reese smoke thank you I'm and
Deputy speaker and it's a pleasure to
follow the honorable lady from Brent
Central and I agree with her and my
honorable friend the member of the city
of London Westminster it would be a very
good thing to sort out the vat issue uh
for for goods that are going to be
exported
but Mom Deputy speaker listening to this
base and looking at the documents I've
been struck that I've made a mistake I
used to think that a phantasmagoria was
a forerunner of a moving picture the
sort of machine I might go home and
watch on a quiet Wednesday evening but
it turns out that a phantasmagoria is in
fact our current approach to economic
policy making and I refer honorable and
right honorable members to page
131 of the abr's report
which says since the ABR was established
in 2010 the government has had six
different fiscal mandates
so what actually happens is that the obr
comes up with forecasts that are wrong
to meet a government mandate that will
change and it means the value of the
exercise on which we are basing our
Economic Policy isn't actually right it
doesn't serve the purpose of what we're
trying to do which is to achieve
economic growth to increase the standard
of living of our constituents Generation
by generation and instead we're taking a
very theoretical approach which doesn't
work in practice and that's why we
haven't been achieving growth because we
haven't been willing to make the
decisions that are necessary to do it so
what do we have today well today we have
some things that are very welcome but
they're slightly picked out of a jar of
sweeties and we've taken to pick out the
one on pension reform this is a great
sweetie as it happens it's a a Toblerone
with um a Swiss marker on it of sweeties
I suppose because it could really
encourage investment it could make
people think that pension investing is a
long-term opportunity which it hasn't
been in recent years as long as this
reform remains and we don't next year
find that there's a new limit brought
back or the sixty thousand pound
investment limit annually is tweaked a
little bit because what we've had in
pension investing is such confusion that
you wonder why anyone has bothered in
recent years and it was only brought
into the sharp light of day by the fact
that people were retiring from the
public sector because the pension system
had become so lunatically punitive in
the high marginal rates it charged so
look that's a very welcome aspect as
long as it's stuck to deregulation of
child care again is a good thing to be
doing
um I pointed out to others that if
somebody like me is allowed to be left
in charge of six children and that is
perfectly legal even without any
government intervention or of stead
inquiry or anything that it seemed a
little surprising that people much more
capable and better trained than me could
only look after four so I'm glad that
the number is being increased and I'm
delighted that fuel duty is being frozen
as the mayor of London wishes to Savage
the motorist and wishes to put them into
penury I am reassured that the
conservatives continue to be on the side
of the motorist so those are some of the
sweeties that we've been able to pick
out but it's not all sweeties is it
because there is the continuation of a
number of things that weren't actually
mentioned in the budget that are going
to happen so everybody is having a real
terms increase in their tax because of
the failure to operate thresholds and
people are going to be coming into the
higher rate of tax who particularly if
they're living in London are not
actually that well off so there is a big
tax rise that we are getting and that's
where I go back to the because by
failing to Think Through economic policy
in a way that will actually work but
thinking of it in this theoretical basis
we have seen the tax take rise look what
happened in the Thatcher era and this is
page 80 of the ABI I think the ABR is
useless for the record I think it is a
body that gives bad forecasts that are
consistently wrong
but some of the data that are in the
document the historic data are perfectly
respectable but this is important
between 1981 and 1995 what you might
call the Thatcher era
taxes have essential GDP fell from 33.9
to 27.4 percent
once the Socialists got in it started
rising and you'd have thought that when
the conservatives got in again in 2010
it might have come down a bit not a bit
of it it's gone on Rising and that seems
to me to be the problem that we're
facing so we have arised now in
corporation tax but we then sort of
salami slice it a bit with some Capital
allowances to pretend it's not much of a
rise this is not a good approach to tax
policy the best approach to tax policy
is low tax rates with few exclusions we
hear powerful arguments from the other
side against tax avoidance but this is
setting up a tax avoidance scheme that
companies are being asked to carry out
because the government thinks it may
Be A Way businesses will spend money in
the that's approved of by the government
but actually who knows best how to spend
their money businesses or the government
businesses so what you want is low rates
rather than distorting investment to
make it go in the way that the
government currently thinks is
fashionable and that's why I think we
should be cutting corporation tax and
looking at what has happened in the
Republic of Ireland which has been
mentioned before but the figures are
Stark I wonder if the treasury bench is
aware that in the Republic of Ireland
corporation tax raises more money than
value-added tax and it's a very similar
vat base to the one in the UK the
figures are
22.6 billion in corporation tax to 18.6
billion in vat Euros compared in the UK
to 82 billion in corporation tax to 162
billion of vat lower taxes raise more
money
let us for once move away from the
old-fashioned from the phantasmagoria
and update ourselves to a modern age tax
cuts and economic growth
Bill Esther listen
short-term giveaways to placate
conservative backbenches the potholes
hotline after 400 million pounds of cuts
to highways budgets apparently their
favorite
in this sticking plaster budget after 13
years of failure and The Bleak obr
analysis shows living standards six
percent lower in two years time and
still below pre-pandemic Levels by 2028
and what was the chance was Flagship
announcement
to prioritize those already the
wealthiest during a cost of living
crisis
other countries have recovered strongly
since the pandemic but not the UK
so how absurd that the chancellor should
crow about avoiding recession when the
UK will still be the only country where
GDP will not have recovered to
pre-pandemic Levels by the end of this
year
now low growth since 2010 has seen
households 8 800 pounds per year worse
off on average when compared to the
average growth in the oecd and a 40
billion pounds Gap in the tax revenues
as well
party which presided over low growth
since 2010 and crashed the economy
was never going to have the answers for
the deep-seated problems they created
and so it was
with the budget that the chancellor
announced
whatever today was it wasn't a long-term
plan for business
investment is a record low level firms
like AstraZeneca are moving overseas
small business forced to close through
high energy bills
High business rates shortages of
supplies and the lack of skilled workers
and one of our International
competitiveness
when the United States is attracting
investment through the invest the
inflation reduction Act and the European
Union is implementing its own equivalent
plan let's look at what business says
here's what my cause of the smmt said
today there is little that enables the
UK to compete with the massive packages
of support to power a green transition a
green transition that are available
elsewhere
and let's look at what make UK says this
does little to tackle the real and
immediate threat manufacturers face with
rocketing energy bills and that's a
point reiterated by the British Chambers
of Commerce who also criticize the
failure to reform business rights
or take Martin Tague of the Federation
small business today's budget will leave
many feeling shortchanged the
government's lack of support for small
firms in critical eras areas is glaring
he said
businesses want long-term help with
their energy costs
they want the abolition of business
rates they want reform of the
apprenticeship Levy so they can all use
it for what they need
and they want greater access to
procurement for businesses of all sizes
labor is committed to all of these as
part of our industrial strategy
businesses agree with our plans for
self-sufficiency and renewable
electricity generation to cut bills and
Guarantee Supply whilst playing our part
in hitting our climate meeting our
climate obligations installation of 19
million homes too and they agree with
our plans for eight gigafactories and a
rollout of EV charging points using
grants and low interest loans for
consumers
absolutely critical in the transition to
Electric when especially when new car
sales are at 70 percent low
they agree with our plans because the
plans have been drawn up in partnership
with industry
Labor's green Prosperity plan is a
response to the massive attraction of
the Biden plan investors and businesses
support us it's the labor party that
recognizes that the party of the worker
has to be the party of business that's
why we will be partners of business and
trade unions when we are in government
it's how modern industrialized economies
thrive
partnership
no wonder John Allen the chairman of
Tesco and Barrett says there's only one
political team on the pitch and it's
labor
the failure of this government
to take a strategic approach
will continue to undermine our prospects
And Delay any recovery in living
standards that's what the obr says
a Madam Deputy speaker this week it's
the Cheltenham Festival
I have two pieces of advice
firstly come to the Grand National in my
constituency next month
it is of course the biggest horse race
in the world
the second piece of advice after this
sticking plaster of a budget
don't gamble at Cheltenham or Aintree
save your money for the sure bet of a
general election and a labor win
Walker thank you very much Madam Mr
Speaker and my honorable friend for West
Worcestershire made her contribution to
this debate talking about inflation and
I'd agree with some of the contributions
we've heard but just as important as the
fact that we have avoided a technical
recession is the fact that inflation
figures are forecast to come down very
sharply that is hugely important and it
has been right that the government has
helped households with the cost of
living including the 94 billion cost
package that sets that out in this
budget and that is not to be sniffed off
I particularly welcome the announcement
on prepayment meters and I I
congratulate The Honorable lady opposite
on her campaign on that issue I do think
it's it it's an important issue of
social justice and and many of us have
been raising concerns about repayment
meters over a long period of time so I
congratulate her on her success in that
regard but the main thing I want to say
as chairman of the education selectivity
is thank you to the chancellor for
listening to the concerns that
colleagues on all sides of the house
have been raising about child care and
the cost of a of an affordability of
child care I want to pay tribute to the
members on all sides of this house who
have raised this issue consistently The
Honorable lady for Wolf and stove The
Honorable lady for Birmingham Yardley
The Honorable Lady of twinkling who
speaks for Liberal Democrats but also my
honorable friends for Stroud for
northamptonshire South for edisbury
Newbury
and ruislip at Northwood and Pinner all
of them have spoken up about the need
for reforming child care and the need
for properly funding uh the the the
so-called free but I think more
correctly subsidized uh hours or or of
child care that we provide and there is
some really welcome decisions in this
budget uh to to go further on that the
decision first of all to invest I spoke
recently in the estimates day debate for
the Department of Education I described
investing in child care at the early
years as a win to the power of four and
I think the decision that the chancellor
has taken here after uh defense
investing in child care in the early
years is the next big spending
commitment in this budget I will both of
those and I think they're both key
Investments for the long run I do really
welcome the idea of extending the 30
hours offer to one and two-year-olds I
think it's been pointed out by many
people again on all sides of this house
um the the the Gap that exists between
the end of um parental leave and and the
beginning of support and that Gap has
been made significantly smaller uh by
this government's introduction of the
the 30 hours for three and four year
olds it's been made significantly better
for a small group of people by the
disadvantaged offer for two-year-olds
but actually widening the offer uh to
cover 30 hours
um for uh one two three and four year
olds uh could be game changing but it
will only be game changing if we make
sure the sector is properly funded and
in that respect I I do welcome uh the
fact that as part of today's
announcement the government has
announced a step up in the funding for
the existing allowances 204 million uh
next year increasing to 288 million uh
for the year uh after um but I would
point out what we've heard on the select
committee are cons concerns about the
very real cost pressures that the sector
is facing right now and and those
include very substantial increases in
business rates uh it is a real problem
it is a very real problem affecting this
sector for the voluntary and independent
sector which is such a key part
um of the child care sector and actually
I joined some of the calls we've heard
opposite from uh and and from members on
this side for further uh consideration
of business rates uh reform uh one other
concern I have about the announcements
on Child Care is around
um the the ratios what we've heard on
the select committee and what we've
heard very clearly from the sector uh is
that if this is voluntary it's not one
that many in the sector will be taking
up and it's certainly not what they hear
from parents uh that they want but I
welcome the fact that the government has
listened to the consultation and has at
least made this uh optional
um I I think that I listened very
carefully to some of the arguments being
made by my honorable friend for
Northeast Hampshire about family
taxation I think there is great sympathy
uh on the select committee for going
further on providing genuine tax-free
child care and I hope that's something
we'll be able to pick up as we move
forward with our inquiry I also very
much welcome the emphasis on expanding
uh provision of child minding and the
reforms to Universal Credit
um they they can make a very substantial
difference a very substantial
contribution uh in this space and and
again that is something which I think is
going with the grain of the sector but
we do need to make sure that we have
sustainable funding for both the
maintained and VI sector in nurseries
investing in child care in the early
years is the right thing to do but of
course there are other pressures um
within the department for education's uh
remit uh I I we heard from the ifs how
under a conservative government
investment in the early years had grown
faster than almost any other area of
Education spending but we also heard
from the ifs Ms summary of Education
spending over the last decade that the
post-16 Fe provision what my
predecessors select committee chair
often described as a Cinderella sector
um is one of the most tightly squeezed
and I hope as we move forward from this
budget towards the Autumn statement uh
the treasury will look very carefully at
the needs for more investment in that
sector and schools whilst welcoming the
2.3 billion extra at the spending review
do still face a real squeeze from the
combination of inflationary pressures
and pay Rises for both teaching and
non-teaching staff now there are some
smaller announcements as part of this
budget which I do really want to welcome
the three million pounds for supported
internships buried away in the red book
I don't think it was in the Chancellor's
speech but eleven and a half million
pounds for ukrainians to access language
programs that's extremely welcome and
something that I know from my time at
the DFE that the provision of esol could
be variable any extra money that is
spent on that and supporting that and
supporting the Ukrainian families in all
of our constituencies uh will be uh well
spent I really welcome the extra support
for children in care and the amazing
people who support them I hope that the
government will look carefully at
extending that further particularly when
it comes to kinship carers now listen
with interest what my honorable friend
for northamptonshire South said about
attendance allowance for grandparents
there's one further point that I wanted
to pick up in this uh the action that
has been taken on pensions to help keep
doctors in the NHS is extremely welcome
and very important that will also I
think help improve the issue of
retention for head teachers but action
to keep and retain doctors we also need
more places in our medical schools and I
met this morning with MPS Worcestershire
herefordshire and gloucestershire with
the hospitals minister to press the case
for funded places at the Three Counties
medical school in my own constituency
this is something that would make a real
difference I heard the chancellor
mention his long-term NHS Workforce plan
I'm glad to hear that will be announced
shortly I sincerely hope and will
absolutely keep pushing for the fact
that funded places at Three Counties
medical school in Worcester need to be
part of that
Claire Hannah thank you chair Madam
Deputy speaker and a pleasure to to
follow the member for Worcester in a
characteristically fair and unpractical
um speech many of the measures obviously
announced uh today are to be welcomed
although it is very clear that people am
struggling uh with the cost of living
with increased mortgages with uh the
pressures in small businesses trying to
pay energy bills and and find staff will
not recognize uh the rosie picture that
was presented uh on on the benches
opposite and it is impossible not to see
that so many of the initiatives are due
to commence in 2024 and when it is
likely that uh The Avengers opposite
will not be occupied uh by the same
people and in many cases this is a
fiscal Hospital pass for my colleagues
on on this bench
um it's also of course my focus today is
on is on uh Northern Ireland and
generally the context for us is the real
opportunity we now have to get on with
things through
um The Windsor framework but the context
is all also
um the the disadvantage we have through
the lack of an executive to implement
some of the uh initiatives that may be
better funded after today and nowhere is
that um implementation Gap clearer than
in child care um I really must command
all of the the members in this house and
the campaign groups um outside who have
fought very hard and pushed uh for this
uh these measures to be uh uh announced
on as a as the lucky mom of three large
Child Care bills I can confirm that this
approach is very much overdue and vital
but it is so crucial that this goes
further than a press release an
announcement and a headline this is a
sector that needs really serious reform
um to to support families that is
focused on children's development that
finally begins and to tackle the the
educational inequality that we know is
set in the first or Thousand Days
um of child's life and on which child
care and can play such a role in that we
make sure that the funding is there for
this not just to be a minding of young
people but to to Really
um get in there and change some of those
stubborn fixed outcomes the changes must
also not leave behind the workforce um
of of this vital sector whose wages have
never matched um the skill and care and
increasingly um the qualifications that
they need
it's fair to say I am a True Believer in
Devolution and it's par and its
protection for a region like ours but I
regret to say as a founding chair of of
the assembly old party group on child
care this is one area where we have
absolutely fallen behind Northern
Ireland doesn't even have the 30
um three or 33 hours for three and
four-year-olds that is in place in parts
of England and I welcome to the proposed
allocation of up to 40 million uh for
Northern Ireland for further and higher
education and hope we can begin to end
um the export of our finest resource um
in Northern Ireland that's our young
people many thousands of whom
um have to leave after tens of thousands
of phones being put into their primary
and post primary education have to leave
to get a university place due to the
artificial miles and cap but I hope that
this funding is one of the things that
gets us moving on the skills deficit as
well that leaves our workers young and
old not able to access the training
opportunities they need to get into
um the the the the labor market of today
um and of the future is often a real uh
mismatch in what we're providing for
skills I'm disappointed that there isn't
as yet
um specific proposals to to address the
really alarming
um Cliff Edge facing many charities in
third sector organizations in Northern
Ireland
um who specialize in employability
um due to the loss of of the ESF which
is uh European social fund which is
um Reckoning on a loss of tens of
millions of pounds for years per year
um in in in Northern Ireland and the
chancellor spoke directly about the
so-called economically inactive so it is
Pennywise and pound foolish to allow to
feel many of the schemes and that are
tried and tested in in getting into the
the labor market some people who do need
a little bit of extra support
um due to additional needs or or for
other reasons there are opportunities
now and we cannot let feel of the
organizations that support them at a
labor market by the way that is
undoubtedly disadvantaged by the the
difficulty bringing in talent and from
elsewhere and it's disappointing that
there hasn't been a recording
um about that all about the impact of
Labor uh shortages in in key parts of
the economy
um I welcome to the specific allocation
to the tackling paramilism program and I
urge those allocating that to invest and
invest and invest in community
resilience and to Alternative leaders
and to learn the lessons of of practice
and power military transition look at
the good and look what absolutely has
not worked um as we try to to rid our
neighborhoods and our society of the
cancer of power military hard man
holding uh people back and praying on
the on the vulnerable um on Green
Technology and transition some progress
is welcome but as the leader of the
opposition said we are not yet really
even on the pitch and remind the
government that green jobs aren't just
you know people in Hive is and working
with steel and all that jobs and caring
and education or or by definition no
emissions and but for Northern Ireland
um the multi-level transition we needed
we can play a real part we are very very
well positioned to be a leader in wind
and entitle and hydrogen and other
things that could be really game
changing with the sort of strategy and
investment we're seeing for example in
the US and the EU a disappointing missed
opportunity with the squeeze the most
vulnerable not to reinstate the UC
uplift and address the two child limit
which are are key concerns of the
Northern Ireland women's budget group
who have who have layered in this area
in Northern Ireland and in finishing
modern Deputy speaker
um all of Northern Ireland's opportunity
comes back to the Windsor framework and
the chance that we do know-how for a new
beginning uh politically and
economically that includes selling or
dual Market access and I and my party
have uh shouted loudly for two years in
this house I know about the unique uh
proposition we now have we're seeing a
boom in some parts of the economy and
life sciences and and advanced
manufacturing on the Niagara foods and
but that needs an executive and it needs
a very serious uh strategy in place to
spend the barn of consequentials and to
realize the potential of our region this
next few weeks we're going to be marking
uh and celebrating the 25th anniversary
of the Good Friday agreement we've had
two and a half Decades of Peace
processing with the right investment on
the right strategy the next 25 can be
our prosperity years I just remind
everybody that if people do keep to
about six or seven minutes which they
appear to be doing we'll get everybody
in and there are no windets at the end
of today's proceedings Natalie elfick
thank you Mr Deputy speaker it's a
pleasure to follow the honorable member
for Belfast South and the way in which
she highlighted the importance of child
care I congratulate the chancellor on
today's budget to support families and
businesses with a cost of living and
growth for my constituents in Dover and
deal there are three measures I would
like to highlight which will make a
particular impact the first is the fuel
Duty freeze and continuing energy
support as many people rely on their
cars to get around and recent Fuel and
energy prices have been worrying for
very many people the second is the
expansion of free child care for young
children and I welcome the focus on
older workers skills and job support in
Dover and Deals since 2020 average wages
have risen unemployment has fallen youth
unemployment has fallen there are
thousands more people employed in my
Dover and dual constituency than when
labor left office in 2010. the measures
taken by conservative governments have
created more jobs and money in Dover and
deal
added to which to over 63 million pound
leveling up funding will create new
creative and digital skills campus and
investment in Port and road
infrastructure
I want to see our whole area grow and
Thrive so the further jobs and skill
support set out in this budget is
welcome
the support for older people uh older
workers is important but discrimination
against older workers is very real
next week I have a 10-minute rule motion
to tackle this very issue of age
discrimination against older workers and
I'll be looking to work very closely
with ministers on ensuring that the
ambition set out in this budget can be
matched with increased employment for
older workers
there is one area where I hoped there
would be more to say in this budget and
that's around housing and house building
and in this regard I draw attention to
my register of interests in relation to
my unpaid directorship of the housing
and finance Institute
under the conservatives house building
has been booming recently with over 200
000 homes delivered last year
in Dover and deal the conservative Dover
district council has delivered an
impressive program of building their own
Council homes affordable and social
renting and shared ownership locally
Dover and Dior conservatives are
delivering affordable local homes
however broader economic conditions have
led to a Slowdown in-house building
which currently looks to be severe the
home builders Federation have said this
looks to be the worst period for house
building since the financial crash the
obr forecast on the housing market has
worsened since November 10 down in house
prices and property transactions down 20
percent
this matters for today's budget because
house building is an area that
contributes 15 billion to 17 billion
pounds for each hundred thousand homes
built new homes also support around 8
billion pounds in additional
infrastructure investment that's roads
that's schools that's GP surgeries and
environmental improvements the financial
impact of a downturn in-house building
is significant and I had hoped and I
hope to see more from the chancellor in
relation to supporting this important
sector
because house building doesn't just
matter in relation to economic activity
or GDP not building enough homes creates
more strain on existing housing stock
higher prices for renting and for buying
higher rents the worst value for money
and for the poorest households they end
up footing the bill for higher rents
which they simply cannot afford and it's
not fair this is something that I feel
needs to be addressed
members of this house will be aware that
there are more than a hundred thousand
people in our country who don't have a
Home of Their Own they are in temporary
accommodation or homeless that's why
I've been working with colleagues at the
housing and finance Institute on a plan
called operation Homemaker to build a
hundred thousand homes over a year and a
half to house the homeless and those in
temporary accommodation
one of the calls in the HFI plan was for
a discounted rate of Public Works loan
board funding for councils so that they
can bring forward social housing as
Dover is doing as we said in the
Homemaker report long-term and
discounted pwlb can reduce or even
eliminate the need for subsidy for
long-term affordable rented housing so
I'm pleased the chancellor has listened
and made new discounted funding
available to councils who want to do
more
I also welcome his commitment to reforms
on unlocking Pension funds for
investment this is another key part of
the Homemaker plan
I'd be grateful if my honorable friend
could ensure as those measures come
forward that they support the massive
appetite for pensions fund investment in
long-term affordable and other housing
I've been pleased that we've secured
positive engagement with the Secretary
of State for leveling up housing and
communities on the Homemaker program as
well as meeting with the Prime Minister
about it but I would ask if the
chancellor would meet with me so that we
can see what more can be done with the
funding envelopes that he has set out in
this year's budget to get those houses
on the ground for people in our country
who need them most because having grown
up in a council house myself I know from
personal experience the importance of
stable housing and how good housing can
and does change lives it's good for the
country's balance sheet too because
investing in stable secure housing saves
money for the taxpayer it eliminates the
1.6 billion pounds spent on insecure
temporary accommodation include a
staggering 125
000 children in temporary accommodation
it reduces the amount of the massive
housing benefit bill it adds to GDP and
good stable affordable housing adds to
that mission stated today of getting
people into work and helping people stay
in work
so to conclude Mr Deputy speaker I
thanked a Chancellor and the whole
treasury team again for their work on
this budget and I hope that together we
will make we may keep Britain building
particularly with a new National mission
to house the homeless and build the
affordable homes our country needs very
much Judy Collins thank you Mr Deputy
speaker and it's a pleasure to follow
from The Honorable member from Dover
today's budget comes as the most
challenging time for my constituents it
follows 13 years of turmoil incompetence
and empty promises under a conservative
government
today's budget promised 80 million
pounds to West Yorkshire over five years
or 16 million pounds a year through the
investment tax zones whilst I broadly
welcome this it is no replacement for
the broken promises of the multi-billion
pound return that Northern Powerhouse
rail would have brought
this government once spark of the
superconnected globally competitive
northern economy made possible with the
creation of Northern Powerhouse rail yet
in their recent plans they abandoned the
much given promise to connect Leeds and
Manchester via a new high-speed line
with a city center stock in Bradford
instead the north is having to settle
with a mere upgrade to existing lines
and we are told yet again not to gripe
because done properly Northern
Powerhouse rail would have supported an
integrated urban area larger than
Birmingham Lincoln Bradford and Leeds to
form a coherent economic unit with a
labor market of more than 1.3 million
people and creating more than 600 000
jobs
and with the projected 30 billion return
from NPR over 10 years so whilst welcome
when set against this backdrop the 80
million pounds for the whole of West
Yorkshire is underwhelming by choosing
not to invest Fuller in NPR these
short-term savings will have long-term
consequences for the people of Bradford
and because Bradford is an area of
enormous economic potential PWC have
recognized this I was there when PWC
opened their Bradford office in 2019
during the pandemic with just 80 staff
members the office is now rapidly grown
to employ over 200 people because PWC
had the vision to tap into the underused
talent pool in Bradford in a market
where skills are in short supply I urge
other employers to follow pwc's pwc's
example
and I only wish that the government
would do the same and invest in Bradford
and because growth requires a skilled
Workforce during the past five years of
this conservative government the
education attainment gap between the
richest and the poorest has been growing
at an alarming rate recently I met with
the chief executive of school home
support who are doing tremendous work
with primary schools in my constituency
by working with families in both home
and school settings they are helping
them to overcome obstacles that limit
their children's educational
opportunities and life chances and this
is working attendance is Improvement and
attainment is rising and because
tackling inequality always requires a
creative approach one which Fosters
positive outcomes for health education
and Community cohesion there was a real
possibility in my own constituency
through a strong level in upbid to use
the Redevelopment of oddsall Stadium as
a catalyst for regeneration
Spike Bradford being independent
independently identified as the UK's
number one leveling up opportunity the
government decided against investing in
Bradford
with the right investment and with faith
in areas such as Bradford Britain's
economy could be on the verge of a new
era a sustained long-term economic
growth but Mr Deputy speaker my
constituents need a government that is
on their side and a budget that supports
their Ambitions they've received neither
from the party of gimmick's opposite not
over the last 13 years and currently
certainly not today
Peter Algos thank you very much Mr
Deputy speaker it's a pleasure to follow
the honorable lady from Bradford South
my right honorable friend the chancellor
was bequeathed to a very difficult
immediate inheritance last October and
in his Autumn statement delivered on
17th November he took the first steps to
putting the nation's finances back on a
secure footing laying the foundations
for sustainable long-term economic
growth he is to be commended for what he
has done in the past four months with
policies that will significantly reduce
inflation and will cut government
spending on debt interest his
initiatives announced today with regard
to child care the abolition of Lifetime
allowances Universal Credit reform and
supporting the disabled into work are to
be welcomed as are his announcements
with regard to investment allowances and
tax breaks however in the aftermath of
covid there are ingredients to economic
growth that are missing and it is
important that the budget this budget is
not the end game and is instead the
first installment of a plan for growth
with parts two and three being delivered
in the Autumn and this time next year Mr
Deputy speaker I shall highlight three
themes which I believe that is important
to keep firmly in mind as we hopefully
move on from the seismic shock that
covid has delivered and the devastating
and heartbreaking ongoing impact of
Putin's invasion of the Ukraine firstly
it is important to continue to support
albeit hopefully on a reducing scale
those people and businesses who have
been most impacted by this cruel double
whammy my right honorable friend is
right to extend the energy price
guarantee scheme for three months and to
introduce the energy bill discount
scheme for businesses he is also right
to support local councils with their um
Leisure Center costs and also very
welcome the support for the charitable
and the third sector he does however
need to keep the situation under review
and I'll suggest you need to pay
particular regard to the following
firstly the disabled and I have thinking
in particular of those of neurological
conditions such as Parkinson's Ms and
mnd who have been seriously impacted by
the dramatic increases in energy costs
and we must not forget the ongoing
challenges that they face in the longer
term it may well be appropriate to
introduce a social tariff to support
such vulnerable groups and I would urge
the government to look very closely at
how this might work I'm also conscious
with the needs of businesses who face
particular challenges and I have in mind
such sectors as Metal Finishing who use
large amounts of electricity who are
losing work overseas and who are not as
yet included in the government support
for energy intensive Industries and I
would urge the chancellor to keep this
under review
secondly Mr Deputy speaker it's a it's
important to put in place measures that
enable businesses to thrive
the tax breaks and the offsetting
arrangements that my right honorable
friend has announced today are welcome
but they are only a start
in the Autumn statement my right
honorable friend announced major reforms
to business rates but this work needs to
be continued in the short term the
non-domestic rating bill must be
introduced as quickly as possible and in
the longer term work should continue so
that business rates return to being a
much smaller component part of a
business's operating costs secondly the
energy sector is a vital import vitally
important component part of the UK
economy from a local perspective in East
Anglia there are significant
opportunities for generating prosperity
and jobs ensuring our energy security
and driving forward on the road to Net
Zero there is enormous potential in
offshore wind
site nuclear and sizable and in the oil
and gas sector through the North Sea
transition deal which also paves the way
for hydrogen and carbon capture and
storage on which we did get some good
news earlier Mr Deputy speaker if we are
to realize this once in a the
opportunities once in a lifetime
opportunity it is vital that we reform
our fiscal and Regulatory regime so that
investment does not go overseas whether
to the US to Europe or beyond the
chancellor has made a start in meeting
this particular Challenge and I look
forward to the government's clean energy
reset which must enable the UK to retain
our position as a global leader in the
energy sector
to speak to achieve long-term economic
growth to enable people to realize their
full potential we need a skills
Revolution here there remains a great
deal of work to do it is right that my
honorable friend is looking closely at
this and has asked Sir Michael Barber to
carry out a full review however in the
short term further education colleges
such as East Coast College in lowestoft
are doing great work but with one arm
behind their backs in the immediate
future there is an urgent need for more
Revenue funding to get them what for is
incredibly challenging period in the
longer term I highlight the need for
reforming the apprenticeship living
thirdly and finally Mr Deputy speaker I
come to leveling up
I
I come to leveling up along with the
honorable member for Cambridge I
co-chair the all party group for the
east of England in December along with
the local government Association we
published a report on leveling up in the
east of England which concludes that on
five of the leveling up missions there
was very low confidence of them being
achieved
one of these missions is infrastructure
and it is in this context the lack of
government support for the Elian Hawley
Junction rail improvements from which
the whole of the UK would benefit is
very disappointing and I urge the
government to continue to work with
those in the region promoting this
project
on a positive note I welcome the
announcement of funding for the
lowestoft seafront Jubilee parade
project which is important component
part of the regeneration work that is
taking place in lowestoft and will help
Revitalize the town making it a
compelling place in which to live to
work and to visit however Mr Deputy
speaker I cannot hide my disappointment
that none of the 12 proposed investment
zones are in the east of England in
lowestoft we have a successful
Enterprise Zoom which is in need of
refreshing we had a full start last
September when Suffolk County Council
and the Suffolk Council put forward
exciting proposals for investment zones
it now appears that in the East that
nowhere in the east of England will have
an opportunity to even be on the
starting grid in this context the Mantra
of Enterprise employment and everywhere
does Wings slightly Hollow in conclusion
Mr Deputy speaker this budget is not the
end game there is a lot of Unfinished
Business last November my right
honorable friend delivered his prologue
to delay today he has provided act one
of his strategic strategy for growth
Acts 2 and 3 come in the come in the
Autumn and next spring I've highlighted
the work that I believe remains to be
done and in the coming months I look
forward to working with him and his
colleagues in the treasury to meet and
address these challenges Mr Thomas
speaker it's a pleasure to follow the
honorable gentleman for uh for Waverly
um he uh rightly implies that this
budget offers very thin pickings for
most in the UK certainly does for my
constituents and it underlines the fact
that we've seen no wage growth across
the UK for 13 years taxes are at record
levels and the obr confirming today the
very Grim news of record Falls in living
standards it would be chillish of me not
to welcome the moves on Child Care
albeit with the very powerful caveats
that were made by my right honorable
friend
um the member for barking and dagenham
and uh to Welcome to the move on uh
pre-payment meters I wanted to just
underline a message from Japan uh
Japan's decade of lost growth many in
this house will be familiar with which
took place at the end of the 1990s saw
an average annual rate of growth of just
1 percent
between 2016 and 2025 the UK is set to
experience even worse an average growth
rate of just 0.8 percent so we Face a
conservative decade of lost growth
missed opportunities and as my right
honorable Fred friends said from the
dispatch box managed decline
the resolution Foundation last year
underlined the significance of that lost
a decade for the UK typical incomes will
were higher in Ireland than in the UK by
six percent are higher in France by 10
and Germany by 19 percent
they are extraordinary figures and
underline the point about the UK
increasingly have then become the sick
man of Europe a profoundly worrying a
state of affairs I would suggest for all
of us
the resolution Foundation also
highlighted last year how the party
opposites particularly toxic combination
of both low growth and persistently High
income inequality has led to some in our
country being particularly exposed to
the cost of living so it was
particularly disappointing once again
sadly not surprising to see nothing in
the budget of substance on the effort to
tackle the rise in child poverty in this
country up to now nearly 20 percent of
uh of children living in poverty almost
16 percent in in my constituency alone
we can do better as a country and we
must do better for our constituents
although I fear it will fall to a future
labor government to reverse the trends I
was particularly disappointed that the
chancellor didn't bring forward a bolder
package to address the slow growth
Britain has experienced over the last
decade and is likely to see over the
next two or three years or two other G7
countries have seen faster growth for
example in exports to the world's
largest economies Germany America even
Italy and France have seen their exports
to the world's fastest growing economies
in the G20 racing ahead of Britain in
the last decade decade now the poorly
negotiated trade deal with Europe was
clearly done considerable damage and the
lack of that much promised U.S trade
deal hasn't helped either but Cuts in
support to British businesses wanting to
attend trade shows trade shows a woeful
government website for helping exporters
and late Decisions by ministers on which
markets to prioritize and then little
follow-up from uh from Whitehall when
businesses go to those markets are
consistent criticisms from British
businesses
the other striking thing about this
budget is how little there was for our
Public Services which to put it uh
generously are heavily uh stretched
hardly surprising perhaps given the
attacks on staff in those Public
Services who have the temerity to ask
for decent uh pay and we all remember
only too well the Prime on that on the
prime minister's watch nearly 30 billion
pounds has been lost to fraud to vanity
projects and even crony uh crony
contracts that could have been invested
in galvanizing the green economic
renewal that our country so desperately
needs or it could have been invested
just in our schools hospitals and police
in Harrow our public services are crying
out uh for investment huge pressure on
our GP surgeries over 2 000 people in
Harrow had to wait more than a month for
a GP appointment in January 8 000 having
to wait between two weeks and four weeks
for an appointment now that's not a
criticism of the staff who work at our
excellent GP uh GP surgeries it is
simply the fact that they are under huge
uh pressure similarly at the hospital
which serves my constituents North Lake
Park almost uh 50 over 43 of people
attending accident and emergency
services are having to wait longer than
four hours it isn't that long ago Mr
Deputy speaker when we had clinics uh in
our in across the borough of Harrow
three clinics across the viral Harrow
that supported uh GP surgeries and
ensured that no one who needed to see a
doctor or a a nurse waited more than an
hour to get it now they face as I set
out many many of them face very long
waits to do that and inevitably that
increases uh pressure on the rest of the
NHS now the chancellor knows that there
is a uh there are huge shortages in
terms of staff in the in the NHS and he
also knows that if he backed the
abolition of non-dome status as we on
this side of the house have argued for
we could double the number of medical
school places and we could train some 10
000 more uh nurses every year which
would make a certainly make a stop but
it isn't in addressing the crisis in the
NHS but it's not just staff that we need
none of the promised 40 new hospitals
that we have seen uh promised has
actually had work beginning on those new
hospitals and all the while the need for
new investment is growing across the NHS
estate at Northwick Park as well as a
rising backlog of essential maintenance
there's a need for capital investment in
new intensive care beds to help improve
a e Services there and this budget
doesn't offer much hope that there will
be change in that regard to our Borough
schools need more investment too and
again and a government determined to put
in place a plan to boost Recruitment and
help head teachers retain staff per
pupil funding in real terms is lower now
than a decade ago and it was striking
that the chance of the exchequer had
nothing to say on that or indeed nothing
to offer in terms of more funding for
our Police Services over 75 percent drop
in the number of police Community
Support officers in London over the last
decade where once we had local police
teams of a sergeant three police
constables and three or four pcsos in
every area of Harrow now we're lucky to
have one PC and one PSO pcso per award
and even that has required extra
investment by the mayor of London to
achieve funding for the Met police is so
tight that it cannot fund Town Center
Police teams in every part of London so
the former prime minister the right
honorable gentleman's constituents in
Uxbridge gets a town center police team
but mine in Harrow does not this I have
to say Mr Deputy speaker was a very
disappointing budget and I hope we'll
see a labor government soon to put right
its mistakes
thank you it's a pleasure to follow the
uh honorable gentleman now
a few weeks ago if I was thinking about
the budget I was probably thinking times
I probably shouldn't bother actually
there's going to be no rigor room here
there's no money to spend you might as
well wait till the Autumn when we've got
a better idea what the public finances
look like but actually what we've seen
is really quite some somebody quite
significant announcements today I I
remember being advised a few years ago
that when you got a two trillion pound
economy any intervention of less than a
billion probably won't touch the size
and isn't worth paying that much
excitement to so I always look through
the red book to see how many things
score over a billion and we actually
have you know
to a total of new policy announcements
for 20 billion for the next financial
year and the one after we've actually
got the child care changes the full
expensing the fuel Duty the energy price
guarantee and defense spending all over
a billion pound I mean actually there's
some really quite significant items
there and some quite far-reaching
changes my constituents I think were
particularly welcome the fuel Duty for
using the retaining of the um 5p
reduction from from last year that
really helped them with their their cost
of living I think it's absolutely right
to retain the energy price support I
called for that on the cost of living
support payments I actually I'm not
quite sure why we didn't just extend
that until after next winter if we think
bills will be below two and a half
thousand pound on the price cap there's
no cost to having the extension if we
think battery bills will be higher than
that then we need the extension so why
were those the government actually used
to keep it an eye on this and try and
practice with the certainty for next
winter that their bills wouldn't be any
higher than they've been this would
have been this winter and I I agree also
that the log over to change those on on
prepayment meters makes complete sense
it the child care changes I think are
hugely welcome and I actually I welcome
the fact that they actually pick up many
of the ideas in the DWP selectivity
report from a
from a few weeks ago on this I I do
think at some point we should just stand
back and think
if we decided years ago that we would
give people free child care from when
their children were effectively aged
nine months until they leave school at
age 18. would you structure it quite
like this with the complex number of
schemes in the 30 hours and the tax-free
child care and all the other options
that are there well there isn't actually
a better way of delivering this for
people that's not quite as a cumbersome
for them because I can say this is a
parent of two children who are going to
be three in three weeks time you know
actually 30 hours free child care for
some weeks of the year does not mean my
wife can work full time 46 weeks of the
year it actually means she can work
part-time for some of those weeks I I
just think we should be careful with
actually what we're offering if we think
we need wrap around child care for 8 P.M
just for 8 A.M to 6 p.m for kids who are
five do we need that for kids who are
two as well I I just think we just need
to think through what the offering
actually what we really want if we want
people back working nearly full time do
we need to have a slightly different
offering there I also welcome the
support the swimming pools I've got
three effectively Council own swimming
pools in my constituency and there's
been huge huge problem with the energy
bills for those and actually the council
tax rise was in part to pay for the
heating of those swimming pools so
that's really welcome and I hope the
council can now find a new use for all
that money
um the a pensions tax changes I think
are usually welcome I think we've all
wrestled with how can we stop what was a
a pension tax system designed to limit
how much to actually people got how can
we stop that driving people out to work
that we just really wanted to be in work
and there's been a load of crazy ideas
about just changing it for one in you
know for one sector of the economy which
I think would have been completely
unviable so I can there was no
alternative I think but to change the
lifetime allowance quite significantly I
was a bit surprised it was abolished
completely actually I think we would be
better having a larger lifetime cap and
not having the annual cap because I'm
not sure that I'm that worried about
restricting it on a year by year basis I
think it's right to restrict how much
tax if you get over your whole working
life it is worth noting that I I I don't
think we have changed the reduction in
the allowance you get if you're only
over 240 000 a year it's actually this
won't really be a big change to really
highest earners I think it is the right
answer also that we've effectively
Frozen the lump sum you can take tax
free a quarter of the current lifetime
allowance rather than having that
increase to effectively anything so yeah
that's probably sneaked in the in the
detail of that uh I think that's
similarly to the to the child care stuff
I just think we perhaps need to step
back and think what are we trying to do
with our tax regime for pensions because
we've always said they should be
tax-free on the way and then you
attacked on the income you draw down and
then got limits to how much tax relief
you can have but it's the new system
we've got really a coherent sensible way
of actually incentivizing pension saving
getting a fellows I think passing at
some point we should have a proper
review and say what are we trying to do
who are we trying to help what are we
trying to incentivize and then we would
use the 50 or so billion a year we
actually spend on this to actually
achieve the outcomes that we
that we want and probably likewise when
we look at full expensing for Capital
spend uh that's probably welcome if it
encourages an increases investment but
our way of giving tax effect to Capital
spend for businesses is somewhat
haphazard now I would like to encourage
people uh as the Americans are doing to
reassure the manufacturing they are that
they've outsourced over the last two
decades but what tax relief do you get
for building a factory uh nothing for
buildings you get some for the equipment
that's embedded in those buildings
nothing for the actual Factory
um is that a sensible situation why
would you not want to give tax
incentives to build factories in the UK
but we're giving 100 allowance in year
one to buy some more computers I mean
it's a it's a slightly counter-intuitive
situation I think I'm not sure actually
how many businesses really can use 100
of their Capital spend against profit in
year one I suppose for some they
carrying it would be hugely welcome and
I I said others will now be having to
defer those deductions and try and use
them over a more sensible time and I
would have thought actually if we're
going to get to the end of the three
years of this and make it permanent we
should just step back and think what do
we want people to do how do we
incentivize that and what's the best use
of the money that we want to allocate to
that so I think it's a welcome
short-term fix but as with so many
things we need just to actually make
them work for a long time and probably
as a final payment Deputy speaker I
welcome the announcements on nuclear I
remember Rolls Royce in Derby being very
keen on scoring modular reactors I think
about six or seven years ago could we
please order some so we can show to the
world we can make this technology work
and that's so that we're committed to it
so hopefully by the time we get the next
budget we'll actually have bought one
and that one then I think we can really
have full steam ahead on those things
thank you Ruth Cadbury
thank you Mr Deputy speaker and it was a
pleasure and intriguing to follow the
member for Amber Valley in fact he and
several members of his side of the house
do seem to have some doubts about some
elements of this budget and I'm sure the
chancellor is pleased that he's managed
to be in the post long enough to deliver
a budget and I'm sure he's hoping that
he doesn't manage to torpedo the economy
like his predecessor but Mr Deputy
speaker this is yet another conservative
government it's a conservative budget
that's failed to invest in public
services failed to address the cost of
living crisis failed to adequately
support businesses and most of all
failed to plan for the future today was
the chance to unlock Britain's potential
but it's just been a series of tidbits
which have been which are papered over
the cracks of their failure after 13
years in government their failure to
really deliver consistent and green
growth in September we saw the
government deliver a mini budget that
shook our economy and delivered a huge
shock to businesses and residents across
my constituency Meanwhile we're in the
middle of a mainly avoidable cost of
living crisis
real household incomes are due to fall
5.7 percent over the next two years the
largest fall of living standards since
comparable records began
and Mr Deputy speaker on businesses over
the past months I've spoken to so many
businesses locally and nationally who
are struggling or who want to grow but
are being let down by government either
because the government's incompetence or
because of sky-high energy bills or
delays in key decisions many are
family-owned businesses one I met last
week well in a pub uh they run a pub in
isworth their previous energy contract
ended in October they have no choice but
to be locked into a contract that is
three times uh that the price they were
going to be paying three times at their
energy costs for the next year they're
locked in a rate that could put them
under the energy bill relief scheme that
ends in March will it be of no help to
them due to the sheer scale of the
locked in rise and I'm not sure the
draft duty extension announced today
will be enough to help that Pub and when
I visited businesses on Chiswick High
Road they tell me that time and time
again just how broken our business rates
system is it's outdated on Fair and
hammering businesses when they mostly
need support the Federation of small
businesses uh chairs Martin mctague
today has just posted today's budget
will leave many feelings shortchanged
the government's lack of support for
small firms in critical areas is glaring
and not a lot of support extra from what
I could see from makeup K and the
British Chambers of Commerce so that's
why we need a labor government that will
support businesses and support workers
and invest in public services and
it's our economy economy growing
key to how government behaves towards
business is collaboration not
short-termism And Delay whenever I meet
with businesses Business Leaders I hear
example after example about the
government's inconsistency
the battle onshore wind turbines that
existed for more than that's existed for
more than a decade a ban that meant UK
firms were exporting wind turbines work
rather than building them for our own
energy grid we know the UK is falling
behind and ensuring that electric
vehicles and batteries are built in the
UK new plants that could provide
well-paid and skilled jobs here but the
conservatives have simply failed to plan
or invest
uh the CH the chief executive of the
Society of motor manufacturers has said
after the statement today there is
little here that enables the UK to
compete compete with the massive
packages of support to power a green
transition that are available elsewhere
unquote another uh another key they and
he is another key business leader who
doesn't agree that the chancellor is
removing obstacles that stop business in
investing as he promised today
and delays in confirming future
standards such as Vehicle Safety
standards mean delay in future
production decisions of course all this
stems from this government lacking an
industrial strategy
and inconsistency with other policies
where does pausing hs2 and cutting the
budget for walking and cycling sit with
reducing congestion on our roads and our
rail networks and Net Zero and investing
in jobs and Manufacturing
the chair of the infrastructure
commission Sir John armit said this said
that this lack of planning especially
around hs2 is and he said impacting on
the confidence and certainty that
business needs when making investment
decisions Mr Deputy speaker whether it's
a lack of housing or labscape space or
skills or capacity in the energy Grid
it's clear that the UK lacks the basic
infrastructure we need to grow our
economy businesses want to do the right
thing and want to invest in new
technology and Greener technology
like the industrial laundrette or the
retailer of green mopeds both are in my
constituency they want to grow they want
a shift to Greener technology but
they're not that uh and and and grow
their sales and grow their business but
they're not being given the tools to do
so and I see little if anything in
today's budget that encourages them so
for many of my constituents this budget
will simply continue the pain that 13
years of conservative governments have
brought for them underfunded Public
Services low growth Rising costs
families and businesses across my
constituency are struggling yet this
budget offers them nothing new oh sorry
I do apologize there is one new thing
there's the pre-announced free child
care places for one and two-year-olds
but I spoke in Westminster Hall a couple
of weeks ago on this subject will these
places be properly funded so that child
care settings are not going under will
it provide places for those children who
will benefit the most those whose those
whose parents aren't yet getting 15
hours a week regular work or those with
disabled children
so Mr Deputy speaker in conclusion this
budget does little to get this country
out of the Doom Loop of low investment
low growth yet high taxation
Giles Whatley thank you Mr Deputy
speaker and it's a pleasure to follow
the honorable lady from Brentford and
eisenworth this afternoon
um I'll start by saying that there are
many things in my on my right honorable
friend's budget that I welcome but I'd
like to mention first of all just too I
mean doubling the care relief threshold
giving 450 pounds at average tax cut for
qualified carers that is great news for
clacton clacton has an economy that is
based on care and uh tourism and we need
that incentive for care the 200 million
pounds for potholes they are a hole in
our budget and that'll be an enormous
help there too
um but one thing I would really like to
mention is the uh is the uh extension of
current tax relief for theaters uh and
that for another two years has made me
quite simply ecstatic I'm the chairman
of the appg on theater and the theaters
were the first to close by the very
nature of the way they work and of
course the lost to reopen and their
energy bills are soaring they're
struggling to get bums on seat and and
we can't
give up this great soft power offer of
ours that that goes across the globe
since the time of Shakespeare we have
exported the English language to the
world through theater and film and
television and the Performing Arts and
we must support them because I
personally have traveled the globe
taking a great theater to every corner
and it is a soft power that we mustn't
forget
um they just need help with their energy
bills now and I'll shout about that a
lot in the future now we pride ourselves
on being the party of low tax and high
growth we we pride ourselves on our
ability to look after taxpayers money
and it's worth saying it again and again
that it isn't our money isn't the
government's money it's not this House's
money it's the people's money the
taxpayers money and my right audible
found the chancellor stated earlier in
the week that um it was due to
conservative diligence which saved I
think it was 80 of the of the of fiscal
uh finances that were coming at the time
that we were able to afford to deal with
the pandemic not least the incredible
furlough scheme that saved many people's
jobs
but people need a break Mr Deputy
speaker as much as some people need time
off a good holiday perhaps visiting the
wonderful Sunshine Coast of tendering
they need a tax break a tax break for
growth with soaring energy bills called
caused by Putin's horrific war and
inflation which is making pay Rises
ineffective and running a home nearly
impossible for so many people need to be
paying out less if we allow the public
to hold on to more of their money what
do they do they spend it we all know in
this place that the economy goes round
and round that's what we must do the one
area I believe we must tackle is
outdated taxes business rates and
council tax are specters from the past
in my view decades out of date and not
collecting anything resembling the real
life impact for example two people in
the band D home will pay as much as four
people next door despite representing 50
percent less service use a shop can have
a greater tax burden far greater than
many online and Tech entrepreneurs who
could operate from very small spaces
indeed we need to grip these these
issues and governments have got them for
debt decades out of fair reform I'd be
delighted to give away I'm very grateful
Jim would he share my enthusiasm that
this government has tackled the social
injustice of those on
prepayment tariffs actually ending up
paying more than the rest of us so the
change that has been made to reduce the
cost of prepaid tariffs to the average
cost of everybody else will save those
people about 50 pounds a year does he
agree that is a really good step forward
Point indeed on our employees by
bringing it up and thank you very much
in in the in the middle of what I've
just been saying on those issues so so
so so what have we done so far on these
taxes well we pretend the current system
works by just adding pieces pieces on
um we increase corporation tax to the
private sector and and we add additional
precepts to local government all
together around the fact that these
outdated taxes no longer represent
anything of the reality that they're
supposed to Target so we mustn't just
tinker and tax and as we move forward we
must reform and renovate but the point I
wish to make here Mr Deputy speaker is
that whilst smaller business need the
financial assistance of paying less into
the state there are some companies who
can afford the opposite treatment
those companies that actually profited
from the pandemic must contribute to the
third of a trillion pounds debt we ran
up during that time this includes oil
and energy companies which are making an
absolute killing right now seeing
enormous and unprecedented profits
whilst at the same time deprivation in
my parts parts of my constituency has
not changed at all I'm always resistant
to the introduction of new taxes however
introducing a temporary levy on covid
profits here would correct in my view
and Injustice that we've all all seen
over the last few years and I hope that
my right honorable friend the chancellor
has taken this on on board and I know
from our meeting yesterday when I banged
on about primary primary care at clacton
hospital and I banged on again about the
railings the east of England Elian
Hawley that my honorable friends member
for waveney brought up earlier
um and the the chancellors are Now
Melting from those attacks that I would
keep giving him but he is very receptive
on the whole to the needs of clacton but
also to the country and I do actually
commend his budget thank you Chris Evans
thank you Mr Deputy speaker it's always
a pleasure to follow the honorable
gentleman who is Frozen in time for
those of us of a certain vintage as a
vicar who married to an extended little
puddling family I think it was around
the time Mr Speaker that you were we
first met when I was a little boy and
you were the candidate in the pontyprid
by-election I think we're also in our
age
whenever a minister is asked what the
government is going to do about the cost
living crisis the reply is often we are
taking tough decisions we already know
the tax burdens at its highest level
ever whilst inflation runs at 10.1
percent and interest rates stand at four
percent
this begs the question Mr Deputy speaker
just really who is bear in the brunt of
these tough decisions
is it the homeowners who are exiting
fixed rate deals or need to be faced
with new ones with higher rates with
little money left over to spending on
other Essentials is it first-time buyers
who feel ownership home ownership it's
just a pipe dream even if they cannot
afford a mortgage they worry that rents
could raise as landlords look to pass on
higher mortgage rates
maybe it is the carer who finds the
higher fuel prices have either eating
into their pay as they relied on private
transport to deliver vital services to
vulnerable people or is it those who get
paid on a weekly basis and struggle to
budget for their monthly direct debits
many people Mr Deputy speaker
the cost of living crisis is not a
political slogan but the reality of
their daily lives
it is those who are taking the tough
decisions not the government ministers
who are sent out to defend the
government week in week out
Mr Deputy speaker the UK economy's been
hit by a series of significant economic
shocks these include the change in our
trading relationship with the European
Union the covid pandemic and the sharp
rise in global Energy prices related to
Russia's brutal war on Ukraine and its
people
for the United Kingdom these shocks have
eroded the terms in which we trade with
the outside world the prices we can get
for the goods we sell have not kept up
with the prices we have to pay for the
goods we buy
the government position has made as poor
as a country the fall International
relington has manifested itself in a
rising the prices we have to pay for the
things we buy as consumers
the position was not held by the
infamous fiscal event last September
which saw the biggest program of tax
cuts in half a century when the
benefited the very wealthiest while
adding tens of billions to the national
debt and I see from today's announcement
your party opposite has not learned
what was the result of that fiscal event
the pound dropped to its lowest level
against the dollar since 1985 and the UK
is now the only country in the G7 to be
forecasted negative growth this year
that's right the new prime minister has
peddled the myth he will have inflation
in a year and we hear that from the
chancellor early on said it will be less
than a half this isn't the hope that
somehow people believe prices will be
halved as well that goes against
economic Orthodoxy when prices stay high
they very rarely come down and they
certainly won't be halved if inflation
is halved
yes of course very grateful to The
Honorable member I'm just interested
because if he looks at page nine of the
impact on house sales distributional
analysis the chart there shows very
clearly that the major beneficiaries of
this budget are those in the bottom
decile of earnings and then the graph
slopes downwards so that it is negative
for those who are in the deciles above
seven eight nine and ten a the most
well-off in the country therefore this
budget is a budget that very much helps
all of our constituents who are in fact
the least well off and that is the whole
point about public spending and Taxation
is in order to help our least well-off
constituents would he agree
I always admired The Honorable gentleman
when I first came to this house the very
first intervention I took was from The
Honorable gentleman where we talked
about high unemployment at the time and
I think he said something very long
along the same lines but I would urge
him to look at that graph again there
was a frozen threshold and I think there
is a real danger that we look into this
look at this look at the frame this
budget what's going to happen is always
happens Mr Deputy speak all these
budgets and I say this to honorable
gentleman we always have the Euphoria of
the budget speech by the chancellor it
is usually followed by being unpicked by
the media over Saturday and Sunday so I
hope that we can have a discussion on
Monday at some point about about the
same thing
how is families from this budget it's
families who are paying the price and
that appears to be a theme across all
governments economic plans just take the
development Energy prices and we're all
concerned about energy process this has
been particularly Stark in October as
the energy price guarantee was put in
place to moderate what would have been
an even higher increase in off gems
price cap the typical energy price bill
was nearly still twice as high as a year
earlier who knows what the government is
going to do after June household Energy
prices will not come down to previous
levels anytime soon and from a cost of
living perspective is the level of what
people must pay that matters energy
bills will continue to remain a
challenge many people particularly those
on Lower incomes once again I'm afraid
the evidence suggests the government has
not say they were working people and
have not made the oil and gas giants pay
their fair share
the story is similar for another
essential in life food the war before
the war Russia and Ukraine Supply
significant shares of global consumption
of agricultural products such as
sunflower oil wheat and barley with
disruption to these supplies prices
increase sharply over 2022. this has
driven up food prices and UK shops and
supermarkets these include the basics
that everyone has in the capital fridge
in some supermarkets a pint of milk
increased from 80 Pence to 95 Pence
pastors gone up from 45 Pence of 70
Pence and some brands of butter are up
to nearly five pounds or these only seem
like small increases when added up the
smallest of changes can make a huge
difference at the end of a weekly shop
every day people see for themselves see
this for themselves and not know how
they're going to pay for it
before this crisis we knew Food Bank
usage was on the right
between April 2021 and March 2023
Trussell trust UK distributed over 2.1
million emergency food Parcels to people
in crisis
it's an increase of 14 get paid in the
same period in 2019-2020
Mr Deputy speaker food is one of life's
Essentials we can't get away from that
we needed to live
and the fact that many people across the
country can no longer afford it afford
to pay for their food
is a disgrace in this 21st century
it is an issue I know has affecting my
constituents in this long deeply
the trade Union Council found that one
in five people in this line of missed a
meal are gone without food during this
present crisis according to Action for
Children 4 578 children were living in
poverty in my constituency in 2020.
we can no longer leave the hard-working
people Insurance country to go hungry
and we cannot talk with a budget that I
talk on the housing or the lack thereof
new mortgage rates are higher than they
were a year ago this means that about
one in ten households will see the
mortgage rate go off the shirt
if new mortgage rates Rise by three
percentage points as Market rates can
only suggest the typical monthly
interest rate will go up by just under
250 pound for everyone
however in this budget there is no
mortgage emergency plan
a no no plan for affordable housing like
we were promised
the people Mr Deputy speaker were being
affected are simply playing by the rules
working hard for little reward
the UK economy is suffering because of
the global energy price shock and a
decade of poor productivity growth made
worse by erecting huge barriers to trade
the EU
these circumstances are making everyone
poorer the consequences for low-income
households with children people with
disabilities and poor pensions
what is desperate needed is urgent
support targeted at the hardest hit
households plus the investment is skills
infrastructure and business finance to
rebalance the economy away from growth
from growth based on consumer spending
filled by Rising housing prices and
towards business investment and exports
this government can be characterized now
after 13 long years by low growth low
wages higher price higher prices and
government waste quite frankly it is
time for a change this country deserves
better Barry Gardner
thank you Mr Deputy speaker it would be
churlish not to welcome some aspects of
this budget the extra money yes
absolutely the extra money for child
care is it's not comprehensive it
doesn't recreate the life-changing sure
start of the last Labor government but
it will make a real difference to
parents of young children
to steal some of the proposals of my
honorable friend from Houston Sunderland
South to take credit for addressing
child care costs but then to delay
implementation of the policy to the
middle of the next year in time for a
labor government to pay for it
I welcome the action taken on prepayment
meters which will make a real difference
to some of the poorest families in our
country
but again what hotspot my honorable
friend and constituency neighbor for
Brent Central has been urging every
Chancellor since George Osborne to
resolve this inequality
and I welcome the action taken to
allocate 20 billion pounds over 20 years
for carbon capture use and storage but
again
foreign 13 years ago the incoming Tory
liberal government inherited 4 billion
already allocated to ccus and they cut
it yeah too often debate in Parliament
degenerates into set speeches the budget
debate is one of those occasions where
we really can take on each other's uh
speeches and respond to what's been said
and I listen very carefully Mr Deputy
speaker to the former leader of the
House the right honorable member for
Northeast Somerset
he attacked the chancellor and pointed
out the failures of his party to adopt a
consistent economic policy to lower the
overall tax take he said they should
have thought through the tax take policy
in a way that would actually work
and it's just a Pity that he wasn't part
of any government that could have done
anything about it but the question my
constituents in Brent North would ask
is work for whom
I've spoken before in this chamber of
the cues that stretched down the Ealing
Road in my constituency of Brent North
and then Round the Corner where I live
in Chaplin Road extending over half a
mile waiting for the food bank at the
sanatan mandir to open
the past 13 years
the economy has not been actually
working for them
it has been working for the individuals
who've managed to amass a pension pot in
excess of the 1 million and 60 000
lifetime allowance limit
after today
it will work even more for those people
as they can shelter even more money from
tax
the right honorable member for Northeast
Somerset also opposed what I thought was
a rather rhetorical question to the
house he asked who knows best how to
spend that money business
or the government
he didn't stay for an answer but my
constituents might have replied
best to achieve what
if it is to spend that money in such a
way as to maximize the return to their
shareholders then the right honorable
member for Northeast Somerset is correct
the answer is business
but if it is to spend that money in such
a way as to achieve the maximum public
good
then it is undoubtedly government by
using the Money Paid in tax to keep us
safe by paying our armed forces or to
keep us healthy by paying for our NHS or
to keep us Wealthy by investing in
education and apprenticeships so that
those businesses have the supply of
skills and labor that they need to make
that profit in the first place
I also support the government's desire
to boost Enterprise and to grow wealth
in our country
I understand the case for r d tax
credits even at the level of 100 but
they shouldn't contradict the
government's other objectives
if you pay those credits to
International companies like Amazon and
who'll pay no tax in the UK while
siphoning their profits out of the
country then it's not our economy that
you're growing
equally it makes no sense to be paying a
hundred percent of the cost of oil and
gas companies like BP and shell for
exploitation of new fossil fuel reserves
in the North Sea which will contradict
our Net Zero objectives these companies
are already making record profits on the
backs of Bill payers in the UK
I would ask the chancellor to put a
green filter on the r d tax credits yeah
at a time
when our household energy bills are the
highest in history
the office of budget responsibility
saying that real household disposable
income is decreasing by 4.3 percent this
year 5.7 over the next two
that is the largest decline since the
year before I was born
I'm Mr Deputy speaker I may feel like
one
but I am no spring chicken
the chancellor had four e's
but he missed out the most pressing e of
all
the environment the committee on climate
change has set out that we will not
achieve our Net Zero targets without a
strategic program to reform our
regulatory Frameworks and Market design
that galvanizes between
300 and
430 billion pounds of investment
and removes the barriers to the
contraction the construction of a new
renewable energy infrastructure
I'm afraid this budget simply does not
measure up
at Western
Mr Speaker I'm sorry it wasn't being
expected expected to be cool so early um
uh can I just say
um that uh when I
Mr probably didn't hear an interview
like I did with country Works radio back
in 2021 and I was talking about the
pandemic it was contrary BBC
um and I was talking about the pandemic
and I said inflation was something that
we should be really concerned about and
I said it could potentially raise up to
seven percent because I was towards a
local business box Factory bits so
picturesque picture frames they've seen
huge rises in the price of glass huge
rises in the price of cardboard Etc
uh spin forward a couple of weeks and
the pro the Prime Minister have done uh
the right honorable member for Uxbridge
was saying on Sky News uh people are
worried about uh inflation
um that their their fears should they're
unfounded
um now I'm not sure where the the Prime
Minister had his head at the time it was
in a a nice bucket or in the sand but
his Chancellor should have pointed out
to him quite what was going on because
it was really clear to businesses
certainly my constituency uh what was uh
going on and that was long before
Russia's illegal Invasion now uh it
wasn't just a case of uh the fact that
uh the price of gas was going to
increase uh from that that point but we
had no energy storage it's rather like
going into the the pandemic when we had
no PPE uh so we spin forward 12 months
we get a new prime minister a new
Chancellor we get a Kamikaze budget the
right honorable member for spellthorne
said uh intermediate in the the in
answer to my question straight after his
statement that I Was Fear mumbled and I
said to be around account now what
happened next the bank of England was
left to bail out this conservative
government Mr Speaker any other
organization the directors would have
been sacked after uh long before at this
point of 13 years uh if the shareholders
have been able to have their say so now
we find ourselves on a fourth I think
Chancellor and we hear that things are
getting better versus last October we
could hope that they were given where we
were if you stand back look at where we
are we have the lowest growth in the G7
I think even sanctioned Russia might be
ahead of us now the World Bank describes
us as having the weakest economy
um the medium-term forecast does not
look good inflation uh of course is also
one of the highest in the uh G20 it's
not rocket science how we seem to have
got there now there are some positives
in what the in the statement that we've
heard and particularly I applaud the the
idea of the uh the Enterprise zones
around universities uh I think those
investment zones will be a a very good
thing and I would actually welcome more
because I do believe they can be dynamos
of a new economy now on the cost of
living
um I think the extension that the energy
price guarantee I I certainly uh welcome
that and the parity for charges for
prepayment meters uh with those who pay
by direct debit that is long overdue but
the impact on real wages we've we've
we've heard that real household incomes
are going to fall by 5.7 over the next
two years and that will be the uh the
worst performance since records began 60
years ago now compare that to France uh
where the average French family will be
10 richer than those of us in the UK and
Germany is 20 richer now both those are
working approximately 20 percent less
than us that is the social Scandal of
our time at the same time we see
mortgages in the wake of the Kamikaze
budget of last year average in increase
of two thousand pounds on a variable
rate mortgage since then now when we
look at income tax threat the Frozen
thresholds that the chances have
previously announced we have a 500 pound
increase uh for those on basic rates and
a thousand pounds increase for those on
a higher rate
um on child care I welcome some of those
moves but I I absolutely believe that
our proposals are a lot better uh one of
my care providers a nursery rather in
the constituency texted me earlier to
say this equates to 26 Pence per child
per hour it won't make a blind bit of
difference and on pensions well I just
don't understand who is going to be the
great beneficial of these what
percentage of the population will
benefit going from one point what is it
zero six million uh to 1.8 million uh it
sounds like the super wealthy in our
society so a big win for the wealthiest
uh maybe more help for Bankers but less
for ordinary Folk
um it won't do anything I believe to get
retired Consultants back into the NHS
that's just too too late let me just
turn to business corporation tax I will
not give away uh because we're short of
time Corporation taxes is rising to 25
from 19 George Osborne told us uh we had
to reduce it from 29 and that would
ensure that we increased our revenues
um because people would be more keen to
pay at a lower rate well it doesn't seem
to be necessarily uh transpired compare
that to I think what France and the US
are much higher levels than we are today
so questions of the minister how much
tax have we lost in revenue on
corporation tax since
2014. uh the the
um the other thing that's striking about
this is the lack of a coherent
industrial strategy and I want to just
focus on the automotive sector uh we
have just one small gigafactory in the
UK versus five already existing in
Germany with five uh already planned
that's in the labor have already gone on
record saying that we want to build a
and those investment decisions are
ebbing away from us we've heard about
Ford divesting out of dungeon Dunton uh
Tesla who had the opportunity to come to
the UK but said they wouldn't because of
the brexit decision we need companies
like northvolt and others to come invest
in the UK as my cause at the smmt said
there's little that enables the UK to
compete in Mass with massive packages of
support to power and bring the truck a
power green transition that are
available elsewhere and make UK Echo
this because we have energy bills which
are approximately 100 higher than the
average of those major European nations
as small businesses Mr Deputy speaker
once again has been ignored a pub and
work has been in touch to say that he
would just have to close he can't afford
it another one in lemington has said
well that's it we're going to close in
April now there was just nothing for us
and the FSB support that saying that uh
they believe all small businesses have
been shortchanged by today's budget the
point backed up by the Chamber of
Commerce as well and I didn't hear
anything for the self-employed but maybe
I am mistaken Miss Deputy speaker in
summary I think this has been another
budget once more with uh no or next to
no uh mention of a proper coherent
industrial strategy we've heard a lot
about potholes but you know they cut 400
million pounds from the highways
maintenance pothole budget and then they
announced miraculously a 200 million
pound budget today it all seems a little
bit Paul Daniels to me
um and Ordinary People and small
businesses have been left shortchanged
up by the chances announcements uh this
this lunch time uh but somehow the major
promise from today's budget is a pension
Bonanza for the very wealthy and therein
lies the truth of this budget Mr Deputy
speaker it is for the very few
okay do good thank you Mr Deputy speaker
it's the thinnest of gruel in another
Westminster budget one in which the
people of Scotland will benefit very
little all the people of Scotland
whether they're self-employed employed
or in need of State support and there
was one nugget of Truth one kernel of
wisdom in the Chancellor's remarks
earlier on today and that is the
independence is better than dependence
something we've known on these benches
for quite some time and I'm glad that
the chancellor is now able to accept
that and we heard later on Mr Deputy
speaker from the member a right
honorable member for wokingham and
Berkshire trumpeting literally
trumpeting the success of Irish GDP
growth investment dynamism and
entrepreneurial entrepreneurialism
forgetting of course that if they were
still Shackled to the union of Great
Britain and Ireland they would have
their me to do no such thing to empower
their people in no such way and to
develop that growth not one bit the
first thing I'd like to touch on
is the absence of any increase or
inflation to the um public sector
mileage rate which was set in
2011. it would have been very well
received by the hundreds of thousands of
ordinary working people and this
government never tires of talking about
ordinary working people I assume they've
met some at least once or twice it'd be
very well received by them to have that
increased to something more reasonable
45 Pence doesn't begin to cover the cost
of inflation much less the cost of
Motoring and that should have been put
up to around about 60 Pence this
government last year removed the rebate
on red diesel for plant and Machinery
contributing to an already dire
situation with construction inflation
and putting a real millstone around the
neck of capital investment of the
Scottish government and Scottish
councils and the same in Wales and the
same in England however the difference
is that the treasury Pockets the benefit
for it on English capital investment
programs but they also pocket the
benefit of it with Welsh and Northern
Irish and Scottish capital investment
programs yet another example of given
with one hand and taken away with the
Westminster sleight of hand
on defense Mr Deputy speaker you can see
on page 31 the combined resource and
capital uh Dale budgets are 51.7 billion
for 24 25 this government and this Tory
government likes to March around with no
shortage of puff in their chest talking
about being the Guardians of defense and
the vanguards of defense and the
European theater well I've got news for
them Mr Speaker because they're claiming
to want to uplift the budget to 2.2
percent 2.25 of GDP well that would give
on 23's projections a 58 billion pound
budget they say at some indeterminate
point in the future they'll increase it
place it to 2.5 percent that would be 65
billion for defense that would please
some of their Critics on their own
benches the problem they're going to
have of course though is that Germany
has committed 2 and 2 percent of the
German GDP is 72 billion so this
government has consigned the UK's
Defense Force to playing second fiddle
on the European stage I understand the
Chancellor's concern because the waste
that the mod is guilty of is absolutely
eye-watering but the problem that
they've now got
is that to keep a the Secretary of State
for defense and job they've had in his
job they've had to give him some
concession but it's not enough and it's
quite clear that the secretary of state
is writing rhetorical checks that the
chancellor won't cash
um on pubs there's a public health
emergency Mr Speaker in in with alcohol
misuse in this country and a lot of that
stems not from pubs or restaurants but
from supermarkets off sales where people
buy large quantities of low value and at
low-cost alcohol and consuming and
unsupervised way day after day
developing extremely damaging habits now
welcome what the government genuinely
welcome what the government has
introduced in terms of their amendments
to duty on draft products but what they
need to do is go further and take a
holistic View and cover the Specter of
Duty vat rates and energy costs on pubs
all of us in this place have got
extremely valuable pubs to our
communities in our constituencies and I
think we should all realize that when
they're gone they are gone and they're
not coming back so proper fiscal
intervention to support pubs is a the
right thing to do and failing to do it
is Pennywise at pound foolish so I think
um I and my colleagues are continually
harassed in this in this Parliament
Scotland is habitually derided by the
superior patronizing forces of unionism
and and
maybe maybe there are no gentlemen
what's going to be but in reality with
16 years of government the the progress
that we have made under the constraints
of devolution are genuinely uh
remarkable and I'm hugely proud of those
achievements even though they can't be
accepted in here by labor lib Dem or
Turi and in Scotland's the principal
destination you know they enjoy the
rhetoric they're less keen on facts Mr
Deputy speaker a Scotland's a principal
destination for form direct investment
in the United Kingdom Scotland is the
highest productive area in the United
Kingdom out of 12 regions with the
exception of London and the south east
if you live in Scotland and you're a
medium income employer then you will pay
less tax in Scotland than you pay in the
rest of the United Kingdom if you live
in Scotland and abandy property you will
pay 600 pounds less council tax than you
will in England England's tax on ill
health of 9.35 for a prescription is
funded in Scotland 65 more police
officers in Scotland pay a hundred
thousand population
226 more nurses and midwives in Scotland
per head of population The Honorable
member from Harrow West isn't in his
place just now he was very concerned
about how hard it is in England to get a
GP appointment well we've got challenges
in Scotland so I don't know how bad it
must be in England because we've got 79
95 GPS per hundred thousand there's only
79 in England and business rates kick in
at 12 000 in England and 15 000 in
Scotland so in summary Mr Deputy speaker
we have achieved these gains to the
benefit of our communities our
Enterprise and our population in
Scotland despite this Union imagine what
we could do when we're rid of it yeah
yeah it goes
13 years of Tory government have seen a
sustained fall in living standards
across my constituency accelerated by
the disastrous mini budget and the trust
mortgage premium and my constituents in
Warrington have frankly had enough of a
cost of living crisis made in Whitehall
it is no longer just those on the lowest
incomes feeling this hurt but many who
would have previously considered
themselves comfortable on the kind of
salaries you could once raise a family
on we've seen widespread industrial
unrest as our Junior doctors nurses
posties lecturers Railway workers
barristers police and more have seen
their pay and living standards squeezed
while the government tries to balance
the books on their backs
the obr reports that living standards
are expected to fall by six percent this
fiscal year and next as inflation
outstrips growth the largest two-year
fall since ons records began
at my weekly surgeries and doorstep
surgeries across Warrington North the
picture is a depressing one and this
budget doesn't meet the ambition we have
for ourselves as a town or for the
country
the budget commits 400 million pounds to
leveling up Partnerships in a range of
key Tory marginals but there's nothing
for Devolution to Warrington and
Cheshire in fact any Devolution
settlement support is contingent on a
mayoral model or directly elected leader
according to
0.3.118 in the statement some think
there is no local appetite for why do we
need another layer of politicians and
bureaucracy to be able to make more of
our own decisions about our local
priorities when our existing structures
are working
with the second biggest nuclear
Workforce in the country in Warrington
North I welcome the news on the green
taxonomy changes for the nuclear sector
that the all-party Parliamentary group
for nuclear energy I co-chair has been
calling for but I'm already getting
whatsapped memes by constituents in the
nuclear sector about the SMR competition
firstly because far from being new this
was already tried and scrapped by George
Osborne in 2016 and secondly because of
concerns about the UK's competitiveness
in this sphere against for example GE
Hitachi which has just seen a major
pre-licensing milestone in Canada
potentially putting our Sovereign SMR
sector at disadvantage in such a
competition
having read through the red book in the
time we've had available I can't see any
money allocated for Great British
nuclear either for all the Chancellor's
warm words about its importance in
launching it today
further I welcome the support for child
care costs
you is not just affordability but
availability and the time scales for
this support will mean many children
will be in school before their parents
see any benefit at all
there's also nothing for social care
which doesn't help those families caring
for parents and children or
grandchildren at the same time to get
back into the workforce
this isn't nearly good enough it
especially at a time when my local
Council are having to spend 70 percent
of their budget on statutory care
services a situation that will only get
worse over time with an aging population
with increasingly complex care needs
the announcement of reforms to the
medicine's approval process is welcome
as it means patients should receive
access to emerging medicines including
psychedelics sooner than they might have
otherwise
MDMA and cybin are due to receive FDA
approval in 2024 having already been
approved later this year in Australia so
hopefully UK patients will gain access
simultaneously or soon after
in the meantime however we will continue
to lose on average 18 people a day to
suicide and our veterans and victims of
crime will continue to suffer needlessly
with PTSD meaning the funding the
chancellor committed today to the office
for Veterans Affairs and to the suicide
prevention voluntary community and
social Enterprise fund could be working
a lot harder and going a lot further if
we would only commit as colleagues
cross-party have been calling for for
drug scheduling policy based on evidence
rather than stigma misinformation and
political expediency
I also welcome the measures to support
Leisure centers which I recently LED on
a German debate on the need for and the
differential for draft beer which will
be very welcome by the pubs appg I chair
but while there are aspects I welcome
this budget has been very lacking in big
Vision ideas to get our country moving
inflation halving doesn't mean price is
coming down but only Rising more slowly
and fundamentally without a proper pay
rise for the country too many of the
essentials of everyday life will still
be out of reach for too many and our
local food banks and charity sector will
still be stretched far beyond capacity
there was an opportunity to reform the
apprenticeship Levy to make it work for
businesses industry and for apprentices
themselves but instead this return ships
proposal no one asked for is what we
have instead an opportunity missed there
was also an opportunity missed to
improve our bus sector the most used
form of public transport in the country
an opportunity to do more for us more
businesses with the FSB calling this
budget irrelevant to the 5.5 million
strong small business community
an opportunity to radically reform
business rates to bolster our high
streets
but the biggest missed opportunity of
all was the failure to make those who
can most afford to pay to do just that
there are a number of companies and
sectors including an oil and gas who
have made more profit over the last few
years than they know what to do with
while my constituents will be facing the
highest personal taxpayer than in
decades little seems to have been done
to tax those giants with the broader
shoulders more
sticking plasters aren't enough and the
government could have gone much further
and be much fairer in this budget
politics is about priorities and we can
see from this budget today that the
people's priorities have been overlooked
and millions will understandably be
feeling shortchanged as a result
mccaskill thank you Mr Deputy speaker as
other speakers have said I think there's
always something in a budget to commend
and some things that are admirable it's
uh the totality that requires to be
looked at and it's not simply the
headline figures that are announced by
the chancellor but indeed the drilled
drill down figures that will come around
in days to come that will be the
analysis of it carbon capture and story
just to be welcomed but the question
remains why not in Scotland and in the
North Sea that has something like 30
percent of Europe's capacity given the
geology of it prepayment meters are
quite rightly being levied that has been
mentioned by many speakers but why
hasn't that been done to date all it
required was a letter to off-gym
directory in ministerial letter that
could have been sent and should have
been sent before winter came because
it's still snowing in Scotland and
people are freezing and this should have
been dealt with long time ago as well as
other aspects of energy that haven't
been touched upon upon new technology
again another welcome announcement
between previous announcements on
hydrogen or on long long storage battery
duration the situation there is we have
over 17 percent of our turbine capacity
in the UK not just in Scotland turned
off not because the winds aren't turning
but because the National Grid doesn't
have capacity there is a solution to
that it is to store it it is to use it
and that's why you need battery storage
that's why you need hydrogen and as we
see with the conflict in ammonia you can
also get an ammonia from it the conflict
in Ukraine so those aspects should have
been considered but as I say this has to
be looked in the round and I think what
the budget does show is that there is
wealth in the society what I want to
consider is fear that wealth is coming
from and to whom it is largely going
because its situation remains that
Scotland is energy rich and yet the
majority of Scots are going to find
themselves fuel poor the oil and gas
wealth that we were told in 2014 was all
but gone and simply a burden upon tour
Scotland if we went independent as now
crops in being used with a great respect
by the chancellor of exchecker being
added to that is a situation of offshore
wind
and yet at the same time fuel poverty
still continues to spare our Scotland
not just rural but urban areas there was
no mention of unregulated fuels and yet
the situation remains at some eight
percent of people in Scotland are
dependent upon unregulated fuels where
the cost has been even greater than that
of gas and electricity and no steps have
been taken to address it there's been no
steps taken to address those who live
off the gas grid and where poverty is
worsened in terms of fuel poverty
because they're either required to
depend upon unregulated fuels or in
urban areas because they are often in
1960s multi-story flats or other
tournaments where gas cannot be provided
that depend upon all electric supplies
that are usually uh most costly and
indeed ineffective in terms of providing
warmth what Arrangements have been made
for them why couldn't the alternative
fuel uh funding be made available for
them because they are in clear need and
that should have been extended so we
needed support for those unregulated
fuels and indeed for those who are all
electric and we're living in urban and
indeed rural deprived areas and there
remains a question of the social tariff
that has been trailed by the government
but we still not have seen an
announcement that is something that's
provided by other countries across the
world especially in the European
continent and it's about time that we
actually saw a social tariff delivered
here for those who are most vulnerable
in terms of support for the poorest we
aren't seeing that we are seeing very
wealthy pensioners provided for but just
earlier this week there was a meeting at
which research was provided by the
Joseph and Russell Roundtree trust and
indeed the Trussell trust pointing out
that in this country we have always had
since the Inception of the welfare state
the belief that there should be a safety
net below which nobody should go and it
was initially supplementary benefit is
now meant to be provided by Universal
Credit whether you're in work on receipt
of a pension and yet the situation that
we face now in our society is that it is
not providing the Basic Essentials for
humans to survive the Basic Essentials
leaving aside the need for people to
kneel with emergencies the deal to deal
with a debt crisis that might arrive it
just simply doesn't allow for day-to-day
living the shortfall is 35 pound per
week for a single person 66 pounds for a
married couple the fact of the matter is
people in this country are going under
and yet the only people being rewarded
out of this budget are those who have
the greatest wealth whether to invest
further in pensions or pass it on to
those who will benefit the wealth that
they've accrued their society has to be
judged by how it looks after its poorest
and most vulnerable and all of this of
course occurs in a country that is
energy rich we are talking about Scots
probably the majority of Scots over half
of our population being in fuel poverty
whole areas are going to be existing in
fuel poverty and yet Scotland's energy
wealth is being used by the UK to make
the rich richer Scotland's wealth is
being extracted and our people are being
left bereft it's not just oil and gas
that I mentioned earlier let's look at
what's anticipated to come from the
renewable energy because I did ask basis
questions about what energy was going to
be provided from Scotland South of the
Border I am told that in the present
moment What's going south is 35
terawatts now I have to say and confess
that I had to investigate what a
terawatt was because I've heard of a
kilowatt I've heard of a megawatts and
I've handled my gigawatt I didn't know
what a terawatt was a terawatt is 1
billion kilowatts the average household
in Scotland uses 4 000 kilowatts per
annum Scotland is sending 35 terawatts
South and by 2030 beasts anticipate that
Scotland will be providing
124 terawatts that's
124 billion kilowatts of electricity and
our people are freezing as I speak
people are unable to power their homes
our energy is being taken you took our
oil and gas you're seeking to take her
offshore and onshore wind it is simply
unacceptable this budget enriches those
who are already rich in England that is
exploiting the natural benefit and
Bounty that Scotland has and it isn't
further impoverishing the poor people in
Scotland as as the poor people across
the United Kingdom
very much Karen Smith thank you for I am
on the optimistic side of the spectrum
that Chancellor was talking about today
I would welcome the uh prepayment meters
and and some support for suicide
prevention but the sensible most
sensible thing he said today was the
contribution that those of us in our mid
50s can make to the economy but overall
frankly is truly astonishing that
knowing how many thousands of pounds
people are worse off after 13 years of
this government that with the low growth
that we are now further anticipating
that that will continue now for another
two years this government completely
lacks ambition for the country but
particularly lacks ambition for young
people there was nothing in this budget
for young people particularly nothing
around housing help there was failure to
reform the apprenticeship Levy as
promised and that's still not doing
enough for people particularly from
disadvantaged backgrounds they have
broken their promise to fix social care
the Stark reality is that over 150 000
people have died waiting for State
social care 57 000 people would have
received support and they now will not
the chancellor himself has promised far
less funding for adult social care than
he himself recommended as chair of the
select committee I welcome that people
who are facing the cost of living crisis
will have that fuel Duty cut but he has
made some very clear choices at six
billion pounds to to to to that
particular initiative plus the
additional billion for the pension rise
that 7 billion would have gone some way
towards meeting that social care
commitment that he himself wants to see
and what happened to the Health and Care
Workforce plan that was so widely
trailed clearly that didn't get past
himself in the treasury for the thing
that he's already committed was
expecting it sometime soon now child
care providers are at risk of collapse
leaving parents struggling not only with
the cost of child care but unable to
find child care in the first place
extending hours is simply not enough
Child Care provision is not just about
babysitting Services it is about the
wide to education of those children
President Biden in America has put
forward a family support package in
Australia the labor leadership have
looked at child care completely
different they say an economic reform
about inclusion and growth it's not a
babysitting service an economic reform
that delivers benefits to two
generations of Australians the best
start in life for children flexible
support for modern families and a boost
to productivity and participation what
we've had today meets doesn't meet those
challenges and it looks like it doesn't
even meet the basic that they were
asking for now in Bristol at the weekend
I was pleased to join uh by the Bristol
women's commission about the care and
economy and how the care and economy can
add to our productivity looking at
carers infrastructure improving working
conditions pay for those and skills for
those low paid workers that's what this
government needs to be doing I commend
the work of the Bristol women's
commission unfortunately it looks like
the green party in Bristol are not
supporting them going forward in the
future I hope party changed their mind
about that because they're doing some
fantastic work
the apprenticeship Levy is a massive
failure Mr Deputy speaker starts are
falling backwards the cohorts made up
mainly of people in senior positions 13
of degree level apprenticeships are
coming from neighborhoods in the bottom
fifth of devils of deprivation and twice
as many coming from the most
disadvantaged Advantage backgrounds that
isn't good enough and the new
traineeship or the returneeship thing
the shiny new thing we've seen today I'm
afraid the Department of Education has
been a dreadful failure on
apprenticeships and the idea that they
can help people come back is not
something that we think we can really
believe but overall it's definitely
speak and there is nothing in here for
the west and the Southwest again we have
been completely ignored by this
government transport is a critical issue
for us in Bristol South we can only
support our move towards the climate
crisis and support Net Zero with a
functioning transport system and this
government simply doesn't care many of
my constituents rely on buses the
elderly and young people going to
education need bus service and with the
end of the bus recovery Grant my
constituents would like to know what on
Earth the government is going to do to
support them it looks like the only
mention of the West country is in the
section when about Devon when we're
going to get some money for the potholes
literally the only mention of the West
and the Southwest is that I can find in
this entire shiny document and it's
because the chantering from the other
side I think is talking about their MPS
frankly if that wall of Tory MPS across
the West country that's the best they
can come up with well I look forward to
them disappearing because something
could have much more could have happened
we are a good function economy 116 Pages
nothing for Swindon Bristol filton
Plymouth Stroud Truro Falmouth
absolutely nothing a complete waste of
our time for the southwest and the
sooner they go the better
thank you just a deputy speaker and it's
a pleasure to follow my my friend from
Bristol South and her analysis of
nothing for Bristol South I feel the
same for York and York Central 13 years
and the obr is hardly complementary
productivity dragging growth the lowest
in the G7 and the pace of change far too
slow and of the last 13 Wasted Years the
last six months have been the hardest
for families businesses and communities
13.4 people now living in poverty and
now with sanctioning regimes to become
more brutal and ill people forced into
work we know who is paying the price for
this budget and for those who got us
through the last few years the health
workers the teachers the Care staff and
so many more the longest paid squeeze
for 200 years where is their pay rise
and well household budgets are set to
Fall by 5.7 percent well 5.1 million
will be hit by stealth taxes these are
the people who have worked to get us
work their guts out so over the last few
years and yet it is the top one percent
who have gained they are paying for the
chaos in Downing Street which has been
which has besieged our economy take
brexit now costing the economy 100
billion in Lost output every year as
Britain is becoming increasingly
isolated and irrelevant to take the
44-day Prime Minister wiping 30 billion
of the economy overnight and with our
Global reputation our interpreters our
influence to attract investment jobs and
the very best from across the globe
stymied 13 years and Britain isn't
booming it's burning burning with the
injustices that we see each day in our
constituencies our NHS grinding to a
halt without the staff to heal the sick
second homes and airbnbs for the rich
while ordinary families are locked out
of home ownership or even a place to
rent yet nothing to ignite a new
generation of house building in today's
budget if these benches were not
fighting each and every day highlighting
the prepayment Scandal where the very
poorests were forced to pay the most for
their energy the Injustice would have
just continued I'm glad the chancellor
has at last heeded and I trust the
compensation is also on its way or take
swimming baths closing their doors as
the float never came in time while the
Prime Minister spent tens of thousands
on his own and again we have had to
fight and at last the the life the
lifeline has been thrown and with child
care it is right to invest in our
children but the ratios matter because
quality matters but with the cost of
child care in my community
it's stripping parents and children of
any opportunity the average monthly cost
of child Kevin York is
1083 pounds 33 well the average wage is
just 1
54.71 of wages spent on a service that
enables parents to access work today's
announcement takes us forward but we
need a Workforce plan and ensure that
those working in the sector many women
receive a wage that reflects the value
of their job it is always the same with
the toys too little too late it matters
and it matters to my community in York I
look at Great British Railways on
hearing about Great British nuclear and
another competition which would
accelerate investment in Britain's Rail
supercluster and place York back on the
global map for rail the competition was
launched
launched over a year ago and the
announcement over nine months late still
to come and of course it has an impact
on the 5 500 jobs in advance and digital
well in our city nervousness that it may
not come for political expediency
elsewhere but had it landed in time we
would already be accelerating the the
economic research and Innovative
opportunities as well as getting our
trains running and take bio Yorkshire
Britain's largest Green New Deal
transitioning to a sustainable future
while creating 4 000 Green Collar jobs
outskilling 25 000 people generating
income through startups and spin-outs
while cutting carbon and landfill and
returning value back to the treasury
creating new insects and hemp
Technologies
and quite frankly one of the most
globally transformative projects around
first raised in this house two and a
half years ago and we are still waiting
waiting years for this government to
make up its mind how to fund it all the
time opportunity wasted and our planet
melting and burning we have our creative
sector bore out of Exile stories making
York a UNESCO city of media arts and
leading the sphere in generating digital
creative jobs and digital film games and
creativity but where is the funding
opportunity well brilliant artists
technicians and and so many more are
waiting for the chance to help Britain
back on its feet not a penny for your
sides and Technology superpower
and of course we have York Central a
major opportunity for investment a site
which is begging attention and yet again
the government pass it by Too Little Too
Late Three brilliant clusters that
government should be fighting to invest
in three brilliant projects which will
not just level up my city by creating
the desperately needed jobs in
post-industrial York but will benefit
the region the country and Tech science
and climate mitigation around the world
in York we think big we plan hard we
build strong relations and Partnerships
attract the very best brains and
determine the greatest opportunities but
we have a government that does not back
these opportunities of our young people
as we have shown in the past when people
put confidence in Europe we go far in
what we achieve instead we have seen
nothing today the next generation is
losing hope they are losing the chance
to do something special the treasury is
losing income and ultimately my
community is losing the chance to create
the next generation of jobs in our city
that are desperately needed to close the
ever-growing inequality
and while some will be breathing a sigh
of relief as they scoop funding for
investment zones York has been left with
nothing in this budget to enable our
well-planned investment opportunities to
flourish this decision fails the people
of my city who are fighting for a decent
job a decent home and a decent future
today feels like government have missed
the chance once again aim below the bar
look down instead of up and reverted to
type dishing pots of money out here and
there in desperation to win the next
Generation next general election not the
Next Generation Well the next gen
general election is coming and the next
generation is rising it is their jobs
their hopes their Planet their dreams
and their future they are clear and they
they have had enough let's have that
general election and let's have a Labor
budget
thank you Mr Deputy speaker
this is I would describe a bit of a
Stockholm syndrome budget after such an
appalling set of budgets that we've had
13 years of the failed austerity
experiment started by the Tories and
liberal Democrats and then of course the
latest mini budget it is tempting that
the captors would say thank you for some
of the peanuts that have been thrown
peanuts such as child care but even then
the measures won't come in fully for two
and a half years hopefully by that time
this shambles will be long gone in
Brighton we of course have one of the
lowest payments for child care from the
government scheme but we have one of the
highest costs because of an historic
Injustice in the way that the money is
calculated this will not help this
budget will not help those child care
workers it will not save
the current
um
places that are up at the nurseries that
are up for closure from the green
Council because it will not increase the
money and the wages and the
professionalism of our sector what is
clear is that despite a few giveaways
this budget will still see household
incomes fall by 5.7 one of the largest
falls in the lifetimes of our
constituents
big business
will of course receive huge incentives
for investment
but they will not be focused on green
investment there will be no focus on
Cooperative businesses as the
Cooperative party has called for and in
fact the Federation of small businesses
say I quote they cannot hide their
disappointment
and that this budget was
wide of the mark and irrelevant
a budget that is irrelevant for small
businesses is a very dangerous budget
indeed
the chancellor said that he would save
labor the bother of reviewing business
tax
but then made no mention of business
rates
a regressive tax a regressive tax which
punishes our high streets the help for
cast bear will be welcome
but the problem in our pubs is not the
tax
on beer that is pulled from the pump
it is business rates it is land values
and is planning laws which allow
speculative breweries to sell pubs and
Chuck out landlords because they get
better amounts
in for other uses
and the reality is that our Leisure and
nighttime economies will be crippled by
Rising fuel bills and they are being
offered apart from the Welcome Leisure
Center relief no protection whatsoever
the failure to bring down energy bills
will affect our constituents and is a
failure also of ofcom
and of course of the horizontal
privatization which means that it's
illegal for British gas to sell to its
own customers the price that it
generates energy act this is madness it
allows speculation and profits to win
out rather than hard Ordinary People and
there is no benefit there for them
but it is not just businesses of course
that will suffer as we know the
government has only last month had to
announce their scheme for residential
customers who are on business tariffs so
that they get the 400 pounds support as
the business tariffs will no longer be
cast
all those people will have to pay an
uncapped amount for their energy bills
many of them are the poorest in our
communities because they live in hmos
and blocks are flat some of them in fact
pay on pre-meter payments but because
they are paying on Commercial pre-meter
payments to their landlord and not to
the energy supplier the welcome benefit
for prepayment meters direct from the
energy supplier will not be extended to
the cap on prepayment meters of people
who are praying to the landlord or on a
commercial supplier this is a tragic
Miss
of this budget
the latest
but the latest areas of course are also
problematic of Investments because there
are no real Investments on the green
sector Germany is proposing 5.2 of its
GDP for green transformation the UK 1.2
in America we have seen the inflation
reduction act and France has pledged
billions to get to Green steel we are
not even scratching the surface okay
some nice welcome war words on currently
the unproven nuclear reactors which I
hope will be proven they have nowhere
have they been proven at commercial no
I'm not gonna at commercial level
Britain should invest in them and roll
them out but as yet they have not been
the same with card note the same with
the same with carbon capture it is
welcome that investment has come but we
are yet to see it at full scale
um capacity and it was Labor that said
the investment should have come in 2010
and it was the conservatives that
stopped them so they are unproven
because conservative failures because
conservative failure to invest and
coming late to the party is no good for
anyone and of course let's be clear only
one third you can can continue making a
noise if you want keep going it is a
complete waste of your time one third of
our one-third of the poorest households
only one third of the poorest households
own a car whereas ninety percent of the
richest households own a car and so
whilst a freeze on the fuel
um escalator is good news for them the
fact that there is no subsequent freeze
on bus rail and other forms of public
transport means the rich benefit and the
poor get messed over again there is no
cap on Rail and if you don't realize
that it's clear that you're not really a
rail traveler are you but of course this
was a budget for the tax top tax payers
and not for normal people the pension
pots that they will now be able to save
and it could have been so different the
national insurance rate
and the upper earnings limit is in my
view a disgrace it is a disgrace that
people earning under 50 000 pay 12 on
National Insurance but people earning
over 50 000 pay only two percent on
earnings above that it is not only a
flat rate of tax which conservatives
usually advocate for it is actively
regressive it harms the poorest and
helps the richest and if that one change
has happened 30 billion at the most
conservative estimates would have been
raised 30 billion what could have that
been paid for well I can tell you one
thing social care another area that was
totally missed in this budget could have
been paid for out of that 30 billion
could have paid for all the social care
costs that councils currently are having
to pay up and down this country and that
would have freed our councils up to
invest in their communities as they they
should in Brighton that would have
equated to a hundred million pounds
every year in the pocket of Brighton
Council investing in our streets
investing in our roads we wouldn't need
a pothole giveaway we would have had our
own money to spend but instead the
conservatives failure to sort social
care means that it is being drained and
was there any mention really of
Education going forward yes some nice
giveaways some nice giveaways for higher
levels of Education in the lifetime
guarantee and already announced policy
might I add so not really something new
but there is no additional funding for
proper further education basic skills
maths functional skills GCSE a levels
those things that people actually at the
very bottom need yes it's good that
people who are going to achieve Higher
Learning will be able to draw down but
we need learning for all people and of
course in this budget the biggest thing
that comes into my inbox and my
letterbox is special educational needs
in the education sector and was there
any mention of more money into the awful
system that we have at the moment for
special educational needs not a jolt
those children will go without the need
without the care without the support
that they currently have and that is a
disgrace because every day that they go
without the education they need it is a
day of their potential that is being
squandered instead of course we also get
no movement on capital gains or unearned
income and we have now the situation
where landlords using company shells pay
little or no tax compared to hard
working Ordinary People it is wrong
morally that people who survive of
unearned income pay less tax than those
who have earned it because this budget
and this government is a government for
people who don't work hard but who
speculate who extract and who use Ponzi
schemes in the market to get money out
rather than actually building our
country up they take out this is a
budget of lost opportunities this is a
budget that we could have changed our
country and when they say technical
recession the reason they have to say it
like that is because everyone knows we
have a household cost of living
recession we have a household income
recession so yes it's a technical
avoidance of recession but the
day-to-day lives of people in this
country is worse and of course labor
would have done better we would have
supported businesses and the economy we
would have supported and tackled climate
change and of course we would have made
the lives of people better in our
communities of course after the last
budget it does feel that things could
have only got better but rather than
having some poor tribute act that is
getting all the notes wrong we need
things to get better with a labor
government move over and let's Let The
Grapes do it again we did it in 97 and
we'll do it again now
yeah
I beg to move the debate to be now
adjourned the question is that the
debate be now adjourned as many other
people say aye you know I think the eyes
have it the eyes have it it's about to
be resumed what day tomorrow tomorrow
Alex Davis Jones on a point of order Mr
Deputy speaker this morning doing
science Innovation and Technology
questions the Secretary of State
responded to a question from my
honorable friend the member for
Manchester Central around her concerns
over the use of tick tock on government
officials devices in her question my
honorable friend stated that three weeks
ago the Secretary of State said that
having Tick Tock installed on a
government device was a personal choice
now in response the Secretary of State
said and I quote what I actually said Mr
Speaker in terms of the general public
it is absolutely a personal choice now I
have since checked and in her interview
with political the Secretary of State
stated in response to a question
specifically about government officials
using Tick Tock that the use of the app
is a personal choice thing now I fear
the Secretary of State May have
inadvertently misled the house and as we
know the official report belongs to
Parliament and it is vital that our
record is true and accurate now I'm
hoping Mr Deputy speaker that you will
be able to therefore advise on the next
steps so that we can seek Clarity on
this issue which ultimately concerns all
of our national security yeah I'd like
to thank the honorable lady for giving
notice of her point of order ministers
are encouraged to correct any
inadvertently incorrect statements made
to the house as quickly as possible the
treasury bench will have heard the
honorable lady's point of order and I'm
sure that the secretary of state will
correct any mistakes if one has occurred
point of order Sammy Wilson
speaker I understand that next Wednesday
the government is to bring forward a
statutory instrument to the house in
relation to the storm and break
could I ask you to investigate the
legislative bases on which such uh an
order a set of instrument can be brought
forward
I'd like to thank the honorable member
for his point of order and the forward
notice of it whilst this isn't uh within
the power of the chair to do that and
the tabling of legislation in this house
there will be an opportunity tomorrow in
business questions for him to directly
ask the leader of the House what the
future business is going to be and under
what auspices that a statistry
instrument would or could be brought
forward if he wishes if he's unable to
do that tomorrow he could go to the
journal office and seek further advice
thank you very much but
thank you Mr Deputy speaker I Rise to
present the petition leading to driver
and vehicle licensing agency and Road
tax it was collected on behalf of my
Constitution Karen Wood from Bonus and
it's very hard as an issue of fairness
and equality as drivers in receipt of
standard rate Pitt are unique in that
they have to apply by post unlike any
other driver
the petitioners therefore request that
the House of Commons urged the
government to instruct the dvla to
permit all drivers to apply for Road tax
by whichever method is most convenient
to them and the petitioners remain Etc
petition driver and vehicle licensing
agency and Road tax
thank you
I beg to move to this house to do now
Joe the question is that this house do
now adjourn Dean Diana Johnson thank you
Mr Deputy speaker and I'm very grateful
to Mr Speaker for allowing this debate
this evening on the issue of
telecommunications infrastructure
I know it's been a very busy day with
the budget but this is an important
issue that my constituents in Hull and
residents across the country are
incredibly frustrated about
so today I want to address the Crux of
the problem which is that there is no
legal requirement for consultation and
Scamp procedures for the putting up a
telecommunication polls and digging up
Pavements to install fiber optic cables
in our communities members across the
house would undoubtedly be frustrated
and concerned if they looked outside
their window one morning to discover a
telegraph poll who exit at the end of
their Garden outside their front gate or
very close to their home without knowing
anything about it there would also be
incredibly annoyed to discover that
there was absolutely nothing they could
do about it because the current
legislation makes this situation
completely permissible
I will do yes I'm grateful to her for
giving way is she aware that this is not
only an issue that affects the city of
Hull it also affects the wider East
Riding of Yorkshire
new infrastructure is to be welcomed but
does she agree with me sensible and
sensitive installation is essential
so I'm grateful for that intervention
and I absolutely agree with what the
right honorable gentleman says and the
reason why there isn't that consultation
at the moment is because the law was
amended by the coalition government in
2013. so Telegraph polls being erected
by Communications Network operators for
the expansion of fiber to the premises
Broadband do not need planning
permission under the electronic
communications code conditions and
restrictions 2003 and the Town and
Country planning General permitted
development England order 2015 and under
the electronic communications code
regulations Broadband Street cabinets
new Telegraph polls and overhead lines
can be installed in any location without
the need for the prior approval from
local planning authorities or
consultation with residents I'm very
happy to give way The Honorable member
for giving away now thank you for
bringing this to the house because
actually it's a huge problem across
Harmony haslington does she agree with
me that it's also very frustrating when
constituents see for example open reach
digging up the roads when these these
Telegraph polls are being installed and
the question is there as to why these
the the the wires can't then go
underground rather than the telegraph
polls spanning across their properties
absolutely and I'm very grateful to The
Honorable lady for that intervention I
think that raises a very important
question why can we not get this
coordinated and I'm very happy to give
way to The Honorable gentleman as well
congratulations for Kingston upon hold
North for bringing this forward the
honor ready brings many things to this
house that are important this is one of
these issues as well and Northern art we
have a very clear process a very clear
planning process there's the involvement
of the councils uh and that kids it's
origin North down Council uh the plan
department will look at these things
there's also a role for the the
telecommunication uh confirms themselves
if they put um Telegraph polls they said
anybody's house that person hasn't a
right to object to that being there if
it blocks their view if it blocks our
targeted and and maybe even blocks our
sightings these things can happen so it
does the other and so therefore we have
a community a council involvement we
have a community involvement as well and
does your ability agree that when it
comes to addressing these issues to the
satisfaction of our constitutions which
celebrity is very very concerned about
then we need either a change in that
decision or clarification from the
minister yes what the honorable
gentleman said and the the changes that
were brought in in 2013 were introduced
only for five years but they have been
extended now indefinitely allowing for
the situation that we're all talking
about today so I just want to
concentrate on what this means for my
constituents So currently residents in
Hull are finding Telegraph polls being
erected around their properties and
sometimes on their properties without
any consultation process that allows
them to raise their concerns these polls
are cheap cumbersome and impact on the
value and aesthetic worth of people's
properties polls are often built in
close proximity to people's driveways in
their Gardens and outside their their
windows and often with wires hanging
down from house to house in each
Direction one of my constituents has
Muscular Dystrophy and a few years May
sadly need to use a wheelchair returning
from work one day she discovered a
telegraph poll had been erected outside
her front gate so close that if she ever
does need to use a wheelchair to leave
her house she will find it very
difficult due to that new poll another
constituent with a disability has had a
poll erected in the middle of his
driveway making access to his property
more difficult when getting his